foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book clubs
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and it make you more social
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
recitation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time oh my
God he just blocked yeah he did I'm
Blown Away the game is over
as the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan
the Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to
close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs for two chess Superstars
lying in wait until next time is now
Jan napam Nashi has methodically done
what he needed to do to get another shot
at the title the pressure to seize the
moment this time rests heavily upon him
again just feels like he doesn't want to
come back to the board when he knows
he's in trouble and he knows he's missed
something
dingley Ren knows firsthand with the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame you must be told
genius a beautiful finish from Ding and
the school's a level momentum swinging
in this match day of the day
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
foreign
the sun is out it's still pretty cold
but the action is heating up inside the
Saint Regis Hotel where chess history is
being written this is the playing Arena
where Jana abomishi and ding Lauren are
fighting it out in a 14-game match for
the ultimate dream to be crowned world
champion welcome everyone to our
coverage of game seven I'm super excited
to be your host today I'm International
Master Tanya sachdev alongside one and
only Grandmaster Daniel narodetsky and
well number six former CEO of chess.com
welcome guys such a big day going into
the halfway mark and Anish you've been
with us from the day one covering the
event how surprised are you to see the
way things have turned out in this match
oh yes indeed I've been here from the
start and oh what a treat so far so many
uh decisive games so many ups and downs
the plot is uh I've lost it I've long
lost the plot I'm looking forward to see
what was coming as next
yeah I think if someone had told me at
the start of the match that we'll have
four out of six decisive games I would
not have believed it Daniel do you
believe that we'll have one more going
into the second half
it's been an incredible match and it's
been an honor to be commentating it and
the craziest part is that neither of the
players is anywhere near the seven and a
half points that they have to reach to
claim the world championship Throne so
the best part about this Tanya is that
the best part of the match is still
ahead and I am so excited to be covering
it
absolutely agree with that usually this
is the time Daniel that we stopped
talking about how the match is heating
up how the games are getting more
interesting and more fighting but this
one has been explosive from the various
thought I mean if we just take a look at
the scoreboard this is the world
championship match we've had four
decisive results and what brilliant play
it was janapamnushi who drew first blood
in game two and then we had dingler and
leveling the score with an equally
beautiful game in around four Yan once
again took the lead in the match with a
convincing win in game five and game six
what a finish that was a tactical
Masterpiece by dingler and equalizing
the match Anish is that the most
beautiful finish you've seen in a world
championship match
oh definitely definitely one of them and
uh no it was an incredible game uh ding
started very slowly with the London
defense a very unassuming start he
didn't try anything concrete Jung
started drifting very early on he was
not familiar with the position and step
by step ding built up his advantage
and maybe Jan has some chances to defend
but in the end this incredibly beautiful
combination one for the ages and uh even
even Jan gave it a little smile of
approval and he had to extend his hand
what a game
it was an amazing game indeed I had a
break yesterday and I was grateful for
the extra hours of sleep but man oh man
was that an amazing game and each player
in their white games they've managed to
steer the game in exactly the direction
that they want to steer it uh Tanya will
discuss the kind of differences in the
player's Styles but when they've got the
white pieces they have taken each of
them full command of the game and
dingley ran managed to do that exact
thing in the previous game
are you going at it every
scene in the match it's been such an
exciting World Championship so far and
our man on the ground Mike Klein brings
us all the insights from Astana let's
head over to Mike
thanks guys and what a championship this
is turning out to be no Magnus no
problem because we've already got our
fourth decisive game out of six
dingleren played the first ever London
system in the history of the world
championship and it's turning out to be
like that old joke of the Scottish
weather if you don't like the score just
wait a day because it's bound to change
after the game John napomnishi had some
pretty Choice words about his own Play
here's what he had to say I guess I
played uh one of my worst games ever
uh so I mean like nearly every move was
I mean yeah it's hard to believe I think
everyone was bad and what about this guy
in a moment of spontaneity ding Loren
said he played the London system
deciding on that choice at the last
minute and at the press conference I
told him that Anish giri called him a
total genius on the chess.com live
broadcast here was ding's reaction to
anisha's quote yeah
actually yesterday I saw Hillary mark
he believes I I will tie the match
despite the I was lost yesterday so
thanks for his uh his confidence so here
we are not even halfway done and these
two Titans have already produced
seemingly two matches worth of wins
what's going to happen in round seven
can possibly ding Loren and janapam as
she keep it up and play their fourth
straight decisive game we're going to
find out for chess.com this is Mike
Klein inside the playing Hall in Astana
Kazakhstan
thank you so much for that inside mic
it's always amazing to hear from Astana
all the action that's happening there
and I've been loving the interviews the
players have been so candid Anish Guri
had a little smile on his face there
with the ding interview and that's
definitely a special moment it made me
smile as well but of course the most
unique thing about this world
championship has just been the kind of
bloodbot that we've seen with four
decisive games Anish how much of a
surprise is this it's been 25 years
since this happened last
yes indeed we are used to these World
Championship matches you know for them
to be very slow there are undecided
games here and there but they are
treated as something really special
Mostly players are playing it very
safely very cautiously a lot of draws
and it's not a surprise that we have to
go this far in history to find uh the
last time something like this happened
and uh I'm I'm really wondering is that
uh for foreshadowing of what's about to
come or will the players finally finally
come down and we will see uh some draws
um from today onwards
it's crazy Tanya that we have to go this
far uh to find a world championship
match this decisive uh unfortunately I
was alive uh in 1998 and even in 1996 so
thank you for uh making me feel old but
not only uh is it just a long amount of
time we've had to sit through an entire
Dynasty without a match like this the
entirety of the Magnus Dynasty all five
of his world championship matches didn't
feature anything like this and I'm not
blaming Magnus for it this is because
he's the best player in chess history
but uh For Better or For Worse I mean we
have had our money's worth in each and
every game this match even the draws
have been incredible
yeah I couldn't agree more with that
Daniel we've been treated to more than
what we could have ever imagined or
asked for yeah
and dinglerin making a big fight of
every single game they've traded so many
punches in the match so far and as you
mentioned Daniel that The Best Is Yet To
Come and if we take a look at their head
to head it is such a reflection of
exactly the action that we've been
seeing Anish these two have been so
close in their battles haven't been
played a bunch of times in the past
well as we had expected they are so
evenly matched and so the match is
indeed extremely close but since they
have such different strengths and such
different styles it is no surprise that
their trading blows when ding gets a
position that he understands better it's
a one-way traffic the same happens when
Jan gets his position on the board and
yeah the best you can hope for is the
match between two players of different
styles but same strengths and we have
one now
we do indeed and we see nepo on the
right side of your screen relaxing there
changing his sitting position over in
the rest uh area and indeed it's
important to emphasize that although the
players are evenly matched on paper
they're not really evenly matched in
their styles of play in fact their
styles of play couldn't be more
different and just to reiterate what I
said a little bit earlier the key for
these players in their positive decisive
games has been steering the game in the
direction uh that they believe
encompasses their greatest strength for
janapamnishi his black one and his white
win you get a more tactical position
with Dynamic chances for dingley Ren
positional Affairs grinded out positions
such as the one that he played in the
London system who will be able Tanya to
steer the game in their preferred
Direction that's going to be the
question I think going forward
very interesting Daniel very similar
strands but very different styles in
just a few moments moments England and
Jana punishi will step out of their
resting areas and walk into the playing
Arena at the Saint Regis Hotel in Asana
for game seven will it be an opening
that will suit ding or will it be a
middle game an aggressive middle game
suffering from that game six defeat did
have a rest day it do you think he got
enough sleep because I see him taking a
little bit of a nap there in his resting
area
yeah I remember the last time I saw Jan
like this in the resting area he lost
the game but he played with white pieces
then maybe he is doing it more often
maybe we just don't always get a peek
into the resting area and this is just
his usual pre-game state of course
players are extremely nervous coming
into the game and the last few minutes
are the worst because you are not going
to prepare any longer but you also
cannot start uh playing chess and
release all the tension and yeah tough
tough minutes we're waiting on here
is it frustrating Daniel that you take a
lead every time only to lose it the very
next day that can be really hard for Yan
to deal with right now
incredibly frustrating Tanya and
especially because his first one came
with the black pieces and you know there
were our share of nostradamuses who
after Jan's convincing win with black
were calling this match and saying
that's it it's over you know ding uh
he's emotionally unprepared he's
collapsing and suddenly those people
have receded into the background uh and
it's got to be frustrating right and Jan
is telling himself man I can't hold a
single game with the black pieces you
gotta keep coming up with ideas uh and
you got to keep cycling through your
opening preparation so can Jan pull
another one of those types of Roy Lopez
type positions out of his pocket that's
going to be the big question and maybe
uh we'll see a slight Divergence maybe
we'll see in Italian but Jan has to aim
for exactly the kind of position that he
got in his previous white win
this is a very critical game seven it's
very unique because it's a standalone
game it comes out of a rest day and the
players will be going into a rest day
tomorrow so it's a breakaway moment if a
player is able to take the lead going
into the second half that will be a big
psychological advantage that we see the
chairs are empty currently but of course
they will be walking in in just a few
seconds and we will have the first moves
of the game we've been talking about
Yan's approach with the white pieces in
the world championship so far he started
with the Queen's Pawn opening he's also
started with the King spawn opening he
won his game when he played one E4 also
in game one it ended in a draw but Ian
was the one pushing with one E4 Anish
what are we expecting as first moves in
this game will it be the King's Pawn the
Queen's Pawn or something completely
random
well it's sort of a self or
self-suggesting self-evident that Jan
would try to dig something up in the E4
continuation indeed so far it has been
proven to be the most effective in the
match and it would be very strange not
not to follow the the recipe that has
brought you success of course you need
some ideas but I believe in the Spanish
and in the Italian there is room there
is room left to try and find something
small something new where I think will
be a little bit less familiar because if
ding is in an unfamiliar grounds as we
had seen in the Spanish he can't he can
um start you know drifting a little bit
and uh I do believe we will see the
repeat of the Spanish because if he
under something else that would
certainly be a big surprise but I'm
probably a very pleasant one for ding
ending is the first player to walk into
the playing Arena we see him there
looking very confident sitting down
taking his place doing his usual
pre-game check with writing on the score
sheet and we see his
antagonisti there taking his place with
the white pieces also in the background
the director of Tata steel why can't say
you're on Vandenberg there uh honey
she's a he's a great friend of yours and
of course a big relationship there with
Tata steel chess and right now the
pieces are being adjusted one E4 1d4
we've seen some crazy openings
things so far in the match with black
has had a little bit of a tough time
equalizing Daniel how do you see him
combating that today
well I mean that obviously depends on on
what nepo plays my prediction is 1e4 I
think nepo might try to choose another
one of those Roy Lopez Sidelines and I
just think ding might want to take a
little bit longer on those early opening
decisions because what set the negative
tone for him in his previous loss was
that early decision to trade light
squared Bishops that gave NEPA the D5
Square it gave him a very comfortable
Edge so it's going to be really
important for ding to avoid the type of
position where he doesn't have a lot of
counter play and where Yan is really
familiar with uh the typical plans in
the early middle game so I mean a lot of
that depends on on what Yan plays and
I'm so so curious Tanya to see what
Jana's gonna bring to the table this
game I think we're gonna get some sort
of re Lopez or maybe an Italian
yeah it all comes down to what is his
strategy for today's match he starts
with white would he want to create his
chances take those risks to get into
chaotic positions or will he want to
just shut the game down going into the
next rest day going into the second half
of the match we will find that very
shortly Jan there taking off his jacket
putting it on the side and we can just
feel the tension right now ding not even
looking at Yan Anish these are the most
tensed moments for chess players right
before those seconds before uh move one
is played
yes yes certainly and these are the
minutes that you have to survive but
luckily at some point it ends the time
goes so slowly when you're sitting there
before the game but so quickly once the
clock begins and you have some problems
to solve and uh indeed it's just two
minutes to go
Yan swinging back and forth on the chair
um waiting for the game to start
okay just gonna throw it out there some
body language reading
do you think just looks a little more
confident coming into this game seven
from what you see with their uh just
with the way they're sitting taking off
their jackets right now
well Jan with his usual routine he's
always swinging back and forth in that
solo chair ding uh always taking a more
sedentary uh motionless pose I think the
players are are equally nervous I think
they're equally excited for the clock uh
to read 3 P.M local time but Anish is so
right it's also that moment perhaps
people can relate before an exam starts
you just want to open the test booklet
you want to see what questions you're
going to face and there's your own
vendenberg uh the chief organizer of the
Tata steel tournament shaking the
players hands Yan ding they want to get
through that opening routine and ding
wants to find out what the heck Jana's
prepared for this game
oh wow and you're on vanderberg plays
the place C4 the English and immediately
puts it back do you think we might see
Yan go for that Anish or that's not
gonna be an option
now just to be sure after he brought the
pawn black young readjusted the e-pawn
just to point out to the commentators
guys don't worry I got you it's going to
be for us you all expects I'm pretty
sure before is coming
it's going to be E4 I think yeah I'm
also I'm also uh rooting for one E4
we've seen Yan have great positions out
of the opening and the ball will be in
ding's court to really prove how he
equalizes he struggled so far in the
match to completely equalize in the
Spanish as we've seen and here we go
handshakes clocks have started and yeah
it goes with one E4
no surprises so far
okay ding's turn will we see a surprise
from ding I don't think so
we might but I don't think it will be on
the move for one uh I think I mean ding
could could pull out a different Spanish
perhaps I don't think it's likely but
there is a possibility for that I mean
doing something else and E5 ding has
very little experience playing other
openings recently of course he used to
play the French then the Karo Khan but
it is you know these openings they're
considered slightly second rate and um
this is not the stuff you usually
prepare for World Championship matches
taking a moment there
yeah ding has been mentioning how he's
been
he's been approached right before the
start
goes with
wow
unbelievable that is huge
oh my God
wow the French so desperate I mean I can
imagine the Spanish hasn't worked out
and I thought ding might surprise him
within the Spanish but oh this this is a
very big one
hmm 92. wow wow very timid response by
Yan there are different approaches like
the two is considered to be the most
timid one actually digging you play the
French as his main weapon at some point
it was his only it's basically sort of a
childhood or a rather opening he grew up
with I think he used to play the French
and the King's Indian at some point
exclusively but then as he reached the
top level he realized that he has to
expand his repertoire and he slowly went
for the more sound systems uh only to at
this important Moment The crucial moment
in his career to go back to where what
he started with playing the French and
um 92's surprising Choice by yan yan
probably didn't expect the French so
they've chosen not the most uh not the
most principled continuation after C5
he's already taking taking a time his
time to think
indeed taking a little sip of tea and C5
is the more modern continuation Knight
F6 is the chief alternative which leads
to more tactical positions but a recent
theory has shown that black is doing
completely fine after C5 I mean I've
played Knight D2 against the French my
whole life and I've really struggled in
recent months and years to show any sort
of an advantage after C5 so Tanya I
don't know what nepo has played
previously Anish maybe you have some
insight on that against the French but
I'm a little bit surprised at the speed
with which he's chosen Knight D2 because
Knight C3 a main continuation even the
advanced French E5 uh with some new
ideas has had a bit I can imagine
because I have prepared this once myself
I've played it in the World Cup against
another episode of I I know I saw the
feature chat there you know check asking
us if there is accessible course of
course there is accessible courses
adjustable course for everything there's
even adjustable course for 1p3 they
certainly adjustable course for French
the many French courses I've authored
one of them but there are many others as
well and a 92 C5 yeah it's a it is
considered to be not the most principled
way for white to play and but the most
safe one and the most solid one and I
guess given that Jan didn't expect the
French to be a big Battleground he has
prepared a small simple system uh had he
I guess had he anticipated the French
for real he would have invested much
more time into something more critical
such as 39 C3 or the advanced French but
you know when you don't consider
something likely to happen why spend a
month studying the main lines of the
French when you can just prepare one
sideline and you use it in case you need
and that's probably what's happening
here as we see this popular sideline
where I believe theoretically from
theoretical point of view black has
multiple ways to get an acceptable
position overall I think a choice for
ding that is likely to work out today is
this uh surprise is definitely something
that Jan didn't expect
seeing one is 6. seeing the front by
dangler and I mean just abandoning the
most solid approach with black starting
with E5 it does show that he's
struggling a little bit in those Spanish
positions but French that is definitely
not one of the choices that I would have
predicted for this one but we have been
seeing ding come up with these uh
opening ideas which are completely
unexpected do you feel that Richard
rapper Daniel has something to do with
that I was actually going to say this
move Knight F6 is a lot less common than
Knight C6 but I think it's extremely
underrated I mean in my analysis I think
Knight F6 basically equalizes right out
of the gate now it's not a unknown move
uh it's been played by many top GMS uh
and I definitely think Richard perhaps
didn't tell ding what to play I mean
ultimately the decision lies with the
players but I could definitely see
Richard encouraging ding uh to sort of
change the nature of the game uh from a
very early Point rather than kind of
fishing for some you know pitiful
equality in these in these Spanish lines
just change the opening entirely and
play something that you know if ding
played this as a kid if he played this
when he first became a GM then he
understands the basic ideas so I'm
definitely very very surprised but I
don't think it's a particularly radical
choice if he used to be uh a French
player as his main opening
yeah underneath Knight F6 on the board
clear threat with some pressure on the
center the E4 Pawn is hanging and Yan
needs to take a decision what to do with
it I see two choices you can either Push
It Forward attacking the Black Knight or
liquidate the center further it feels
like this is the moment that we'll
decide how the middle game will turn out
the kind of positions we'll get what is
uh what is the choice that you're
expecting Yan to go with here
I have a suspicion that I've seen a game
by Yan there I could be wrong and he
could be playing with the black pieces
as well because Jan he had a French
phase he played the French at the
candidates tournament uh Jan actually
also played the French in his childhood
as well so both players you know they
they've got the opening in their system
uh Jan was probably influenced by his
one of his second golf who is a big big
uh specialist on the French I think you
know I I do think I knowing ding this is
so uncharacteristic of him to surprise
the opponent in this way this is really
not the way he uh treats uh treats the
opening usually this is not the way he
treats events if there is a one uh word
you know to describe ding um
I I would say predictability is is a
very big one this was always something I
felt about dink as one of his main
disadvantages one of his main weaknesses
I think he's in he's always been an
incredibly predictable player I was able
to guess in most of my games almost to
the to the dot what he will play but um
this comes as a total surprise to
everyone and I am absolutely convinced
that Richard Richard had to say it was
Richard's idea uh from the start and he
also convinced thing I'm pretty sure and
probably ding wasn't hard to convince
because uh so far
um so far the Spanish wasn't working out
well and I I guess ding you know is
trying trying to be more open-minded for
this event seeing that uh well you know
as his usual approach uh might not be
the right one he was also very nervous
at the start I think he relied a lot on
the support from his friends as he said
and when the friends suggest him now to
do something he thinks you know the
they've been helping me very well so far
so let me just lean lean on them and
trust them on this one as well so I I do
think it's the Richard's idea to play
the French and uh knowing yeah it takes
D5 I think if ding is a little bit
prepared here he will get a reasonably
safe comfortable position uh of course
whites has a nominal Advantage but I
think the opening choice is likely to
work out for Dink and it's it was
definitely a very clever thing to do
yeah extremely clever and Knight takes
D5 also as far as I know not the most
popular move Queen takes D5 used to be
all their rage uh but I think Knight
takes D5 just totally equalizes
typically I mean this structure is very
easy to understand black is ultra solid
and the French Bishop on C8 later on can
be deployed on the long diagonal with B6
and Bishop B7 if if memory serves me
right
um white typically responds with Knight
2 uh to F3 kind of opening up a pathway
for his own bishop and then there's this
line uh where black develops the bishop
to B4 with check and drops it back to C5
but I don't want to delve too deeply uh
into the sort of weeds here I think we
should wait for yon to make his choice
and Tanya Jan is taking his time here
this is obviously a position that he's
familiar with this is a well-known
theoretical position uh but it's very
very clear that he didn't expect the
French and it's very clear to me that
he's he's trying to remember his prep
and uh I think that the psychological
onus is on his side right now the ball
is in his score to demonstrate any sort
of an edge in a line which has been
considered really Problem free for black
in the last couple of years
yeah yeah I'm taking his time in the
opening is not something we are very
used to hearing in this match so uh that
just means that ding's the one who did
manage to get in at least a little bit
of a surprise but as you're mentioning
it's not too much because Jan definitely
is familiar he is trying to decide where
to place his pieces where to develop the
light Squad Bishop where to take out
that Knight so you can open up the
diagonal for that dark Squad bishop and
currently Jan's the one who's just
slightly behind on the clock it of
course doesn't matter because there's a
lot of time but in this match so far
we've seen these Dynamics be a little
different it's always been ding who's
been in the think tank early on taking
the time just feels like he's slightly
better prepared today more confident in
this offbeat opening that he's chosen
Jan goes for the idea that you mentioned
Daniel just centralizing that night
opening up the diagonal for the dark
Squad Bishop taking the F4 Square under
control and you're pointing out the move
with the bishop coming out with a check
and that allows white to push the sea
Pawn hitting that Bishop gaining a Tempo
so I really want to understand what's
the point of provoking that move
so there are some early tactics here
perhaps we should pull up our first
analysis Board of the day and Anisha
obviously please feel free to jump in at
any moment uh my opening knowledge is
shoddy at best but I did have uh a a
recent game here I played this line with
black if white plays C3 as far as I
remember black can actually play Knight
takes C3 and the tactics work out for
black after the trade on C3 white blocks
of the bishop and obviously you don't
take the Rook here because then white
gets two pieces for a rook you double
back and take the Knight and very
importantly Queen A4 check very common
Motif but it doesn't quite work out
because Knight C6 protects the bishop
just in time and black emerges uh with
two extra pawns but instead ding he
takes a more simple approach he develops
this bishop more modestly to E7 right
away and accompanies that by getting up
from his chair so Anish Bishop B7 is on
the board
yes a small surprise indeed I also
recollect as Bishop before check I think
the line you referred to was Bishop
before check Bishop D2 probably black
Castle first and after C3 the bishop
Denver throws back to C5 uh promotary
collects are looking at these positions
they they're indeed options for black
Bishop E7 is also one of the moves and
black is as you mentioned just very
solid it's just
um fundamentally very solid the pawn
structure is is such that there isn't
that much going on I remember once I had
the spawn structure against ding in a
Blitz game many many many years ago and
I lost that Blitz game he played it very
convincingly very quickly very
confidently I think he he's comfortable
in this Pawn structure and I think Jan
is feeling underwhelmed in general I
think he had something planned the
French came as a surprise his plan this
outgoing 92 it was never it was never
the plan a it was always the plan B uh
and uh I can almost feel uh how
underwhelmed he is he had big hopes for
this game I'm pretty sure and now the
the course it's taking is just not
um not you know what what he was hoping
uh for the uh one thing I do want to
mention though the the advantage of
playing the French or a surprise weapon
like this at this point in the match is
that okay even if we assume that today
Ayana surprise he'll play uh something
um unassuming and even if thing will
make a draw the question will come back
two days later so when ding will play
the next game what is he going to do
then because if he then repeats the
French it will no longer come a surprise
Yan will be ready for something in the
main line while if ding goes back to his
regular weapon Jan already has something
prepared for it and he doesn't need to
do extra work so that is one problem
with playing the surprises in the match
and this is why I think they haven't
been played so often and certainly not
early on in the match
but maybe dig strategy has changed maybe
he will keep jumping maybe the next game
will be the karakan maybe uh something
else we will see but
um yeah what I want to say is that the
match is long and just you know doing
this one uh jump into a French defense
it could uh long term long term it could
also backfire for ding
indeed Bishop p7 though on the board and
right now ding has to be sitting pretty
I mean he's not sitting at the board at
all it's Yana pamushi who's sitting at
the board and kind of looking off into
the distance and oftentimes when we see
an opening surprise in a tournament or a
match that's this momentous I think a
lot of commentators and players are
influenced by the result of the game but
I actually think that regardless of how
this game finishes already we could say
tentatively that the opening Choice has
been very uh very well chosen by dangly
ran or by Richard Rapport if he indeed
influenced ding to go for this line
because there's no question in my mind
that objectively black has already
essentially equalized the structure is
very easy to understand and if ding did
his homework then he knows exactly in
which order to finish his development he
knows uh whether it's a castle next or
whether to play B6 next and if he can
solve the problem of his light squared
Bishop Tanya I mean maybe my
understanding of Chess is primitive but
I don't see a single reason why black
should be any worse here with a nice
Knight on D5 if of course he can find a
good parking spot for his light squared
Bishop whether it involves B6 Bishop B7
or trying to push E5 that of course is
what ding would have to check in his
pregame reparation
traditionally in the front we always see
black really suffering with that light
squat Bishop that is the piece that
brings in the nightmares but right now
it looks like with both these ideas
either on the queen side or advancing
the Central Pawn the problem of the
light Square Bishop can be easily solved
fitting and we once again see Yan taking
his time to decide how to finish his
development it's important to bring out
his own light Squad Bishop currently
does he place it on D3 does he place it
on C4 these are the questions that
janapamnushi is currently contemplating
very interesting points that are made by
you a niche that think taking this
approach of playing the French is this a
one game approach or will we see this
again in the match but one thing's clear
the ding has been coming out with these
small Novelties these small fresh ideas
out of the opening and that just shows
that he's ready to take the
unpredictable part now I am slightly
surprised to see Yan who does combine
his aggressive play with with quick
moves take his time and he decides
finally to put the bishop on C4 a
slightly more attacking approach there
eyeing that Knight on D5 does he just
simply want to go shot Castle next
yeah I'm thinking of uh of the different
possibilities here and I guess the one
of the reason of placing the bishop on
C4 is that perhaps in some cases I'm not
sure if it's relevant but some cases you
could see a tactic after a B6
potentially some Knight F5 option maybe
maybe that is one idea uh keeping an eye
on that item D5 maybe that's that's one
advantage of uh having the bishop so
actively developed
and I certainly expect zinc to keep uh
keep up the pace and show us his
preparation here I indeed do think he's
uh he has prepared this bishop E7 he
plays so quickly and Bishop C4 probably
is one of the critical moves I guess
black should probably start by castling
white will also probably castle and then
as Daniel mentioned of course once the
bishop gets to the long diagonal
everything gets developed black will
consolidate and uh be fine but maybe the
devil is in the details and maybe while
black goes for B6 wife will try to do
something quick maybe it's Knight of
five maybe it's 95 and queen I don't
know G4 or something like that probably
not that but keep an eye also on 95
takes F7 sometimes when the bishop comes
out to B7 uh keep an eye out for the
tactics like like that because indeed if
uh White doesn't have any tactics if
black gets to develop all the pieces
he's feeling comfortable and one other
point I wanted to briefly make because
we speak about the French now what
people say you know the memes about the
French are about the different kind of
French they're about the close positions
when white plays the most
um the most ambitious approach that is
three E5 or 393 followed by E5 on the
next move and this is the French
structure where the bishop is sort of
almost eternally dead on C8 and it's
really struggling to come out or trade
itself while what we have here this is
not your typical frame structure it's a
common structure in chess it can arise
of course mainly from the French but
also it happens in various other
openings
but this this structure is fundamentally
less strategically dangerous for black
but it's very safe for white and yeah
this is not your usual kind of French
the one they they talk about and uh
on on the internet in 96 has been played
this is an interesting idea
oh that's a spicy move not the move that
one would expect and clearly a sign that
Ding has done his homework because you
do not allow your Pawn structure on the
queen side to be damaged like that
unless you've looked at it beforehand
before we proceed to an investigation of
this move though uh our amazing team
behind the scenes coming up with a crazy
stat the last time that the French has
been played in a world championship game
you will not believe this was in 1978 in
the karpov corporation Baguio city that
incredibly controversial match but
that's beside the point 1978 is the last
time that we have seen a French in the
world championship match so uh Victor
cortional rest in peace he passed away
recently and it's only carpa probably
sitting uh you know by by a fireplace
thinking man I remember the last time I
faced the French from Victor the
terrible and here we go again
yeah oh my God that's that's insane so
long ago that we you know how many times
the London was played in the world
championship match all of zero Daniel
and we saw ding do it so we can
definitely expect more of these uh
opening ideas from him in the coming
games but right now it does look with
the speed that he's playing and the
confidence that he's playing that he's
got the kind of position that he wants
out of the opening while Jana probably
she goes into a thing on every move now
to me it looks like here shot Castle
would be one of those hand moves that
you want to make you want to complete
your development is there something
wrong with that is there an alternative
that Jan's already thinking about Anish
you mentioned these amazing tactical
ideas with the Knight jumping on to F5
maybe some Far Away sacrifice on F7 one
day which might appear is Knight F5
completely crazy in this position or is
it something Jan's thinking about
well I was particularly excited about
Knight to five when the pawn was um on
b69 was on B8 so that after EF Bishop D5
there I would have collected the rook
and now the situation is very different
I also wander up 95 if
there are no tactical possibilities uh
there maybe a simple move like Bishop of
six also to diffuse all the the tension
I'm not sure I like 95 like it was it
was not in this position that I I like
the look of it now now it looks to me a
little bit a little bit artificial uh
big question is of course if uh instead
of that how to assess the Knight x66
basic continuation that pawn on C6 is a
little weak but often in these positions
where I bring it to C5 and bring the
bishop out to B7
um well I will have a very powerful
Bishop the pawns on the queen side they
are weak you could say but at the same
time if I uh potentially maybe an A7 and
on C5 I I do wonder how weak the C5 Pawn
actually is okay I'll play Bishop pc7 my
queen will also hide the F4 Square Up
Bring The Rook out to d8 Knight F4 will
come there is a lot of potential for
black and all of that uh all over that
for what you what you call a weakness on
C5 but why exactly is The Tweak uh who
is attacking it I mean defending it
twice nobody's ever attacking it it's a
very abstract statement I know the I I
heard uh secretive who plays the
structure with white a lot a famous
Dutch Grandmaster originally from Russia
he is a big fan of these structures for
white and he calls this spawn structure
better uh better for white and he calls
the spawn of weakness but well from uh
from my experience and in an early
middle game like that before you know
before we we get into an end game before
white has a chance to attack the spawn I
think it's it's very hard to say who
benefits from the straight on C6 and uh
Jan seeing ding play so quickly and
confidently might defer the trade for a
while because after the trade black gets
a lot of easy moves while if you keep
the status quo you may be Castle first
with white instead of taking then maybe
after castle castle maybe you can play
C3 or rookie one just a waiting move
then you'll ask like okay how do you
follow uh follow it up do you because
it's difficult to make a waiting move at
this point because a move like A6 will
be a waste of time while taking on D4
okay this this keeps the structure alive
and still asks black the question how do
you develop the bishop on C8 so I think
Yan annoying Yan and looking at the
position and the fact that he's
unfamiliar with it I expect Jan to
actually not take on Sussex to try and
keep more tension and try to confuse
ding uh with a simple move like castle
and rookie one or C3
yeah a lot
I loved having chat someone mentioned
that Richard rappo is just making this
world championship so interesting with
the opening choices he's not even
playing but he definitely has a big role
in the way we're seeing the games turn
out and that is the beauty of these
matches uh the kind of influence the
team of seconds and the trainers have on
the players we've seen it with their
opening approaches and that's the action
that we've seen ding playing the French
is not a call that anyone would have
made and there we have it the move that
you've been talking about Anish he goes
for the most direct line and this is
something that we've seen Yan do over
and over again where when faced with
something he wasn't expecting on the
board he does tend to play the most
direct options there he picks up the
Knight on C6 and says that you're going
to have this weak Pawn for a long time
on C6 uh and you've got you've got to
find the time to neutralize that
Advantage ding slowing down once again
for an obvious move we're not surprised
by that anymore are we
yeah especially since he's probably in
the bathroom at the moment
I mean you do recapture you recapture
the knights this is nothing to think
about I I don't think he's uh he's in
the bathroom probably right now or in
the rest area obesity will certainly
come and the next few moves as well I am
surprised by the captions that it's
because I don't think it's a bad wolf
it's the most principled one indeed but
I do think that black has very easy and
play for the coming few moves and I'm
curious what Young uh
will do actually I see some ideas for
white we'll discuss them perhaps later
maybe we need two and Bishop A6 as one
trying to trade that potential active
Bishop but what I want to mention is the
fact that okay we give a lot of credit
to Richard but it is ding you know who
who gets out of his comfort zone he has
to play this and he he agrees he could
easily shut this kind of talks down very
I can easily imagine when Richard says
okay let's do the French Dingle black no
and that's it but uh Dean was like oh
and uh you know that makes a difference
also dig mentioned he is now speaking
English and this brings some different
thoughts perhaps in Chinese the French
opening is called differently maybe it's
called like a miserable uh like a
miserable opening with legal space when
three Chinese characters and that's why
he never he never liked it but now that
he knows it's called the French he's
like oh but the French you know it's
cool you know they have the croissant
they have the Eiffel Tower it's uh it's
all good maybe I'll play it so perhaps
you know doing getting out of his
comfort zone the new ding but he's with
Richard and um now thinking in English
and now much more open to the idea of
playing the French
and then continues to Blitz out his
moves obviously he castles and without
any question this position occurred in
his preparation because nepo has made
the most direct moves Tanya you bench I
think you called it nepo tends to resort
to the most sort of straightforward
developing moves uh when faced with a
surprise weapon so Bishop C4 was direct
move number one uh developing the bishop
to the most active post and direct move
number two of course was the principled
capture on C6 essentially trying to call
Black's buff Bluff but now I think nepo
has a much faster choice because he has
to actually choose his arrangement of
pieces in Anish I definitely want to
hear more about your idea of Queen E2
and Bishop A6 I would only contribute
that another one of those types of ideas
involves dropping this bishop back from
C4 uh and actually trying to advance the
pawn to C4 in order to chase blacks
Knight away from its Central post but
one thing is for certain if you give
black three or four Tempe and you let
black get the bishop out and open up the
long diagonal white could actually end
up worse and that is why nepo wasting no
time on each we need to is on the board
great call by you
yeah I think uh Jan is also realizing
the potential that the bishop has and
now it's a big question uh for for ding
how how will he treat this position well
I don't know if he's still in book now
you could you could make a case for a
well a way to move like Queen C7 or C5
Bishop B7 is the least likely because
then after Bishop A6 you would have
wasted a move and I guess Bishop A6
could anyway be White's idea at some
point maybe it's just me by the way but
I I do like this movie Bishop A6 does
stare at me so I think it's an idea
another way for black to play to try and
stop this so you could do so by doing by
going Queen B6 uh you could also uh
flick in an A5 first I am not sure how
much A5 contributes but just stopping
Bishop um A6 could already be enough of
a reason to play it
certainly uh an interesting choice there
therefore ding I think practically
speaking it would be harder for white to
play if you if you don't get Bishop A6
straight because once you get that trade
you get the C4 Square also for the queen
you can then play it a little bit more
um simply but even these positions even
when you trade these Bishops they don't
it's not like they are better for uh for
white by no means black has pressure on
the B file
and the B2 Pawn will be under attack so
the bishop on C1 will be harder to
develop but Knight on D5 also controls a
lot of squares and the bishop doesn't
have uh the C1 Bishop doesn't have a
clear square like if it could teleport
itself to G3 that would be fantastic but
I don't see that happen and how does it
do so often uh y chooses therefore to go
for move like Bishop G5 once the queen
leaves j8 Square to trade that Bishop
altogether and theanchetto would not
look attractive because of Bishop F6
always so B3 is out of the question
usually so a lot of a lot of questions
for both sides here and it looks like
and Dink already started to think and
I'm not surprised because he had to
prepare so many complicated lines in the
French so many challenging lines and
this is a position where you you feel
pretty safe as black I believe his prep
would would end somewhere around here
and I think that he could just a few of
these positions quite well a lot of
experience there as I mentioned that
Blitz game I played with with him was in
a position similar to this he played it
very quickly very well so uh yeah I'm
feeling feeling confident for ding but
he he definitely has to take his time
and take a decision at this very moment
all right I got a little game I looked
this position up uh as Anisha as you
were sharing your excellent insights it
turns out that this position has
occurred twice in tournament practice uh
once in 2020 but one time a lot earlier
than that in a game between two very
strong Grand Masters and black uh was a
French expert who unfortunately passed
away a couple years ago and he was one
of Gary kasparov's first coaches and
trusted confidence Tanya I'll ask you
first uh what year do you think this was
played for the first time
oh wow
um one of Gary's coaches you mentioned
so I'm thinking maybe 60s late 60s
okay Anish what's your guess
hmm
okay let me uh I'm embarrassed I'm sure
when you'll tell me the name I will know
who that is but since I don't know don't
know I'm not going to start naming uh
coaches of Gary that are oh alive oh is
it in the kitchen the kitchen passed
away
Grandmaster
[Music]
who uh was a very strong player in his
own right retired pretty early and
became a noted chess coach he reached
this position in the year 1987 against
Yuri Krupa uh another very strong
Russian GM also a French player by the
way with the black pieces but Krupa had
white in this game and dokiyan was a
lifelong French player he played Bishop
B7 and in that game for whatever reason
white did not respond with Bishop A6
yeah I mean Bishop A6 is uh it's my
instincts I'm trying to eliminate active
pieces I'm trying to eliminate attacking
potential of my opponent this is my uh
particular style of course many people
they wouldn't even think of that they
would be like I have such a attacking
wonderful bishop or that could
potentially will help me give a
Checkmate on H7 why would I ever trade
it so I could certainly see Arguments
for not trading it I I was not aware of
um's opening reporter I know him
predominantly as an incredible uh
trainer he has coached
Kasparov then he transferred that
experience to to be a successful trainer
in um for for the Russian national teams
with women I believe mainly also he
coached many great Russian players
including a supreme court as well uh
careykin when he was at the peak of his
career
um and uh yeah very uh
a very you know Legendary Legendary
chess chess player but I didn't know
that he was lifelong French player
uh and that's interesting I think it
never never influenced Kasparov though I
don't think Kasparov ever played the
French I think a lot of Sicilians and
some e45 don't don't recall any french
there but uh yeah I think
ding is thinking right now I don't know
I do think the bishop A6 move is quite
good what do you think Dania do you
agree that Bishop is selling Bishop A6
is the right response
so I've been trying to tease out uh
those complications after Bishop B7
Bishop A6 perhaps we could uh quickly
bring up an analysis board uh because to
me for some reason intuitively after
Bishop B7 Bishop A6 it seems to me like
black could maybe take on A6 as
counter-intuitive as it seems and now
try to use exploit the placement of
White's Queen for Black's benefit uh
maybe with night before I was also
thinking maybe Queen to B6 getting the
queen out and putting a little bit of
pressure on B2 and Anish your idea made
me think of this uh the idea of
basically pressuring B2 with uh Bishop
to F6 I don't think it makes any sense
for white to take on B6 here I mean this
end game has got to be at the very least
comfortable for black probably even
better so white would presumably drop
his Queen back uh where well that's a
hard question maybe Queen back to E2 and
I was thinking something like Bishop F6
followed by Rook d8 the position looks
pretty lifeless to me but intuitively I
feel like the activity of Black's pieces
compensates for the lack of the light
squared Bishop but Anish Maybe your
intention was to squeeze more out of
this position with black and that's why
the 2020 game uh featured the move Queen
to B6 uh even though black lost in that
game
hmm yeah I I
um
I have to say that after Bishop Nissan
Bishop A6 Yeah the more I look at that
position the one that you stop the
analysis again I I think the crucial
factor is the fact that this bishop on
C1 uh so after the taking let's say
Bishop a6.6 now I I thought you were
gonna go night before to try and make uh
use of that but then I would just drop
the queen back to E2 right so a queen
Basics certainly made sense to me so
Queen B6 let's say queen E2
uh yeah Bishop F6 let's say C3 now again
I want to reinstate it if I had the
bishop on G3 where I would control the
ba Square uh connect my own Rooks and
not worry about life I'd be very happy
with wise here I am happy about my Pawn
structure but I don't know
um I I could consider even the move like
Bishop G5 because I I need to develop
that bishop and it bugs me bugs me
strongly that
um yeah that I cannot do that okay ba is
even more natural to me to be honest
just put the pressure on the beat upon
and I think if I'm not able to develop
the bishop why should I why should it be
better uh and potentially I will avoid
could even be worse because you know you
need to finish a development at some
point uh if you never do then it could
be uh could be quite a problem so visual
Basics maybe are not too tempting and if
that is not tempting perhaps
um black can just play Bishop B7 and
ignore that idea altogether
well also pick and try and start with C5
because maybe C5 is the move you anyway
want to play
I think that's the likely one as well
the starting position
and now after Bishop A6 You could argue
that now you can take in one go and then
I don't know how uh how much of a Tempo
that is but it's probably nice to have
the extra move C5 isn't it
definitely
wow so England going into a big thing
here about all these options whether to
take out the queen stopping the idea of
the bishop trade or just continuing with
the bishop coming on to B7 opening up
the diagonal with C5 he is currently
contemplating these decisions and
meanwhile of course it will be about
whether Yan wants to trade the Bishops
next or not and while ding has a think
about this we're going to head into a
shot break and hopefully by the time
we're back we will have a decision of
the development that Ding decides on
we'll be right back
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
of the world championship match dingler
and still contemplating how he wants to
proceed to proceed in this position
coming up with the first surprise of the
day was the French by Ding and right now
in a think tank before we Deep dive into
a position we do have some great
announcement for our viewers World Quant
is an official partner of the chescom
broadcast for the v-day world
championship they are a global firm that
builds complex mathematical models to
identify market inefficiencies now world
one brain is bringing together its
International Pawn championship and the
chess Community to hunt down the next
generation of Quant Finance Specialists
because nobody knows how to analyze a
position better than a chest pair right
if you think you have what it takes
register for the international fund
championships head over to go.chess.com
iqc or use command iqc in chat for more
detail
and wow we are back to the game action
Anish Daniel it has been an exciting
opening an explosive start with the
friends something nobody expected and
now ding has been in the think tank for
quite some time does this give Yan that
extra confidence out of the opening
well you know Tony I just wanted to
point out one thing
um I I just it just hit me do you
remember the the opening uh the opening
press conference they asked ding about
his favorite players
and he mentioned a bunch of names and
amongst them so he mentioned um of
course mentioned Magnus
I don't remember all the names but uh I
think they were all world champions with
an exception of Vallejo pons and
um is the top player from Spain and he
well he didn't argumentated for you know
who he
why he liked all these players and he
said that he liked uh Paco Vallejo
because back when he was playing the
French
he liked a lot of his opening ideas
and he said that uh in a press
conference with young president and I
realized at that time he had no idea I
was going to play play the French
because if he had that would be such a
giveaway so I think the French is also a
big surprise for ding himself I think it
hasn't occurred to him at the start that
he might use it because then it would be
just very strange to um to give that one
away no yeah wow Daniel do you think
that was a little slip there because
definitely out of the players that he
mentioned well Echo a very strong brand
Master as you said stood out a little
bit amongst the different names and that
might just have been a bit of a slip
there right at the beginning of the
match by ding he did maybe the opposite
maybe he actually mentioned it first and
then it got into his head like oh French
actually why not
reverse psychology
I love it he has been mentioning how he
decides what opening to play right
before the start of the game I'm still
not believing in that bit I do think
that it is premeditated and decided a
while ago but this position wow ding
with his head in his hands still
thinking so Queenie too we've been
talking about the idea of the bishop
trade should Black Avoid it with the
move Queen to B6 uh what are the
possibilities that we are expecting ding
to actually
make sure the trade doesn't happen or do
you think he will just literally not
care and Advance with the c Pawn or with
the bishop on B7
yeah that's a big one by the way
and it does not and by the way uh I
mentioned that there were two games in
the database here the second one from
2020 uh black was uh Jerry Huska Yovan
kahuska's brother uh so there's there's
a lot of layers to this
um and I was also reading during the
break about Yuri uh who had this uh in
in 1987 with black it turns out that
dohoyan was one of the main mentors of
Vladimir putkin who uh was napomnishi's
main coach and still is one of his
closest confidants so there's a lot of
layers to this uh to this position but
to get back to uh the task at hand for
ding I think it's a major Divergence
because keeping the bishop versus
allowing the bishop to get traded leads
to two fundamentally different types of
positions uh in a Blitz game I would be
very tempted to play a move like a five
or queen B6 because you have this
instinct to keep the bishop alive but I
think upon closer inspection uh ding
probably begins to realize that his
other pieces can pick up the slack even
if this bishop is traded and as I say
that uh Anish Gary Bishop B7 is on the
board
yes ding showing uh
well it's early to say if it's deep
understanding but uh he's definitely
definitely showing confidence in the
assessment of the position after Bishop
A6 he doesn't even want a good version
of it he thinks okay trading trading
Bishop is fine by me and I can
understand that completely I I do agree
I think I also find Black's position
reasonably comfortable especially
because Bishop on C1 is not developed so
what we could also see is
to avoid this idea and try to develop
his pieces differently and keep that in
reserve in case black insists for
example if black goes for Knight B6
targeting the bishop then you can go
Bishop A6 or if perhaps one one day
later circumstances will be right then
you'll go Bishop basic so this is
possible to keep it in reserve possible
also to forget about it completely it
was just thought that occurred to me as
I mentioned I was not sure at all if
that's a good idea the other typical
moves here of course is to bring the
Rook from F1 onto a file usually it
heads to E1 somehow because I guess on
D1
well you have this x-ray but the queen
anyway moves to C7 I think they're yeah
this is okay I think the Rook on the
phone belongs to E1 because the Rook
from A1 belongs to D1 that's probably
the the way to go and uh often white
plays this move C3 controlling a bunch
of well a couple of important squares D4
and D4 and also opening an eye on the B2
Pawn from the queen so that then later
you can develop the bishop the queen
will protect the pawn uh the Bishop from
C1 it has to be developed somehow
you could make a case for a potential
Bishop D2 Rook 81 Bishop C1 idea but I'm
not sure you'll be in time because uh
the beat upon Mike might get attacked
before you manage all that so a lot a
lot of uh a lot to think about here for
Yan
and uh especially the question is with
which move to start what is the most
useful move
um yeah
just a lot of options really
yeah the most committed would be to
start trading the bishop on A6 and let's
say Yan decides that he wants to keep
more pieces on the board keep the game
More Alive you were talking about the C
Pawn advancing to three to C3 is there
also an idea to start pushing the a pawn
the dream would be to get it all the way
A4 A5 A6 I don't believe that Ding would
allow all of that to happen uh but is
that one side of the board that Jan can
start thinking about gaining more space
with the push of the a pawn
interesting idea I think if you can make
a deal with your opponent that you know
would you be so kind as to allow me to
bring my bond up to A6 then uh one would
consider it but A4 could be met with A5
I think it would be less advisable for
black to wait for white to play A5
himself and then play A6 because then
the A6 spawn obviously becomes a serious
liability and white has this battery
that is trained at the A6 Square so I
think A4 would probably be met with A5
and the only other thing I would add uh
is that the Krupa dokayan game actually
went Knight E5 but 95 seems like an
impulsive decision black quickly got his
Bishop over to D6 and the queen over to
C7 uh he induced this very very
weakening move F4 and after black played
C5 I mean his pieces started breathing
and black got a big Advantage uh pretty
quickly thereafter so as we're saying
earlier I mean this is not a risk-free
position for Jana pomnishing I think it
might look that way uh if you look
superficially but in fact I've white is
not careful black can absolutely I think
uh sees the initiative in the next
couple of moves and I think Jan realizes
this which is why he's investing a
serious amount of time on these last
couple of moves yes absolutely and as I
mentioned this 1966 it involves a
certain risk indeed and uh going back to
to here I I would expect a castle and a
slower move perhaps not creating this uh
potential for black pieces to to
activate but Jan chose what he has uh
what he has chosen and now one other
point I want to mention in connection to
what Tanya mentioned this move A4
definitely an interesting inclusion A4
A5 and uh one idea that might not be so
relevant in this position but is in
general quite common uh is when the
Knight is positioned here
and this pawns are positioned here this
was often to the advantage of the site
that has the knife here and the reason
is that if white eventually wants to
Target it with C4 then you create this
major hole on uh before so very often
this inclusion A5 A4 it seems like it
doesn't impact uh the rest of the game
and the rest of the board but it's
actually
in in a strange uh in a weird way it
creates this Outpost for the night it
wasn't there before because here let's
say if we imagine uh the night at some
point after let's say Bishop to G3 A3
can be targeted by C4 Knight doesn't
feel as secure here as it does after the
inclusion of these two moves and this is
an interesting theme that can also
happen um
for you know in the reverse White could
have denied there but it could also
happen when the Knight is on E5 and the
pawns are on H5 and H4 as well so this
this is like a theme that I've seen
happen in various openings and so this
move A4 is um although possible it also
has potential downsides that you might
not immediately uh spot uh but uh other
than that indeed as Daniel mentioned
this potential for black to activate the
pieces here is huge I mean if I get
everything at some point even the F Pawn
can join you know the the central pawns
can join the action so there's like lots
of potential uh but it's on the end to
try and diffuse it and I think
probably indeed not rushing with this
and maybe taking care of this bishop
that is what what you want what you want
to do
um but not so simple because besides
preventing Bishop issues with A5
sometimes black can also develop the
queen out Bring The Rook here and then
Bishop Basics can be made met by Bishop
A8 the bishop will stay on this long
diagonal forever I'm really curious as
to see um to see us what what Gian has
uh has in mind here because I think this
is a pretty difficult uh position and uh
I don't know I I think it's easier for
black to play maybe it's just me but to
me the whites moves they don't come as
naturally and uh I'm a little bit
struggling to suggest something really
good
yeah and I think it would be so
different if only White's a dark Squad
Bishop could be developed easily if only
you could find a nice Square for the
bishop uh imagine it on the H2 B8
diagonal and we'll be talking about
completely different uh Dynamics in the
position but the F4 Square isn't vacant
D2 is the only Square you can develop it
to but it just feels like it's coming in
the way of your own pieces the d-line
for example and just not a very nice
spot for the bishop to come out to so
some development problems now if Yan
does decide to trade with the bishop to
A6 is that a sign that he just wants to
shut off the game and go like I'm okay
with an equality in this one and we'll
see what happens
um I think it would be a sign that he is
okay with the equality but I think ding
would say wait wait wait a second before
we call it a day you know let me try to
squeeze the juice out of this position
and Jan in the meantime he does make a
bishop move but he makes a retreating
move with the light squid Bishop
dropping it back to D3 and training it
at the H7 pawn and this is an idea that
we had mentioned in passing earlier is
he preparing c2c4 in order to chase the
Black Knight away from its active Post
in the center or is his idea more
aggressively aimed at Black's King
yeah Denise you looked a little
surprised with that yeah it's a little I
I mean I I mentioned at some point uh
jokingly that Bishop A6 some players
they might find it ridiculous because uh
this bishop could contribute to
Checkmate and it seems that Jan has got
this very simple idea of going Queen E4
C4 by the way um C4
could be an option of course but you
have to be very careful about that
because after C4
your D4 square is weak and I see the
potential for my knight let's say night
before C5 Knight C6 to reroute itself to
D4 and then you'll strongly regret the
smooth C4 so C4 is a very double-edged
sword you of course if you get let's say
hypothetically C4 A3 B4 and C5 and you
clamp down my Bishop on B7 okay I give
you that but in the real world uh it's
not not so simple and um
I'm thinking here um so one question
that comes to mind uh just to establish
it as an option this night before
that that is the first question that
comes to mind because you immediately
Target the bishop after Bishop E4 uh
which is probably why it's idea I don't
see any other sensible move uh after
Bishop before I could gain the bishop
pair with F5 but I guess the idea is
that then you Retreat the bishop
um to D3
yeah perhaps you can move those on the
board yeah make some moves on the board
perhaps uh then yes after F5 Bishop D3
uh you will see that the bishop pair is
not worth uh perhaps not worth the
weekend weakening of the E5 Square so
this is not not something uh or even uh
taking yes even of course taking on
passant
what's the word
okay
yes yes yes now forgetting all the
everything is ambassano for me but even
uh even as a move like CD I would wonder
like how would how would that um how
would that be because E5 square is quite
significantly weakened but that said uh
night before is the first thought was
probably not the best thoughts the other
thought that I had upon thinking a
little longer is Queen C7
maybe I won this move Knight F4 and then
the big question is how to deal with uh
the move Queen E4 because if you go
Knight F6 I can swing the queen across
to H4 and uh have some very primitive
ideas perhaps the move G6 is uh instead
a better way to play I guess G6 is uh
more likely but then after G6 at least
the bishop gets that H6 Square this is
probably Jan's idea he is not you know
so naive as to try and Checkmate the
opponent this would be a little too
primitive and simple Jan's idea is to
perhaps bike
creating this battery perhaps try try
and get that H6 Square for the bishop
Jan is looking to create some some
provocation on the king side create some
weaknesses for black on the king Side by
threatening amid on 87 uh pushing black
to make the move G6 to stop that uh
Anish you were looking at a line of what
happens after let's say queen C7 which
is a natural move and if we can just
have that on the analysis board and
queen E4 you're pointing out now if ding
decides not to create the dark Squad
weaknesses on the king side with a move
like G6 and falls back with the Knight
to F6 you've been talking about keeping
the Queens on the board with Queen H4
and attack is Bishop F4 completely crazy
instead of Queen H4 and let's say after
Bishop F4 how do you evaluate Queen
trades let's say 94 Bishop C7 if the
queens were to come off in this Pawn
structure who would stand better
hmm
I don't know I think it would favor
white typically right because of the
pawn structure and in the meantime move
called Queen C7 has been played see this
go ahead
no I was indeed hoping that you would
take it over because uh it's extremely
difficult uh to say I've
like the I think the traditional
knowledge suggests that indeed the queen
trade would benefit white because
um the pawn structure is better for
white and why is the post structure
better is a big big way to a reason for
that is to count these Pawn Islands so
when you count upon islands and uh black
would have three the A7 is an island C6
is an island and this king-sized chain
is another Island and white has two
so uh using that metric the one that uh
well I first read the
when I saw annotation to karpov's game I
don't know who introduced that metric I
suspect it must have been before karpov
but um I don't know anyway now it's it's
an important metric that said I've had
some games in this Pawn structure in an
end game as well where
somehow these weaknesses said they were
never exploited so I'm not sure
um the White's construction Advantage
can be exploited uh very often because
also you have to realize the activity of
pieces is a big factor and often when
you have more weaknesses or you have one
weakness it is not the end of the world
you can just defend that weakness and
make and just hold so it's not like you
have a weakness you have to lose
famously you have to have two weaknesses
to lose yeah
one because of let's say a king uh or a
bad piece but you you need more than one
weakness to win so yeah nice a nice
International Bishop before I didn't see
that I I in general don't like Knight F6
even because of Queen H4
when the my Bishop on C1 has so many
different squares available it can now
uh go to G5 it can go to F4 as well lots
of um yeah and of course of course I'm
all about uh all about sorry I had to
yeah yeah sacrifice you get Knight G5
and all that so
um very appealing for white I I guess I
guess G6 must be the the move
instead because I have um okay maybe you
can make a move here and after Bishop G5
go H6 and prepare for the sack but G6 is
yes G6 is more likely
but then Bishop
Bishop H6 at least Jan secures the
position for uh for a bishop which is
nice
wow and currently the players are not
but they will be back soon and now it
will be Jan's turn to decide whether he
wants to place the queen on that Central
Square provoking some weaknesses uh it
has been a very interesting opening
Choice by ding his creativity has been
on full display in this match so far we
had the London on Sunday we got the
French today what more could we have
asked for and this is what ding had to
say after his uh win in game six
uh actually today I was very
um I'm not sure which opening to play
and and the last time I decided to go
for this London system also the line
occurred in the game he played Bishop E5
with all of my preparation so I just
tried to keep the position as
not so fast as and give some possibility
to play for a win and I think it turned
out to be quite well
and uh of course ding has been a beast
on the board and a total gentleman off
it we see there a tweet by my clients
who wins the world championship game and
then holds the door open for his mom I
have to say it has also we've seen this
very emotional side of the players so
far in the tournament Anish with the
hugs between Richard and ding ding
opening the door we've seen him in the
interviews this is also a very new
aspect which makes this world
championship uh so emotionally working
yeah though I think green gets a little
too much credit uh he didn't really hold
the door it's an elevator you just keep
the hand like that it's really easy if
you hold the real door which was like
heavy then there will be a different
story but other than that no certainly
um very likable a likable personality
and you know
just just a sweet uh sweet guy at the
same time so ambitious and such a
fighter making all these aggressive
moves and uh showing strength of
character I I believe that the fact that
he was confessing to you know his
worries at the start of the match it
doesn't show a weakness at all everybody
has these worries but the fact that you
are confident to share them uh that is
more the sign of a sign of strength sign
of confidence you're not afraid to to
share what you feel because I'm
absolutely sure the Jan feel feels the
same way and uh people you know we all
have our own insecurities
so I think a strong strong character and
uh and a great personality there uh
there by our champion from from China
and uh
I just looked up at the base as well uh
in the break like to see what happened
in the opening I am surprised actually
uh I did remember it's a game of young
but Jan has actually had many games in
this line so he uh I think he didn't
prepare for the French at all to be
honest for the match like he didn't even
look at it a little bit he just played
what he played before which is
timid but also doesn't have a surprise
value either so I think his team just
hasn't thought about it at all um or
well they thought it was so unlikely
that they just told him just play what
you normally play there's 92 thing and
just uh you'll be fine but uh yeah no
not a good outcome from the opening um
doing uh you know already comfortable
equalized according to the computer here
uh very comfortable position 24 G6 uh
the computer uh yeah finds black
Exposition very very fine The Rook comes
to d8 pawn to C5
so a big uh opening success there by uh
by doing and the reminder you know for
future players we're gonna play in the
world championship match so all of you
watching uh prepare for all the
scenarios even the even the French
and the one certainty you mentioned
ding's predictability this is the one
thing that you think you can hang your
hat on okay we can safely expect E4 E5
diga's been trying to push the envelope
all match long and yes for H3 was uh not
quite a novelty but an opening surprise
that didn't ultimately turn out that
well but I think what's lost uh in our
over Reliance on the results is the fact
that even for H3 actually gave ding
quite a good position right that game
didn't go south because of H3 it went
South because he decided to take the
Knight on F6 instead of taking on C5
which would have yielded a very pleasant
position so thus far uh ding's decision
to uh essentially fight is essential
unpredict his predictability and become
unpredictable has turned out
successfully almost every time he's done
that and this comes back to the point I
made earlier about not over relying on
the results right we have to evaluate an
opening Choice based on the position
that you get in the early middle game
not necessarily the results of the game
overall and of course the time situation
as well and yet again just like
yesterday he's got a good time Advantage
at this point which is unusual and he's
got a position where he feels
comfortable structurally and where Jan
might just not be quite as familiar as
he'd like to be with the typical plans
and ideas Tanya yeah that's an
interesting point to make that Daniel
about how you play an opening and
regardless of How It Ends you judge it
on based on the position that you get
the middle game that you get out of it
rather than the absolute result of the
game but psychologically that is so
difficult to overcome especially when
it's a mad situation because you also
know that your opponent is preparing
against that surprise I would be shocked
to see ding employee H3 or for that
matter Jana punishi with the white
pieces in the future to employ the
bishop C60 exchange variation of the
Spanish which also he got a good
position out of the opening uh but
definitely there it's important to keep
in mind uh that you can't just discard
an opening based on a result we've seen
great players like Maxine wash stick to
his night off regardless of sometimes
having bad streaks uh with the opening
and now finally Jan abomishi decides to
step out of the restroom he's come back
to the board he's having a think on how
to proceed in this one Queen E4 is the
move that we're looking at Anish you
were talking about the players uh and
their vulnerabilities that we've seen in
the press conference and how that's a
sign of strength to be able to talk
about that Jan's been very different in
press conferences he's been very guarded
about his emotion uh he's been
dismissive a lot about the game as well
sometimes we've seen him shut down to
certain questions do you think that
comes from his experience in 2021 on how
to handle the press conferences
this is the more indeed standard
approach what Yan does is nothing new I
think this is what his predecessors have
done as well I remember the press
conferences in the past players have
always been hiding
a lot there wasn't usually no there
wasn't sort of a gentleman agreement
that you would share your entire team so
uh back in back in the days when vishu
was playing all the matches at the
opening press conference everybody would
announce the team of seconds until
suddenly Magnus ended up playing Vichy
and he broke that Unwritten Rule and
after which he told about the entire
team Magnus just said no I'd like to
keep my team a secret and everybody and
wish you everybody was like oh is that
possible to do that and so the bar was
set even lower as to how open you're
going to be at the press conference is
also the team of Magnus has have always
been extremely extremely secretive about
everything even when it's obvious
um that something was has gone wrong
once I think it's gone right they would
always uh you know keep
um and you know it pretends that
everything is is all a big big secret
and nothing is known but of course we
can still deduce we have so many tools
we have uh the engines we have our eyes
and uh what notes to to see how the
players feel uh where the preparation
ended and so we can of course see that
also Jan is struggling
um with the human struggles you know he
he also feels attention he also makes
mistakes and just like just like Ding
and everybody else and um
here he is thinking because there's a
lot a lot to think about I do expect him
to play Queen E4 and Bishop H6 because
at least it solves the problem of the C1
Bishop
but um yeah definitely a big surprise
for young you know a surprise for
everybody as well I I watched different
experts and I also respect very much
Daniel dubov's opinion on
on these topics he is one of the best
prepared players in the world and very
experienced also in the world
championship match situations being the
second of Carlson and dubuff himself
also said you know before the match uh
when they asked what openly Super League
he said I predict Jan to be a bit more
clever and ding to be more direct and
from my experience against ding as I
mentioned earlier uh predictability was
one thing you could rely on you could
really rely on dink to play what he
plays you could rely on him following a
very clear cut logic very simple logic
um and it worked for him that was the
thing it worked for him before he's
achieved all his results being
predictable
so nobody's expecting suspected that he
would change but it seems that in this
uh tournament uh it's been such an
emotional roller coaster for him and
he's um he's been forced out of his
comfort zone and he is uh he's a changed
man by now stepping out of his comfort
zone more and more until just playing
the French in this game which is uh
which is almost the extreme I mean
there's no one has no no player in the
recent chess history has done something
this uh this out of the comfort zone
this unpredictable so he's completely
overstepped the mark you know and um
sets a new goal standard for for
surprise value
yeah and Daniel that's got so much to do
with the uniqueness of playing a world
championship match it's a match like no
other tournament that the players play
and uh being predictable or having a
specific opening approach in other Elite
events you can completely change up that
strategy for a match and that's what
ding has shown with his approach against
Yan we're also seeing a very different
thing than what we saw in the first two
days of the match he looked a lot more
shaky a lot less confident and of course
that's got a lot to do with the kind of
wins that he's been having to equalize
after trailing Yan uh now yeah yesterday
mentioned that it was his worst game uh
in the match and today we see him
slowing down a little bit he did make a
lot of critical bad decisions in game
six which were played super fast some of
the fastest moves were the worst ones
played which got him in a lot of trouble
so do you think that is a learning that
he's taken and we will be seeing a
slower Karma Yan going forward
I think Jan has made you know the
conscious decision to slow down a bit I
mean he's played slower than usual he
spent about 40 40 minutes in the first
13 moves but I think we talked about
this a couple of rounds earlier with
Anish the double-sided sword of Jan's
fast play Jan has basically always been
a relatively fast player uh really the
only other comparable player I think is
vishianan who particularly in the
earlier stages of his chesker was uh
very well known for essentially blitzing
out uh entire classical games he slowed
down a little bit later but uh he never
really had problems with time management
so when this works it works to
Perfection we saw this in Jan's Victory
with the black pieces he made some of
the most difficult and most critical
moves almost instantly such as the
exchange sacrifice and Knight C6 boom it
works to Perfection but of course when
it doesn't work it looks kind of bad it
looks like he's making critical
decisions without putting sufficient
thought into them so so it's it's a
really really tricky situation and uh
you know you just gotta trust your gut
instinct if you're young uh but I do
agree with the idea that uh he has
consciously slowed down just a smidge in
some of these critical moments such as
uh the move Bishop D3 which maybe
earlier in the match you would have
played a little bit more quickly or
maybe he would have blitzed out Bishop
A6 and by thinking a little bit longer
uh he's uncovered a slightly more hidden
but perhaps a little bit more venomous
idea of building the battery do you
think that Jan is before the game
consciously trying to decide uh what is
time management is going to be or is he
just basically trying to play it by ear
yeah Daniel it's a very good question
you were asking and I was also wondering
about the same thing when you mentioned
it I think some players try to do that
given uh what I know about Yan I think
he's the type of player who does not do
that I think his time spending is um
is entirely on a subconscious I don't
think he um he thinks about it uh
beforehand you should also realize as
you probably know very well as as well
as an experienced player that you are
and Tanya as well you're surely aware
sometimes you you try to play faster or
slower
but by no means do you follow that more
often than not it's because it's one
thing to say okay I'll play fast but
then then you're like okay but G6 Bishop
H6 rook d8 and then you know and the
moves are coming at you and you're
you're like okay I'll play fast but
there's a problem I have to solve here I
I want to play fast but I can't there's
a move I'm thinking about something then
so
um it's really hard uh to artificially
change
um your time spending also the process
of playing chess that is such a natural
process for a top player or for any
experienced player for that matter this
is something you've been doing for so
long of course you know everything
you've learned lots of lessons you
thought about it all um
you know consciously but the process of
playing there is something you do
automatically that is
yeah there's not something you'll double
triple check during the game you're not
thinking am I am I thinking enough am I
uh double checking Triple Chicken the
moment you start doing that this means
something is wrong the moment you are
double check double guessing triple
guessing and
um doubting yourself that that means
that something is gone so I I don't
think Jan has taken a conscious decision
to slow down probably the position just
provoked him uh to think he you know
it's a new position for him and uh for
certain things um yeah we're worth his
attention and maybe also it's a sign of
a little bit uh lowered confidence maybe
he's a bit slower because he lost some
confidence oh ding plays Knight F6
though that is a surprise for me
yeah yeah some really nice insights
there by your Niche on just the kind of
approach players have while playing and
it doesn't matter what you come to the
board thinking before it's often the
position on the board that dictates the
path and this was a path that we were
not expecting after the Checkmate in one
threat by Ayana we were talking about
the Jeep on advancing forward to G6
blocking that a battery and instead he
falls back with the Knight so defending
the pawn also attacking the queen we've
been looking at two options with
janapomnushy good sidestep go to H4
definitely a more aggressive one keep
the Queens on the board build up the
pressure or maybe the move Bishop F4
hitting the queen uh offering a queen
trade going into the end game and look
at Yan he's also slightly surprised uh
by the move that Ding chose right now
yeah I mean I'm actually very curious
what exactly ding has in his pocket
against Queen H4 because the way we were
looking uh at these lines and the speed
with which White's Pieces come out and
create threats against wax King the
biggest question for me is why like what
exactly is appealing uh to ding in the
position after Queen H4 he must have
something specific in mind maybe he's
tried to find a way to make C5 work uh
but unless he has a tactical and dynamic
response prepared after Queen H4 then
I'd be very surprised and I think Jana's
as well you can see it by the way that
he's consorting his face and he's
already pushed the queen to the side
John is calling things Bluff and we're
about to find out what he has in store
for us
big moment and
as well and he immediately barely in
about a minute or minute and a half
makes the move Queen H4 keeps the Queens
on the board keeps the pressure on H7 is
loose it is a Target and now what was in
ding's mind with this Knight Retreat
when he could have just blocked it out
with a battery to me it looks like this
is the start of a very very fascinating
middle game that we're about to see
yes indeed I think I understand what he
wants to play I think he wants to play
Rook fg8 and after Bishop G5 H6 Bishop
H6 he can take on D3 and on
H or first on H6 and then on D3 so I
don't think their the attack will will
be dangerous for white but after Rook d8
I think white can start with Bishop F4
just developing the bishop moves yeah no
I guess did I'm not sure oh the bar
didn't like it but I thought that was
the idea yeah
but I I don't find the position
comfortable at all I
I don't yeah I honestly don't understand
what purpose Knight F6 serves of course
he has played screen H4 quickly uh he he
sends his opportunity he wants to put
the pressure which before you mentioned
I think it hasn't occurred to him it was
a very creative idea I don't I don't
think that was the record to him um I
think his idea was to swing the queen
across
and uh yeah I mean maybe maybe there's
maybe okay C5 is the most natural move
so maybe C5 Bishop G5 H6 Bishop H6 is
not
working here because maybe something
here is strong for black maybe you just
take
and after Queen H6 you have
94 comes to mind what else comes to mind
Bishop E4 comes Bishop will probably
lose some material somewhere maybe now
you could try rook fd8 and then second
as well yeah maybe the sacrifice is not
dangerous simply um that that's maybe
not dangerous but uh even if the sack is
not dangerous well I have I have options
with white so don't tie some Bishop of
four perhaps
do you want to induce H6 and then drop
back to F4 or are you thinking
immediately go Bishop F4 well I I
assumed immediately is um
is a better move order
because I can always go Bishop G5 H6 and
then take if I want if I want that
well I I yeah I think probably ding is
hoping this that this works out but this
is oh yeah the stuff is a little
a little suspect
um I just don't see why because I
thought G6 was sort of a lot more safe
in that sense and after G6 also the
queen on e4 would be misplaced
significantly and after C5 it would have
come under attack now the queen found a
very nice position on H4 it's it's
sitting there very nicely but again
um a long term from a long-term
perspective Black's doing okay because
the bishop is on B7 is very pretty and
if there are no direct Bishop takes H6
tactics
I could easily see black having a fine
position if black gets for example the
move H6
um already there is uh
well there's idea of Knight D5 chasing
the queen and white sort of only
sensible way to make something of it is
Bishop H6 well the problem is that the
bishop machines could also be great so
yeah it's a it's it's a very uh very
concrete position
but I I wouldn't with black I wouldn't
dare
um no take all these risks where you can
just play G6 I wouldn't dare dare simply
I just wouldn't dare I don't see why
wow it does feel like a little something
for Yan and surprisingly after making
the move Knight F6 Queen H4 is
definitely something you have to take
into account and then ding goes into
another thing perhaps feeling a little
uncomfortable with what he's allowed it
may not be much but it does give Yan
that push that edge that nepo loves he
loves it right he loves to try to be the
one who will be creating an attack on
the king side the line that that I
really want to check and deep dive into
is the sacrifice that you both have been
talking about after the move eight six
stopping a piece arriving from G5
because it's clear Yan has one idea he
will either put the bishop first to F4
hit that Queen but eventually that
Bishop will land on G5 and then that can
be a lot of trouble for black on the
king's side now after eight six exactly
how dangerous is the sacrifice on 86
Daniel it was your instinct to go for it
immediately uh so take over this attack
how would you finish this off in a
bullet game oh man these types of sex
bring a smile to my face I I would say
it would be a great crime against
humanity not to take on H6 here but the
main idea is that you're going to bring
the knight in as far as I understand
into G5 and and to show how dangerous
this is Let's Make a random move for
black let's say black plays C5 you
contribute uh to the attack with Knight
G5 and the game is simply over because
white threatens Bishop H7 that's a quick
Checkmate and if black tries to open up
an escape Square for the king well that
just doesn't help here Bishop H7 leads
to forced mate if black takes then of
course Queen takes H7 and F7 is mate and
if the king slides over to h8 then
Knight takes F7 immediately is Checkmate
so white only has three pieces involved
in the attack the Rooks are not playing
a role and yet the combination of the
Queen the Knight and the bishop in this
particular set of circumstances is
sufficient if black is able to eliminate
even one of these minor pieces uh and
that Harkens back to the line that we
were looking at if it was black to move
here uh Tanya that crucial actually
Tempo would have allowed black to snap
the bishop off the board and the Queen
and Knight alone are just not able to
break Black's defenses so it's tempo for
Tempo but I think the tactics after
Bishop takes H6 work out in White's
favor Anish uh I don't think that Ding
is going to touch this with a 10-foot
Pole
yeah I think um the lines we looked at
that they were a little too Cooperative
I think black is even in danger if they
win a temple so starting with H6 is uh
well it's too proactive you should
probably make a move and then after
Bishop G5 go for H6 and then you once
you get an extra Tempo it will be less
clear I think the reason ding is
thinking because I obviously he expected
Queen H4 I think this Yan's facial
expressions they are so aggressive
um that they made him second guess and
doubt himself because indeed uh now he's
much more concerned about the second H6
because he thinks that well I thought
they are they're not dangerous I imagine
ding just plans C5 Bishop G5 H6 take
everything so okay what's that what's
the big deal
um and then when he saw Jan's face he
was like okay did I miss something uh he
hadn't realizes the importance of the
moment that you know the score and all
that I at the back of his mind and he he
has some time so he is trying to take
the time and think well why was Jan so
excited about it I didn't think this was
dangerous but Jan's face and I have to
say Yan's face iyan always surprised
with your move but uh I can tell you the
moment I realized when you should not
worry about them is that one dime I
played the only classical game and he he
blundered
he blundered a piece and uh so he
blundered the piece and he didn't see my
follow-up I made the follow-up and then
he made that face
and then I realized oh he just makes
that face when he's surprised it doesn't
mean that it's a pleasant surprise he
just yeah he just yeah he was he was
like he was like this like but actually
it was his blunder not mine and so
that's when I realized that okay Jan
always makes that face but he's
surprised it could be a pleasant
surprise could be an unpleasant surprise
he will make the face and you just have
to play your game and and so ding is
thinking and trying to find the right
continuation I for me I think yes I
could I always wanted to mention you can
still try try to back down and
make the move G6 still
anticipating Bishop G5 and in turning 95
but that would be really very very
inconsistent and I I don't recommend it
at all so I I'd expect mainly C5 or
perhaps Rook fd8 uh in both cases the
idea being that after Bishop G5 Bishop
H6 I gained the tempo and then uh I will
do something especially this move C5
perhaps is the most uh the most uh the
most contributing one to the to the
cause so after C5 Bishop g6h6 at least
then after you take everything I can
play 94 uh perhaps using the fact that
my um Bishop on B7 is now open I also
have C4 don't I have C4 just force uh C4
just forcing it
dislodging the bishop
in which position so C5 Bishop G5 H6
Bishop H6 GH Queen H6 and then C4
um
white has that Perpetual there with
Queen G5 and queen H6 and maybe the game
ends like that right maybe we have that
sort of Perpetual uh but right now I
mean it's a big choice for ding so you
know it's worth waiting uh to see what
he ends up choosing but Tanya move 14
and you know he's through 45 minutes of
thinking time
yeah this is such a critical moment and
uh an issue we're talking about Yan's
expression we saw it there and in the
chest World there are definitely certain
players who can be difficult to face
like that especially OTB especially over
the board because you can see these
changes in that these reactions in them
Hikaru comes to mind it can sometimes be
so overwhelming to play against them
across the board simply because you tend
to lose faith in your position in your
own moves you start doubting stuff is
that something that uh that
Anish you've ever faced playing these
top players or now you've you know how
how and what to believe when
well uh there was definitely an issue
for me and it remains an issue but
that's why you have to become a better
chess player you have to understand
positions better and have the confidence
that even though Hikaru made a face uh
it's it's him who doesn't understand
what's going on and not you and uh as
you get more experience these face
special Expressions it can also give you
more confidence because if you see
Hikaru made a surprising surprised face
and you are absolutely sure in your
assessment then this only benefits you
and you are aware of the fact that
Hikaru himself didn't understand what's
going on so it's it's a double-edged
sword also on the faces they can
backfire very easily you have to realize
so you have to imagine a scenario you
make a face
you make a face for a couple of moves
you know you're trying to put up
psychological pressure but uh four moves
later you are going into an end game
upon down where you have to defend and
it's crystal clear that you are worse
and then the opponent will feel the
momentum is changing and the faces you
are making you know in hindsight you
just look uh you just look quite
miserable and and the immediate question
that both players will have is like that
okay so you are making all these faces
and now you are pawned down in the same
game what's your point and you feel
quite stupid if you are the one making
the faces so you have to be very careful
as an experienced pacemaker I can say
you have to be very careful and time
your faces very well because before you
know it it can backfire so you better
make a face at the right moment uh you
better make a face when you got
something on the board otherwise um it
will backfire
yeah I always feel the nerves when that
happens during
the whereas a niche that it's at all we
gotta do is become better chess players
easy task ahead but right now of course
it is a tough task ahead for a ding Lin
as he has a big think in this critical
moment an attack is brewing I'm gonna
tell you guys to get your Brew because
we're gonna go into a short break and be
right back
[Music]
foreign
ER Danny wrench Chief chess officer back
again with more chess terms here for you
today we're going to talk about the past
Pawn the past Pawn must be pushed you
hear it said often and that's because
just about every end game you see that
isn't a blowout often comes down to
maybe someone's up one Pawn or maybe
even just the first person to create a
past Pawn is the person who goes on to
win that game we're going to talk about
what the past Pawn is and to find it for
you in today's video let's do it what is
a past Pawn a past Pawn is a pawn that
has no enemy pawns stopping it from
moving forward that means pawns either
on the file in which it resides or on
the adjacent files that would therefore
capture the pawn should it advance so if
a pawn has none of those things stopping
its way then it's time to push them baby
as our boy Yasser would say it as you
hear mentioned on many broadcasts that
you would watch on chess TV and on that
note as we look at our game examples we
like to do this is taken from Thomas
chefsky versus rajaba here white plays
the move 5x Glam which highlights again
it's not how many pawns you have but
who's going to be threatening to get a
queen first after black takes it white
pushes forward with gusto and because
the Rook can't blockade the pawn due to
the light Square Bishop this game is
already over black is going to have to
sacrifice the bishop for the pawn on B6
and white would simply be up a minor
piece note that after the first move B5
should a takes B5 have been played white
would have pushed this pawn and then
trap The Rook on A7 showing the power of
the pass Pawn as with it protecting the
bishop this Rook is completely out of
the game and white would easily go on to
win picking up pawns and just flexing
the Rooks muscles over the bishop for
the rest of the game so here we see a
passport being used as a weapon to just
cramp down and trap all of your enemy
pieces so this has been another chest
terms video hope you enjoyed it hope
you're enjoying all of them and with
that I will sign off hoping that you
learned something about what a past Pawn
is and we'll see you around on chess.com
thank you
[Music]
this is the 14th move of game seven in
the world championship match between
is in a thing at a very critical moment
after the last few moves Yana pamushi
has managed to create some threats some
some and definitely we can see their
ding feeling the heat he needs to be
critical at the moment he has decided to
start game seven with the French we've
seen some very fascinating opening ideas
and approach fighting in the match and
of course that has a lot to do with the
players teams their team of seconds
their trainers who influence them to
decide the kind of opening approach that
they have well there is another very
special player who is currently in
Astana it is the four-time women's world
champion who your fan and Mike Klein
caught up with yufan to find out what
she's doing in Astana
thanks guys we are here with four-time
women's world champion Grand Master hoyi
fun and the first thing we have to know
is were you one of the friends that Ding
Loren called after round two when he
wanted to improve his mentality
because if I do not review anything but
I have to ask are you on his team I know
you won't say Yes even if you are but
I'm asking anyway if you're talking
about the series of preparation no
okay fair enough now he has actually
been very uh open about his mentality
and other things are you surprised at
the press conferences that you've seen
from him
well to be honest a little bit a little
bit
it's been my impression I thought his
his player with the fair emotions
somehow I will understand you know
imagine such a a player and to play a
very important tournament and the first
time and also actually in China we have
a lot of Chess fans for supporting him
so I could feel that he might have such
a pressure you know to deal with all
right so there we go we've got a lot of
women's world champions but we're here
with the number one four-time women's
world champion Grandmaster how you font
now back to you guys in the studio
laughs
thanks Mike wow that was a fantastic
interview there really shows the kind of
atmosphere that is going on and we've
been talking about teams for the players
the secrecy that's important what's the
doubt for me was how you find said well
if you mean preparation then no Anish
what did you make of that and and this
whole secrecy surrounding the team of
players
yeah no that's
um that's one of the traditions of the
world championship matches today to have
a big big team of uh you know supporter
seconds
uh cook or you know particular food
because sometimes I can imagine for
example for ding
a Chinese food uh at least the ones that
I've uh you know the restaurants I've
been to in in China when I was there you
know it's it's a very different
um from the food you expect in many
countries I I guess Kazakhstan they
could have something to offer as well
since they're not too far maybe there is
some Chinese influence there as well but
uh the food the massage you know like
all sorts of psychological support as
well you could have
friends relatives you could also have
professionals there's some professional
psychologists for psychologists they
could would guide you sometimes so both
players you know at a match like that
always have some teams you you in
history you had cases unfortunately
cases they also had you know he had this
match with karpov there was a lot of
intrigue there they also had some
political tensions and I think at some
point there were the stories uh of uh
they were bringing this mentalists you
know the guys who are sitting there
hypnotizing hypnotizing each other a
person I was wearing this famous picture
of koshner with glasses trying to uh you
know trying to not get influenced by uh
by this hypnosis so lots of
a lot lots of things to talk about when
it comes to teams I I think it's also a
treat that we had hoi fun uh show up at
the broadcast you know these days
she is not visiting uh chess events this
option at some point she has gone into
the university life and now she seems to
be back to chess and that's really a
treat she's a legendary player herself
A Woman's World world champion and uh
you know I've played a lot of games with
her and uh top tournaments uh it was it
was always challenging I've lost some
she's a great player and so really happy
to see her here but okay she's not
making uh Parts not taking part in
things team I think she was never
um
I don't recall her being very passionate
about opening preparation of course she
did the diligence as a player she was uh
reasonably well prepared but from what I
recollect it was never a favorite aspect
so I'm not surprised that she doesn't um
doesn't join you know the uh well they
also I assume she is quite busy I guess
her life is filled with uh all sorts of
um challenges and uh well I'm not sure
yes that I would consider her to be a
likely candidate for for ding's team but
good to see her there for sure
Yeah a hundred percent she's such a
legend four-time woman world champion
and she said that if you're talking
about preparation no for me it also
implied the niche that it's so important
to have friends and a support system
around when you are in this very high
tension pressure situation and uh who
you ding mentioned it himself right he's
had his friends calm him down after game
one game two to regain his confidence
back and we see the thing that we're
used to seeing I remember in the Dubai
World Championship match with Magnus and
Yan there was such different approaches
in the kind of the team that the two had
at the venue yanstein was smaller it
comprised of his trainer potkin was
there as well as uh you know a few
people who were close to him in his
personal life but it was a very small
team meanwhile for Magnus his whole
family was present there was only Peter
Hannah Nilsson who was there as a coach
but he had such a big group of people
around him which who are not just
players and for him that seems to work
really really well Daniel what do you
think how important we speak about the
group of trainers and seconds who decide
the opening moves who decide the moves
on the board but how important is it to
also have this emotional support around
in such a big moment with so much
pressure on oh extremely important C5
has been playing nepo responsive Bishop
F4 will get to the move in just one
moment as the queen is attacked but I
just wanted to quickly add that there is
a rich tradition of having an assistant
or having at least a team of seconds
really since the first days of the world
championship because it really takes the
village uh to be able to suffer through
uh this level of emotional stress even
Wilhelm steinens the first world
champion uh he had an assistant named
Potter was one of the strongest players
uh in England who was basically
traveling with Stein is Paul Murphy when
he traveled uh to Europe in order to
challenge the strongest European players
of his day he went with a guy named
Frederick Edge who handled all of his
correspondence basically cooked his
meals tied his shoes and did other
things that chess players are really
known to do so uh you know you always
need at least somebody some players uh
they they take a whole village with them
others they take one person or one
Confidant but you really can't do it
alone and uh on that note let's get back
to the game Bishop F4 an instant
response Anish by nepo who is now fully
in his element
is he feeling more confident than ever
this game
yeah Ian likes to put the pressure on
the clock of course especially when he
worked out to move or when the move is
obvious to him I think this bishop a
form of indeed is uh relatively uh you
know an easy one a low-hanging fruit
there for Yan because Bishop G5 H6
didn't seem too appealing I guess that
was the draw in best case for white
sobish before first and uh now it's on
ding I think B6 is the most natural
square of course but you could also make
an argument for C6 trying to pin the
Knight
for now although in the long run of
course uh I even move like Queen H3
becomes an option 95 would come with the
tempo so I think Queen B6 is the the one
the move to make but then um then we'll
be a more interesting moment I think uh
Jan will have to choose between
different options Bishop P5 comes to
mind but then once the bishop is on E5
H6 will feel much more safe and instead
of Bishop E5 or Bishop G5
there's also a
oh Bishop takes H7 is a tactic but I
don't think it's a very good one because
after you win that pawn you will uh
allow Bishop takes F3 in the end and
queen B2 and uh well there are some
night moves Knight E5
Knight G5 Knight D2 Knight G5 probably
met by H6 so probably Knight E5 or
Knight d2r
are the ones that make sense 95 is of
course the more natural route forward
but Knight D2 skips the E5 Square
available for the Bishops still so both
some have something to say for it you
have to realize the B2 Pawn is not
hanging because of Rook B1 so I can
afford to ignore this uh threat oh now
indeed 97 is uh it's indeed a juicy
juicy thread there ugh
this is nasty
this is nasty are we sure that Queen B6
is is the most prudent option maybe the
queen should stay closer to home base
with Queen d8 obviously not a good sign
but Queen C8 queen d8 I'm not sure what
the difference is but if you do play
Queen to d8 the one perk of this is that
95 could potentially I thought be met
with a move like Queen to D5 and if you
can induce the move F3 well that's a
serious weakening move that opens up
further possibilities for black Tanya
where do you what does your intuition
say where should the queen go
well one thing's for sure that you don't
want to block the
at the queen with the bishop because
let's say you were instead to play
Bishop D6 you'd love a trait of the dark
Squad Bishop but I think Bishop G5 would
be super dangerous in this position now
you're hitting the 87 Pawn on the F6
Knight with a lot of power so you're
asking me a tough question where should
black move the queen you were talking
about the queen d8 Retreat it's not the
first move that came to mind simply
because I also felt that this allows
white to put a rook on the open D line
and start targeting that Queen on d8 and
you might start feeling a little
uncomfortable also it's just so
unpleasant to make a retreating move
with the queen to d8 where it started
from so I'm gonna be surprised if ding
chooses this option uh the move Queen B6
for me just felt so much more natural
yes these lines with the Knight jumping
in look very dangerous but I just still
feel that Queen B6 is somehow the move
that at least if I was playing Blitz
Daniel that would be the hand move for
me in this position Queen d8 very high
class stuff
we have a Gambit suggestion there in in
chat they're asking why not to take the
Knight and double the pawns nice idea
but I think noted the cost of a queen
because currently the queen is still
hanging so you probably want to take
care of that and of course once you do
white will no longer allow it so there
was no real time for doubling the pawns
because if you could you certainly would
but as the queen moves the Knight will
also move away and um well I think ding
might have underestimated something here
56 on the board yeah the maximalistic
approach sort of the best Square for the
queen but after 95 you do have to have
find a good response I think I can deal
with the thread Daniel of 97 with a rook
coming to d8 but the question I have is
whether that's enough there are also
some other threats there's the bishop
takes H7 thread yeah
it's quite quite looming uh
oh gosh and if you're mentioning Bishop
A7 I have to ask you guys if Bishop 87
immediately this is a line you touched
upon briefly in your analysis does black
simply capture on H7 and then when white
free picks up the bishop on E7 are you
going to destroy the king side is that
what you're counting on with Bishop F3
will will come in very handy Lian
doesn't want to waste his time he's on
our time yeah okay 95.
95 on the board already on the board
wow
huge threat
are you seeing uh Daniel or Tanya uh are
you guys
you guys are a good team uh you know
Daniel or Tanya a good good good team
there you guys seeing a defense for
black because uh I see the bar also I
trust dink but the position looks
extremely unpleasant to me and I I don't
even see how to how to defend from
from the basic threats I have a crazy
idea and it probably doesn't work but
I'm gonna throw it to you guys to refute
it so if I was to make a move like G6
okay stopping that mating threat and if
my only thing is that if you're going
Knight D7 I'm counting on Queen C6
is that a tactical resource that black
can count on that often Knight D7 there
is the option to go Queen C6 you have to
take care of the e87 point before
yeah I had that thought as well but I
was uh worried about other things like
Bishop G5 it was was very very
disturbing and you don't have a natural
way of unpinning so I uh no I I was
really struggling for for a move but
given the fact that the bar is still
saying is that it's okay there's
probably a move here
but yes yeah we have to dig deep so Rook
uh d8
so if you go with this truck yeah I
think there's Bishop H7 and just to show
the point is that F7 is now hanging so
not only you're down upon but you're I
mean Checkmate in two is being
threatened this is out of the question
so maybe you go with the other Rook to
d8 so that the other Rook protects F7 in
the event of Bishop H7 but still I I
dislike the look of Bishop H7 but maybe
there is something here uh Anish Knight
H7 Queen E7 and maybe in this position a
move can be found maybe Queen takes B2
actually
I'm not a fan of Queen B2 I'm thinking
maybe something uh something keeping
more more harmony with Knight F6 backed
spreading Knight D5 keeping the threat
you know stress being stronger than
execution
um keeping Queen B2 in mind
um also I have six threatens Rook D to
E8 uh trapping the queen actually
yeah I was thinking like G5 or something
like that in order to set up rook de8
but I couldn't quite put my finger on it
but I like the look of Knight F6 it's a
very calm move and it sets up a bunch of
different threats
can you start attacking the C5 Pawn now
I don't want to go Knight C4 again
because I've been C6 but maybe just fall
back with the bishop and start hitting
the C5 Pawn mm-hmm
yeah that's sensible very sensible but
uh well one good thing for black is that
at least the dangerous I mean the
dangers have been averted the damage has
been limited we lost the pawn but
um with black to move here there might
be resources there might be resources
the queen is okay is of
it's unpleasant annoying on E7 but it's
also almost trapped so that that's there
uh Bishop uh you know I I have a strong
bishop and Knight D5 is always a move so
I I feel like there is a potential here
for black to have tricks even the move
like Knight D5 and yeah it's not not
clear but Queen C5 probably did not but
ISRO kd8 the only just just to rule out
is H6 out of the question entirely just
to rule it out
version well GH we should just finish
the line I think now you just play Queen
takes H6 probably and again Knight D7
Knight G4 just too many threats on the
gang side this is like the ideal setup
and the Queen on B6 is just so misplaced
here it's just not contributing to the
defense at all so I I actually think
Rook da might be the only move
and man 55 minutes now for ding another
thing we haven't been talking about uh
wait a second you know he doesn't have a
second he's got 55 minutes uh he's used
over half his time and he's got the most
committal and most difficult decision
awaiting him right now
yeah and after Rook 88
um just to be sure that doesn't quite
have something even more dangerous than
Bishop H7
something more Bishop G5 Knight G4
related let's say
so let's try Knight G4 first
maybe no no Bishop E4 doesn't work
because the bishop hangs in the end
ah
can you click on D3 and try and make
something out of a jump with the Knight
I was thinking about the sack as well
but I'm I was not sure after CD3 if you
have enough compensation
um but I was indeed looking at the psych
also same same
maybe Queen C6 there no then Queen H3 I
mean you should not dismiss the move H6
always because maybe it's at some point
it's not going to be a Checkmate after
your second H6 but uh yeah it could be a
Checkmate here as well of course Knight
H6 and Bishop H6
yeah good luck finding a move here yeah
no there's probably there's probably
some move because the bar is also not
like saying it's all over but these are
serious questions that you have to
answer in a practical game
it's really not easy I mean it's not
obvious and you don't know if there is a
solution here I am really puzzled by the
decision to go Knight F6 and I wonder
what exactly did ding Miss because this
feels like a danger and 12 dangers and
this Bishop D3 Queen H4 Bishop G5 a kind
of
theme is so so
um you know it's so basic but I guess
maybe ding missed Bishop 495 idea from
afar I guess he was actually counting on
Bishop G5 and he can then just go H6 the
bishop f495 that's probably something he
missed so it is really strange that um
he didn't get alarm Bells going earlier
and maybe he has seen the defense all
the way through and he knows that this
is okay but I really doubt so I think
there are so many difficulties here for
black you don't really end up here on
purpose
you're not even sure you're okay here
and thing is indeed uh you know this
sense wrapped around around his head
he's in deep thought because he has to
solve some serious serious problems here
it might be the only move to keep the
balance in the position and then you
have to try to navigate all these
variations with the Knight jumping back
hitting on 87 how do you counter it not
an easy moment for thing we saw
janapamnushi there around his restroom
uh taking a bit of a walk uh Anish you
probably know these two players the best
here what do you think is going on in
Yan's mind right now can he smell the
blood can he can he feel that there can
be real chances in this game right now
well Jan is a very optimistic player in
general even when he was giving comments
about his last game you remember he he
thought that he was all right all the
way uh until he played Bishop C2 and
then he had just a bishop D3 which which
is a move that we also looked at with
David and I can tell you that move was
uh was it was an ocean but it was the
position was actually close to lost her
black so he is in general always very
optimistic which is good because in
chess it is I am absolutely certain that
it is better to be more optimistic than
pessimistic
so this this is a huge strength because
when you are optimistic you are in a
better mindset to exploit chances and
chess is all about exploding chances
both in the offense and in the defense
so Yan with his optimistic mindset he is
definitely uh definitely happy here even
if you are not optimistic you still see
all sorts of threats even I would be
quite thrilled here potentially with
white or I would of course being a more
pessimistic player I would uh you know I
still believe that maybe there is
something I'm missing and would not be
surprised if there is something but even
I will start getting optimistic but a
player is optimistic by default as young
of course he's thinking here the game is
almost over
but uh he's thinking okay I don't know
this guy why he allowed become H4 I
already made the face there after Queen
H4 and now it's 1995 he probably missed
now probably he's getting crashed
because 97 and 9g4 is coming and he's
also thinking so you know Jan is
thrilled but um dink should come up with
the defense if there is one and I
believe there is one so if you guys uh I
do want to still take a look because it
I think this is what's uh what's going
through ding's mind and it's very
important we had seen that dink by the
way is an incredibly resourceful player
he's he's the depth of calculation is
remarkable so if there is a defense he
will likely find it but let's try it and
I think along with him after Rook 88
which you guys say is the best move
and okay uh I assume it is the best move
I'm not sure I see a better one so let's
let's Okay Bishop H7 let's say okay I
will have there something I have some
composition this I trust but let's see
uh this night night to G4 move let's see
Knight G4 because here you you do have
to you have to show me the money you
understand
okay I'm gonna try I'm gonna try showing
you the money I want to sacrifice The
Rook on D3 I feel like that has to be
the first line we check exactly okay
okay I I take it I take it I don't know
this is the critical position yeah this
is not the money move please
where is Daniel I was gonna go for a
night jump but hey please help just help
me here fight anisha's attack I was
thinking about Knight D5 hitting the
queen hitting the bishop uh is there
something better that you see
Knight T5 is very logical I think from a
conceptual thing but I I would add one
thing which is that we shouldn't assume
that black has some necessarily has to
win the material back uh I think one
type of sequence that can be very hard
to find is one that involves essentially
garnering full compensation for the
sacrifice to exchange whereas a human
might assume that okay this has to be
something where we win the exchange back
um here white has two moves there's
Bishop to G5 blocking the attack
apparently there's something mortally
wrong with this move uh yeah
yeah uh very very nice the bishop drops
back and bang Bishop is defended the
Knight is going to be lost which means
that after Knight D5 white has to drop
the queen back and protect the bishop
and we have another money move here
Daniel that was a beautiful line the you
and Anish just said with refuting Bishop
G5 because in my head that was the big
problem but F6 F5 actually just turns
the table around immediately oh so Queen
G3 is the only move here
and I want to add yeah go ahead no sorry
I just wanted we just wanted to uh to
mention that I no longer have any
um any pretensions for attack uh attack
is of course gone once you capture the
bishop now I'm just hoping to sit it out
uh being up in exchange so at this point
I don't like White's position in a sense
that uh you know my pieces are no longer
active without light Square Bishop I
have zero attack but at the same time I
am up in exchange you don't have a pawn
just yet so I do think that black still
has to find a couple of good moves here
uh even though even just capturing the
bishop okay you will get the bishop pair
Bishop pair is huge but still you need
you need some moves and I think Dania
you were you were finding something with
Queen F6 virtue
man I'm I'm tempted by this idea that
I'm trying to work out but I just
realized there's a little flaw I was
trying to make F5 work in this position
and my idea was that after F5
I think does not hate it uh yeah 95 is
the problem because if white drops back
to E3 here I think after the trade black
has this move G5 and suddenly the queen
runs into some problems but now I
realize the queen also has the lateral
Escape Square so
I feel like these types of positions
black has some compensation but it's
clearly insufficient so perhaps there's
a more concrete way uh to to develop
compensation in this position and
probably this is what ding has in his
head
as he grabs upon and starts fiddling
with it
what could it be you should I this is a
secondary question I I believe
once we get there we get there but first
in the starting position that we have I
think this is ding's only option anyway
at least there is some activity here for
the exchange maybe there are some
compensation maybe not enough but I
don't think that there is a better
option so I think ding should go Rook d8
he should go Rook D3 and 95 and then
after Queen just three if you get the
position on the board you should think
later right now I think you should make
a move
Anish how critical is it for ding to
find Rook date you're saying it's the
best defensive move but is it the only
defensive move here it will dingby just
in big trouble if he makes any other
move apart from Rook d8 he cannot make
another move there is just no other move
that you can possibly make so he will
make rookie did I mean I just don't see
how to say uh you cannot convince
yourself to play a move other than Rook
date all other moves they they also look
bad like very very quickly so ding is
basically essentially wasting his his
time right now trying to oversee the
consequences of what's about to come
he's been doing it before he likes to he
likes to see a little further ahead he
likes to be prepared for what's about to
come before he makes his move this is
something that is fundamentally
different between him and Jan Jan if he
likes a move he sort of makes it he
feels as the right move and he thinks
okay we'll see what happens so he he
didn't see the he didn't see everything
after 95 to the end not at all but he
saw that this is the direction I want to
take and afterwards we'll see
and ding is very different he
understands of course he already seen
all the moves I mean there are two moves
Bishop H7 so there's nothing to see but
he already sees Rook 88 is what he'll
play he's trying to still see ahead to
have no surprises because it's very
unpleasant you know you make a move you
miss the opponent's response it's very
unpleasant and he wants to avoid this uh
shocks he wants to be prepared mentally
for what's about to come and he's taking
his time but essentially uh maybe there
is an alternative but I just right now
don't see one I just don't see a
candidate move that makes sense nope
and Daniel as you were pointing out so
some of the moves that might come into
our mind G6 runs into Bishop G5 quite a
deadly move hitting the Knight hitting
that Bishop you pointed at the drawback
of moving the F Rook to the d-line it
weakens the F7 Pawn the F7 Pawn will be
super tender once the bishop on E7 is
crap ding there he's kind of reaching
out for a move but then he holds back
it's like he's double checking he's
double checking the sacrifices and the
answering attack uh that we're seeing
but this feels like a very long thing
especially because big critical
questions will come on later on in the
game
no sorry I want just to point out that
uh of course uh it is not the right
approach to to waste your time in this
way because yes you mentioned tiny8 it
will come in handy and I think that this
is uh you you can get away with it and
ding has been getting away with it in
multiple games but in general there's no
need to waste the time so ding should
just trust himself a little more and
just make the move a little bit faster
yeah you can see that that hesitation in
him it's like he wants to make the move
but then he he withdraws his hand every
time that's happened about that's
happened a couple of times now but it is
a critical moment it is a difficult
decision from him we've seen this
narrative over and over again in the
match in moves that seem to be the only
the obvious defense thing taking a
little bit of extra time that little bit
too much time and will he make a move
this time Daniel will we see Rook d8 it
has to be the area I think I think it
has to be that move and I was just going
to quickly add it something about his
move Knight F6 it reminds me uh of the
movement is previous loss where he
grabbed nepo's Knight on F5 which was a
very logical move on the surface just as
Knight F6 is here hey let me avoid
weaknesses uh and let me make a Tempo
move but the problem is that it it opens
up Pandora's Box uh just as it did in
the previous game but ding he uncorks
the only way uh to keep the objective
balance Rook 88 is on the board but it
comes with a major price price tag he's
got 43 minutes on the clock and if nepo
comes to the board and just blitzes out
Knight to G4 I mean the the biggest
trial for ding is still ahead he's gonna
have to uncork the exchange sack and
then he's gonna have to find a move in
that critical position after Queen to G3
and remember we're sitting in the
comfort of our rooms uh you know we can
set our temperature what we want it ding
is sitting there at the board he knows
that tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands of eyes are on him and he's
got to find a critical move potentially
down in exchange this is going to be
real tough
we know ding watches it when Anish is
commentating so he definitely knows he's
got the eyes of the world on him right
now but he but he does Dodge a big
bullet with that move Rook today but
he's definitely used up the clock a lot
more than he should have and now it
comes back to Yana pamushi will he come
back and Blitz out a move Anish what are
you expecting Jan's definitely been
calculated and calculating and thinking
about these lines while ding was the one
who was on the board are you expecting a
fast response from uh from thing from
Jan here and will he choose the move
Knight to G4
Rihanna's capable of that for sure that
being said uh most other top players
would uh tank here for a while because
it's a very important moment and you
have to oversee the consequences of the
exchange sack now black is under
tremendous pressure that said that said
if black will navigate the complications
well
it is a three result game
because uh the you know if black finds
All the Right Moves I mean I see the
bars there in the middle saying that
okay it's more or less okay for black
and uh it could go either way but it's
the thing is that at this very moment
it's black that has to find
um a bunch of sequences in both Bishop
H7 black has to prove compensation in
Knight G4 black history proof
conversation and also the more Bishop G5
we didn't have a chance to look at it
yet just want to point it out that move
Bishop G5 looks playable to me as well
it or at least looks like an option to
me so just we should also make sure uh
rule out that move that is not a
possibility but uh yeah big moment for
Jan but knowing Jan he could have
already made up his mind and he could
just play quite quickly who knows
yeah we've seen him do that time and
time again and I just put so much
psychological pressure on ding to
respond we've seen ding go into a big
Think Tank on every move after that
night Retreat defending that eight seven
square so still waiting for Yana
palmushi to come back to the board Anish
you mentioned a really interesting
possibility we've been looking at Knight
G4 but let's do a deep dive Daniel in
this position after Bishop G5 a huge
threat capture the Knight mate in one
how do you see this going forward
I was initially worried about Rook to D4
here but upon closer inspection I
realized that the queen can drop back to
H3 so if we play the move Rook D4 I'm
trying to induce F4 then maybe C4 opens
up a line of fire to White's King but
after Queen H3 I was trying to calculate
Bishop E4 but there might be some sort
of Knight Fork on D7 at the end of the
line so the line I was looking at is
Bishop B4 and you can see it loses
because Bishop takes E4 this is really
pretty geometry all of a sudden you
don't think anything's gonna happen in
the center thing ah I can breathe a sigh
of relief I'm saved Knight D7 and uh
goodbye see you later Rook on fader and
okay that did not roll off the song No
you're a hater yeah exactly so Bishop B4
is not going to cut it Anish eval Bard
liked Rook D4 did we see a defensive
move here
you know Dania I keep coming back to the
move H6 because your attacking instincts
always tell you that Bishop takes H6 is
Checkmate but for me it's never obvious
I think that after HD Bishop page six
sometimes it can very well be another
Checkmate because you don't even have a
like a clear-cut threat other than
perpetual and you I think you will need
to uh lift your Rook via ae1 to E3 to
actually do some damage and that takes
some time so in the meantime maybe I
have some defensive possibilities so I I
do easily imagine here that after the H6
GH Queen H6 black has a defense I have
lots of options I can um maybe you know
this move C4 comes to mind always uh
okay psyching also of course possibility
and some some other move bringing the
queen closer to action lots of options I
feel for black here of course very very
dangerous but by no means lost and you
know as we know from
many such examples these kind of
positions just because you are attacking
just because your sack doesn't mean that
you win uh sometimes it means that you
know it's only enough for Preparation
sometimes not even that it doesn't mean
that the side attacking necessarily has
to win the game it means it's either
attacking you know it has it has uh
temporarily more fun but if you defend
well uh things can turn around and if
you've given up some material you're
also risking to to lose the game if one
if the side you know defending will be
able to defend so I'm not sure not sure
uh about all that and Jan is thinking I
suspect he's thinking in his resting
area he likes to think there as well
because actually he does indeed have a
very very important choice to make here
and it's a very difficult choice because
all of these moves look interesting and
it's very hard to oversee the
consequences here 94 is the greediest
approach but after 9g4 takes 95 Queen G3
it's clear that um you know you lost the
harmony you won an exchange but you lost
a lot of Harmony and players who want to
keep the you know the initiative more
prune prone to go Bishop G5
um Bishop H7 is sort of a middleweight
uh it's also grabbing some material
yeah it's a extremely important moment
here and um right now we'll be watching
uh you know crucial moments of this of
this match as anything is uh possible
here
yeah and I would just add Tanya I want
to know your opinion but we don't have
to analyze I would add that white
doesn't necessarily have to make either
of those moves either white could make a
general accumulating move like Rook F to
E1 uh preparing a real Cliff because I
asked myself well what is Black's next
move in this position and black has no
direct threat right you can't move the
Knight because you either drop the
bishop or blunder Checkmate you can't
take on B2 because of Rook a B1 so a
move like Rook fe1 or Rook ad1 is also
in the mix particularly these kinds of
moves can be effective when the opponent
doesn't have a lot of time because
they're what I would call open-ended
moves right they toss the ball right
back into black scored Tanya what do you
think we're going to see as nepo sits
back down at the board
yeah I love it I love the idea of just
bringing all your pieces into the attack
keeping all threats exactly as they are
and just forcing ding to have another
long thing a move like Rook to D1
keeping the ideas of the Knight jumping
back or the stack on 87 will be big
pressure what I'm most interested to see
is how quickly nepo does take a decision
here because I will also tell us exactly
how much time he's been spending
thinking about this moment while ding
was the one having the long think right
now nepho back and it's so fascinating
how these games just quickly turn around
it started with the French looks like
ding was doing absolutely fine out of
the opening a bishop B7 Queen B6 doing
everything right and then suddenly here
we are in this extremely critical moment
where there are big threats big
questions to be answered ding also low
on the clock and suddenly we've got a
game on our hands and it could go either
way right now I like the idea of
bringing the Rook onto the attack as you
mentioned Rook D1 but if it was my game
I'm gonna be honest I would go for
Bishop eight seven pick up that one
yeah I think it's a fascinating position
Tanya I think if you show this position
to like 10 different strong players they
would all have a different opinion
because this is so stylistic here the
greedy players would go Knight G4
because this is where you win an
exchange uh uh players you know who
um who are not so much into exchange tax
but prefer to take pawns like you they
would take on H7 uh you know the
attacking uh the attacking guys will go
for Bishop G5 because it's the most
direct move where you can sacrifice
something those who are more cunning and
devious like Dania they they even came
up with bringing the Rooks and I believe
there's very possibly there's not one
move that's better but this is a
fascinating stylistic uh choice and it's
also uh it's also a big question whether
you think about it all these moves
forever
uh like I could totally see myself doing
uh or whether you are going to take a
Snappy decision like Jan and Yan is
about to take with decision judging from
from his body language really you know
very very fascinating position in itself
big moment and Anish where are you on
this Spectrum which decision would you
make with Whitetail well I'm definitely
on the Spectrum the question is where I
am and that's a good one so I think
I'm I'm it's hard like one rookie one
rookie the bar has influenced me the bar
has influenced me if I didn't have the
bar I think I could I could not trust
you on Knight G4 like this was the first
move that came to mind I might not trust
you on that compensation for the
exchange because
um after Knight G4 takes 95 Queen G3
I mean I understand you have options but
it is a full Exchange
I don't know the greed the greedy in me
uh likes Knight G4 I'm not a
particularly greedy player but when it's
in exchange for nothing
I don't know it's in exchange for
nothing
so Knight G4 maybe
um because I have to Bishop version I do
I do a few compensation at the seven
Knight F6 back I don't like the queen
there I see all sorts of 95 jumps I
trust that a little bit less
I wouldn't I mean I I would be okay to
take on H7 of course but the thing is
that I guess if I was playing this game
I would start I would start by
asking myself uh what is black playing
after Knight G4 because if I don't find
the answer then that's for me is the
money move hmm
not too far wow and we're struggling to
find a response other than the exchange
sack then or Daniel Rook D3 looks like
the most natural response and weirdly I
it is and we were focused at first on
the position after you know Rook D3 I'll
make the moves on the board really
quickly because this is one of the
critical positions that we started with
and the question that we posed ourselves
we refuted Bishop G5 we thought Queen G3
is forced does black have a concrete way
to generate clear compensation and we
didn't find anything
too satisfactory but just my intuition
somehow seems to say that black is doing
fine here the idea of H5 came to my mind
we don't have to investigate it deeply
but I just wanted to add maybe I'm
pushing my agenda too intensely but the
more I look at the position after Rook
88 the more I'm reminded of these like
old positions that I used to get for my
coach where you know there's like three
or four attacking options but the
solution is always to make this
nonchalant slow move like rookie one and
basically build up the attack uh and it
would always be a trick question because
I would spend so much time calculating
the Tactical moves uh and you know
doretsky in particular which is a name
that breathes a lot of Terror into the
hearts and minds of Grandmasters he
loves these types of positions where the
move is like the ultimate anti-climax
especially once again uh passing the
torch back to Ding and forcing him to
burn more clock to figure out a
defensive approach so if I had to vote
for a move I'd vote Rook fe1 with Knight
G4 a very close second because as uh you
know Abraham Lincoln famously said an
extra exchange is an extra Exchange
and we've seen so many of these Exchange
prices in this match with some big
results so there is no doubt if Knight
G4 happens ding will a sack that
exchange on D3 and very deviously
pointed that as you mentioned the niche
by Daniel that you can just make a move
like rookie one a small little move in
this position in a blitz that's a
guaranteed flag right because your
opponent now suddenly has to recalculate
it has to rethink each of these tactical
sacrifices but your Rook is also joining
the attack scary stuff
yeah I certainly like this idea
um I I wonder how long it would take uh
uh me to come to eventually get around
that because indeed all these tempting
options they
they somehow
um lure you you know they they lure you
into the directions
um where where yes where where they're
heading and somehow you're you're just
you might just not realize while you're
busy uh investigating all these options
but yeah
yes my hand I also had the instinct to
take the a rook rather than the F Rook
because especially after Queen B2 like
you don't want the Rook to hang on A1
and you also want to protect the F2
Square just somehow in case I like that
through K1 especially as I do the rookie
through K3 then Queen B2 is no longer
gonna come with uh with the tempo so
rookie one I I like a cool decision by
Jan also played obviously reasonably
quickly
and it's nice now ding is uh of ding has
a really difficult task cut out for him
because he was just calculating all
these concrete moves because I know
think he's a very concrete player he was
uh worried about Bishop H7 and Knight G4
and Bishop G5 he was thinking about all
these moves and uh he probably convinced
himself that everything is fine but now
came Rook A1 and well I I would be
surprised if ding had anticipated that
that's a clear threat right you want to
also have a rook left Rook can come to
E3 and join the attack on the king side
and things can start getting super
tricky for black here expecting another
long think by uh ding there very
interesting how nepo chose the part that
Daniel you pointed out just keeping
things super tricky and super
complicated
yeah and I'm I mean I now that I look at
Rook 81 it does look a lot more natural
to me than Rook Effie one um even though
I understand that again the engine uh
apparently doesn't quite agree but
keeping the Rook on F1 just ensures that
your King's gonna be a little bit safer
you know F2 is going to be protected and
uh the niche pointer Queen takes B2 is
just as impossible as it would be after
Rook fe1 because simply The Rook travels
back to B1 uh and skewers the bishop but
this is yawn in his element He has still
played this move so much faster than I
think most top GMS you know I could see
somebody spending 45 minutes there
easily uh on a move for Hawaii but Jan
trusts his instincts and you know we
talked about the double-sided nature of
his fast play I think this is the
positive right this is where his fast
play is what is what has made him a
world champion Contender and someone
who's essentially unplayable when he's
in good form um Anisha might
exaggerating or do you think the black
is in fact uh practically speaking in
serious trouble here on the clock and on
the board
well yeah and uh we have the luxury of
um having the evaluation here so
again I can only say that if ding finds
The Good The Right Move it will be a
three years old game
but if we are to you know to judge
position by a glance well all the same
threats are have been kept my instinct
is to somehow calculate the move Rook D4
the smooth Rook D4 screams at me but I'm
wondering after C3 whether I can
and follow up uh with something good I
could second exchange there on D3 and
hope for Bishop A6 and try to somehow
regain that stuff but I am uh not sure
if that if that works that's just one
very concrete idea and if it doesn't
work it doesn't work but if it does it
does though maybe you'll go to the one
in Queen H3 you'll just defend it twice
maybe
and if not Rook D4 then I'm kind of uh
slightly struggling for for a reply uh
here I guess G6 becomes more of an
option now that after Bishop G5 we have
Rook D4 again
because before we didn't have this move
and after F4 we have some ideas of C4
opening up the diagonal and setting up
tricks so maybe G6 is a possibility now
certainly certainly more than the movie
earlier but I don't know still if it's
good because g4u also G6 you also have a
move like Knight G4 more more quiet but
not not just not as challenging just
going for that Bishop yeah maybe I have
Knight D5 or 95 95 you have some Bishop
E5 maybe some interest some pleasure
tactics there oh yeah
yeah yeah but uh yeah well G6 is
certainly a move now well what else uh
comes to mind what else that's the
question I mean I'm I would I wish to
move like C4 would would work it would
try trying to generate some tricks but
I'm not sure it does you just take the
pawn with the Knight and I guess you
will eventually
come back with a knight and you just
have gained the pawn not sure that does
a lot and other than that well it's not
easy to suggest uh move a rook fe8
perhaps isn't is an option sometimes I
don't know I was thinking about that
yeah but I don't know still there's some
move like magic forests
still a question
um
or rookie three maybe yeah a lot of a
lot of moves over Bishop G5 again again
all the same moves are there all the
same movesets on the Move earlier
they're still still there so well
difficult difficult choice for for Ding
and his time situation is not good and
okay if we um to be honest if we remove
the bar from the from the picture we
have a nice overlay there you know we
have three of our pretty faces we have a
board we have ding we have the clock
we've got everything there but if if we
only remove the bar situation would look
extremely worrying for ding if you ask
me personally
yeah and as the clock runs low he's
definitely feeling the pressure right
now some critical moments critical moves
to come up with there rookie one a
sneaky move by and keeping everything
under control all the attacking
possibilities what a match this is
turning out to be and what a game seven
this is turning out to be the players
are going for it every single game
maximizing their chances at every
opportunity and Chad if you have been
inspired by the player these two and
want a chance to play against them do
you dream of playing in defeated
Championship well chascom is making your
dreams come true kind of you cannot
challenge both World Championship
contenders in what form dingler and Jana
punishi Bots are available to play right
now at chess.com computer so head over
there and let us know if you can beat
the Bots use the command in chat for
more info and take a go have a go at
these players currently Tingler and is
having a go at this position trying to
defend and this could determine the
result of the game a big critical moment
we will be right back with the live
action from Astana
foreign
[Music]
I do recommend Meetup to a lot of my
friends that are looking for different
things wine tasting movies book club
meet a lot of new people a lot of new
friends and make you more social
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
what is a chess Dynasty
unceasing dominance move after move
again and again and again we have a
reservation we have history he is the
five-time fide World chess champion
but a chess Dynasty can also be cruel it
forces most to defer their dreams until
next time if there is a next time it's
losing my god did he just block yeah he
did I'm Blown Away the game is over as
the Chess World Turns to Kazakhstan the
Magnus Carlson Dynasty is set to close
the feed a world championship is finally
up for grabs for two chess Superstars
lying in wait until next time is now
she has methodically done what he needed
to do to get another shot at the title
the pressure to seize the moment this
time rests heavily upon him rest area
again just feels like he doesn't want to
come back to the board when he knows
he's in trouble and he knows he's missed
something
dingley Ren knows firsthand what the end
of this dynasty means an unexpected
chance to make history
can China's best turn his Good Fortune
into Eternal Fame you must be told
genius a beautiful finish from Ding and
the scores are Level momentum swinging
in this match day of the day
the legacy of this Championship spans
across centuries it reads from the names
of Chess Giants
for the first time in a decade a new
name will raise the trophy and be etched
into chess history
it's the 2023 feed a world championship
whose name will next be called champion
[Music]
singular and has to make 22 moves in 35
minutes on the clock now 34 a big task
ahead of him this is the halfway mark at
the world championship this is the game
seven history is being written in Astana
we see the players at the Saint Regis
Hotel right now at a very critical
moment of game seven and to call on the
action I'm your host Tanya sachdev
alongside everyone's favorite including
his own Anish Guri and of course also
the one and only Daniel narodeski and
he's slightly surprised there you mean
I'm My Own favorite is that what you
said
did you just say I'm My Own favorite no
I never heard this uh something that you
were concentrating on the position and
you just completely missed that no no
but it is true I am my own favorite I
just never heard anyone ever say that
about anyone but it's it's all good I
was just looking here I was looking
actually at the position of myself for a
change and um I was just trying to
understand what is the what is the big
deal why is yam so happy what is the
threats and why did he play Bishop G5
and queen H3 like what's the why yeah I
think we've had a couple of moves and I
think we should just back up because
this was a line that we were looking at
but let's get up to date on how we got
here because the players did play uh the
exact line that you were calling out
with Bishop G5
yes and I thought the the G6 stops
Bishop G5 because at the bishop I have
Rook D4
and I felt that for example Knight G4
looked much more uh threatening than
Bishop G5
but uh maybe Jan is hoping for a second
wave of his attack here
currently I am struggling somewhat to
see the
well I guess rookie 3 is perhaps his
idea or okay black has to make a move as
well so that's that's the thing that has
to make a move
and if you play Rook fd8 I think there
might be Knight F7 related tactics and
then Bishop takes F6 so
um
just to mention that Rook of d8 of
course is uh very shaky with the Knight
25 eyeing the F7 Pawn no but something
much more something much more uh solid
or something on the lines of Queen C7 or
queen d8
um trying trying to
to get closer to the to the king side
protect the bishop in 10 Knight D5 I
mean Knight D5 is really what you want
to play but right now it's um is met by
Knight D7
although I was looking at that sorry I'm
so sorry there is Knight F4 after Knight
D7 which should be factored in but
please continue
yeah I didn't see that obviously uh uh
and that that makes 95 actually a good
candidate move because then you you sort
of force simplifications
I I was thinking yeah the queen 728 also
didn't look too bad because I didn't see
the uh the urgency either I don't see
what Dwight's uh threat is as I already
said about 10 times I don't quite see it
so
um I don't know uh
what what do you think he he wants to to
play here what is the
C3 maybe for now maybe C3 uh kicking The
Rook back
to begin with
rub D5 or Rock d8 black has to be
another decision Queen H4 is sometimes
uh Connect Four back sometimes is an
idea in case of rotate I guess Rook d5's
most tempting maybe F4 yeah and now F4
and then you're still hope for Queen H4
but I have options I have Knight H5 uh
move some other night move perhaps also
to to for the trade of Bishops
mm-hmm
although
Knight H5 I think white already has to
consider like the double sack on G6
I mean it's I feel like it's getting out
of control for black and he's got 30
minutes now which is why I thought maybe
the immediate Knight D5 is an attempt to
solve LAX problems but the problem is
and Anish I think I agree with you if
you play 95 here Knight D7 Knight F4 the
point is if black if white takes Black's
Queen black takes White Queen with check
and then recaptures the Knight the
problem is after Bishop takes F4 Rook
takes D7 I thought white could just
drive the bishop down to E5 and I'll
show this one idea and then I'll let you
guys continue in the analysis if black
proceeds normally white of course has
this beautiful mating construction which
never gets old let me just make a random
move to show this idea of course Queen
takes H7 Rook H3 and then Rook h8 uh is
going to be a very pretty maid and it
sounds like we're just writing a tactics
book but it's actually not that easy for
black to stop this idea uh just because
you don't have uh sufficient Defenders
on the king side uh to to do all that
much about it so Anish I agree that
Knight D5 is perhaps a little but too
dangerous but given the time situation
maybe any Clarity in the position maybe
any sort of trade or relief uh is what
ding desperately needs here I don't know
yeah and I saw Tanya smile after uh
Queen H7 Rook H3 but I have to tell you
tonight I I'm
exposed to this on daily basis Daniel
continuously continuously showing um you
know a tactic after tactic when there
isn't one he sets up one so it's it's
extremely disturbing but I have to
endure it already for many days so I got
used to by now
but it's your first day so enjoy yeah
yeah it literally made that happen and
appear out of nowhere
it was absolutely crazy and suddenly
there's a rook on AJ checkmating black
but it's really interesting how these
ideas do exist and Anish I'm gonna point
out that it was back and move on move
nine that you had mentioned a potential
sacrifice on F7 with a knight on E5 with
the E6 being Thunder and we're also
seeing these kind of tactical ideas
appear on the board so black has to
watch out for these tricks and now I
agree with what both of you have been
saying that more trades the more easier
it becomes for black to actually handle
the pressure on the king side so Knight
D5 looks like a really nice move if
there's no immediate repetition to it is
that what you're expecting ding to go
for Knight D5 offer the bishop trade
dark squares a week just ease out the
pressure there
well I have to say uh Dania keeps
mentioning it and it indeed is the most
relevant Factor very soon the time
situation is really dangerous and now I
understand why young played Bishop G5
Queen H3 I don't think that's
particularly threatening continuation
but yeah I'm quite cleverly realized the
momentum and the fact that the clock is
um what's going to matter he didn't see
good follow-up of the G6 I don't think
he made that G4 Knight D5 work because I
think it maybe didn't so tricky young he
just made a move quickly
and he sent the ball back to dings Court
you know feeling the his opponent who
really really likes to think today in
general as well but today in particular
ding really likes to think I think it's
um a little disturbing how much time he
spent so far and now again he keeps uh
he keeps tanking and the clock I mean 26
minutes in a complicated position with
over 20 moves to go that is likely uh
going to be a main factor and even if
you simplify somewhat with the move
Knight D5 that position that we were
talking about
still lots of Tricks lots of danger to
avert a very very uncomfortable
situation for ding because of the time
yes
yes it's going to be a big factor and we
can see a reval bar saying that it's
pretty level but uh we're just 26
minutes and so many moves to be made
this could turn very tricky still some
critical decisions to be left uh for
black here ding the more he thinks the
more I ask myself what are the
Alternatives that he's looking at you
know Knight D5 is one that we're talking
about is there something else that holds
his attention because it's really time
to speed up now to start taking those
decisions and making the moves faster
because it's going to get very tricky in
just a few moments
well I I really don't know if Dean can
avoid the temptation of Knight T5 if of
course I mean we take these things for
granted but it's very easy to just
refute Knight T5 and then not return to
it because Knight D7 looks like it's
winning so first of all you have to see
Knight F4 but then that resulting
position after Bishop E5 looks
incredibly scary with those dark squares
just melting down on the king side so
let's say you refute that I just want to
Echo anisha's point at the start of the
game you know the 25 minutes before the
start of the game seemed like the
longest 25 minutes in history nepo's
sitting in the rest area and he's AGA
looking at his watch and every second is
taken by with agonizing slowness right
now these 25 minutes ding is looking at
the board looking at at his clock poof
another five minutes bang another five
minutes to disappear off his clock and a
lot of players can relate to this
feeling because there's so much to
calculate and there's no end in sight
and finally a move is made and it is
Queen C7 wow which is apparently the
best move
ding holding his holding the fort for
now but this is just the start
you know it's the best move uh only
based on a very difficult follow-up
after C3 Rook D5 F4
had a chance to look at the position in
more detail because after c35 F4 it was
very difficult for black to come up with
a move
and the right response there is uh Pawn
sacrifice with C4
which is a really difficult one and if
ding has that figured out I'll be very
impressed because if it if he's and then
He he'll probably regret this decision
because Knight D5 would at least
simplify the position somewhat and
indeed Clarity would be most welcome at
this at this point in time because now
he has C3 Rook D5 F4 will come
the tension the tension around the black
king is is very serious and uh you know
the the pressure pressure and thing
doesn't know the evaluation of the
position ding only sees you know all the
all the dangers he sees the clock
of course if things work out especially
once white has played at four it could
also backfire because you weakened
yourself a lot already you've banked
everything on the king side attack which
might not work out
the clock situation is highly relevant
in this type of unbalanced positions and
so yes
I mean C4 I don't even know like Bishop
C4 I guess Rook D2 here is the point
Rook D2 because it's not true for us to
be considered because Knight C4 and then
try to come back to E5 and look stare
black in the face and say thank you for
the pawn what's your follow-up there's
these additional checks but if you just
randomly give a check on C5 that's
really bad because now the knight's
gonna hang and White's King is perfectly
happy to tuck itself away uh on on H1 so
when I say there's no end in sight
there's really no end in sight to the
amount of computer moves the ding
apparently has to find uh to stay afloat
and a niche if he doesn't find C4 I
think this is the pivotal question how
bad is it Knight H5 the Bishops
that is the move that I uh that was the
move that I mentioned uh that's the one
that uh ding likely uh Banks his hopes
on but I I'll be worried about
everything starting from Bishop H6
when now removing the Rook is really
welcoming Knight F7 so probably you have
to play Knight G7
but
white has a free hand there and might
try to
try to build up more pressure
yeah Knight G7 now a Nepal like move
would be Rook E3 or Rook F3 I just want
to show what happens if black in fact
moves The Rook away to d8
does white already have a second F7 at
least that has to be calculated probably
not in this exact version
oh and this is funny because after Queen
takes E6 this darn Bishop on H6 covers
the knights Escape score which would be
a double check so here white would have
to be very careful but
why does an abundance of options that
that Ding would have to calculate even a
slow move like rookie 3 Knight G6 I mean
Tanya this is ding might just have to go
for something like this and just say you
know what I'm throwing caution to the
wind whatever happens happens I don't
have the time to consider this in any
amount of detail
um right now it's Jan's move right and
ding is definitely using this time as
well to navigate all these calculations
and these lines that we're looking at
but Queen C7 that's a very brave move
and we saw the eval bar approve it say
that it keeps everything under control
not an easy move to make in already a
very difficult position and I just
wonder if it's because he perhaps missed
this tactical trick of the response to
Knight D5 Knight D7 because you're
really dreaming of trading the pieces
and it's it's kind of easy to miss that
it's easy to miss the the resource that
that Knight could have jumped to F4
taking care of that fork and instead
we've got Queen C7 now on the board so
things getting tougher Yan currently not
on the board not on his chair having a
sink in the restroom and once again it
will be about how quickly he makes the
move because knowing Yan he's going to
use the clock as a huge tool in this
game
guys
no I mean I think the silence it
represents how complicated this position
is I I just don't have much to say
exactly that I all I have to say is that
I really think that nepo it would be
very consistent with his style to
quickly Blitz out C3 and F4 because the
price of each move for white is not all
that high White's got everything
defended and this might be the most
depressing thing about handling the
black pieces here which is that you
aren't actually suffering for anything
you're not even up a pawn with that
being said I don't want to overstate the
case because obviously yeah John's back
let's see if he makes a move quickly
it's not like white is playing with a
carte blanche I mean White's pieces are
also suspended in mid-air the bishop on
B7 which has been an you know ever
present for since the start of the game
that can be a very strong piece so it is
a double-edged position do not get me
wrong and it's easy for Yan to burn a
lot of clock here as well he's under an
hour too and he hasn't even made move 20
uh but if he finds C3 and F4 or he
really pushes ding I think to the brink
with all these moves that you're
mentioning it just feels like for white
these moves are sort of easier to find
while ding has to find moves like Queen
C7 calculate tactical resources of
saving that and that's always a way more
difficult task to do than what Yan has
at hand is that fair to say Anish
yeah and it always feels almost unfair
that Ding has less time on the clock but
at the same time this is not unfair this
is the consequence of how much time you
spend so far and this is the consequence
of facing Jan and you said that Jan can
also easily tank but he won't and we
know that he won't he will play quickly
uh c3f4 is screaming to be played even
if he notices C4 and the consequences
are unclear it will nonetheless go for
this leave it to ding um to follow it up
and I am really wondering in a case like
that given the situation long situation
I really wanted at some point AI
um AI based software will come out that
will give an estimate of How likely the
game will end and that will be our
future bar and not the bar we have right
now because I think taking all the
factors into account the complexity of
the position the narrowness of the path
thing has to follow in the time
situation I would really feel that um
even though of course Dean could
actually win this game
the uh the bar of this game you know the
bar that represents uh the likelihood of
Jan's winning it should be on the white
side right now because I think that um
things are looking good for him and the
fact that you know the black has so many
resources
yeah they it it's you know it could mean
that link takes over the initiative but
I find it all very vague and very hard
and yes I wish uh you know as a ding's
fan uh you you'd wish uh I think to have
much more time and for this to be a more
fair fight but of course it was fair
because Jan was just playing much faster
but now ding is definitely definitely
the one on the defensive
it all seems to come down to that night
Retreat to F6 right all this pressure
that we're seeing on the board could
have completely been avoided had they
chosen another path to defend with the
g-pawn moving forward which eventually
he did but in worse circumstances and
now here he is having to deal with this
we've been talking about the line with
pushing that pawn to C3 hitting that
Rook The Rook falls back hits the Knight
and then the move F4 and black has to
deal with ideas of The Rook coming into
attack with Bishop C4 E6 being tender
the clock situation Anish you made a
really nice Point how if the the AI was
a little more practical and more human
we would see the eval bar actually tilt
towards Yan just simply because how
difficult the position is from a human
perspective to keep under control
uh Jan here still having a sink uh what
do you what do you make of that uh
Daniel do you think we're gonna see C3
or is there another attacking idea that
keeps things under control but keeps
ding from again forces thing to go into
a thing and use the clock more
or will you go for a direct line with C3
our star producer Vic is suggested
Bishop C4 should I think absolutely has
to be considered with ideas like Knight
F7 and Bishop takes C6 uh so that is
definitely circling around nepo's mind I
if I had to make a prediction I would
say C3 and then jump on the AI bandwagon
what would be one way uh to quantify the
difficulty of playing a position where
well already now you can run a search on
megabase the largest collection of games
assembled uh you can run run a search
based on piece location so you could
basically say I want all games where
White had a bishop on D3 and Knight on
E5 and a queen on H3 and black at a king
on G8 uh so you know this AI could run a
search for similar positions or
positions as similar as possible and
this is not an uncommon structure like
I've seen attacks exactly like this and
then it could measure the results uh of
the players on the defensive side let's
say white scores eighty percent uh
against an average rating of 2600 uh in
similar positions so it takes things
time into account so I really think
there is a future in terms of this
quantum
interesting idea
let's co-found this because I think the
approach to build it would be quite
simple you would need to just feed all
the the games in the base uh with the
timestamps and that's the beauty of uh
of the deep learning is that it would by
scanning all these games and uh you know
seeing the um the outcomes it would
essentially figure out all these
patterns on its own and it will take the
clock into account and uh it would it
would find out all these patterns on its
own that's the beauty of it you don't
even need to feel this particular
pattern it would itself know that uh
because uh yeah essentially what it what
it does now it shows you know it is it
is built to play what we have is an
engine evaluation of an engine that is
built to play and to win
but this is not a commentator this is
not a chess commentator you know and if
you want to ever replace us you need to
build the software that predicts the
outcome of the human game and that's an
entirely different
um very different task than building a
computer that is um built like a
building a killer machine that is just
built to destroy everything that it sees
so yeah the bar should definitely be
taken with a
with a grain of salt here and Yan indeed
has all these tempting options c3f4 is
screaming to be played but uh indeed the
move you mentioned is Bishop C4 move uh
that is also one potentially one move
Yan can can make and okay there are
probably others uh you can probably make
a slower move if you want Bishop H wait
isn't Bishop H6 is also a very tempting
idea in Knight xf7 isn't that actually
obvious
we must build that uh type of AI
um okay now let's get to Bishop H6
a new business idea a co-founded by
Anish Guri and Daniel narditsky I might
be a shareholder in that company but I
love it a way to quantify exactly how
difficult a position is to play from the
human perspective not being able to find
the best line the one line that keeps
everything on the balance but right now
uh never needs to find a line that keeps
the pressure up Bishop 86 let's do a
deep dive it's a very direct approach
starts threatening that F7 tender Pawn
how does black counter the attack on The
Rook with C4 is a move that uh that
exists maybe that is a problem
and if Bishop takes that f8 just Bishop
f8 I can just take right yeah oh and
you're gonna give up The Rook for two
more minor pieces if I play Bishop C4
and I have three three light pieces yeah
this is wonderful for black isn't it the
king is now so much safer that I
collected all your light pieces your
Rooks are useless
amazing position and queen for three
pieces is a very common sacrifice you
see two Rooks for three pieces uh a lot
more rarely but you know Black's King is
the happiest it's been all game here C4
is a great find uh easy to miss by the
way especially in a Blitz game
but it's kind of the move it's the kind
of move that turns everything around and
it might just be the only one right
because if you go for the alternative of
trying to save your Rook you might lose
on the spot after Knight F7 and queen E6
uh coming in
yes and it's something that Ding had to
see when he played Queen C7 it's
something that Jan discovered now as
well so these are the kind of lines that
uh players calculate that don't even
surface uh you know they come to the
surface when you analyze with the
computer because computer already sees
that it doesn't work for white but these
are the kind of lines that the players
think about there's a lot more to the
position very often than what meets the
eye if you follow uh the AI but uh yeah
of course uh lots of hidden tactics here
lots of
things to think about for Yan because uh
especially Yan he doesn't like to waste
his time he never does so if Yan is
thinking it means there is really
something to think about
yeah this is the tension is just at an
all-time high now I mentioned that it's
easy for Yan to tank and you know not
saying he is tanking but he spent 14
minutes on this move he's got 48 minutes
I think he's close to making a decision
I can just kind of feel it but Black's
King is just Breathing heavily and
saying white pieces could you please
already leave me Elon
all right I'm done
you guys can take it away now
so bad
so bad wow for seven a.m
if you're online
it was great Daniel okay so yeah
yeah he he's deciding which path to take
and of course we've been talking about
the clock situation and how tricky that
is and how there are some critical
decisions still to be made by ding which
can be very costly so he needs to keep
control on that now she is a player
who's so dangerous not just with his
style of play but also how he handles
the clock in pretty much all formats and
not too long ago Daniel you spoke to Yan
about the difference between classical
and rapid play Let's Take a look at what
he had to say
I mean of course it's more entertaining
to to look I don't know some three three
plus o and flagging each other but uh I
mean okay I think I used to be quite
good at this as well yeah but back then
and maybe I can also you know
get back to some of my Esports skills
but their priorities have shifted yeah
absolutely absolutely so I mean in terms
of enjoyment for me yes so I really find
a good classical game which you're not
necessarily win but you have like a big
Clash so you like spend a few hours
thinking about something really really
interesting to try to also get to into
your opponent's head so how is he
thinking what is he planning and when it
just happens everything is happens in
you know in in three minutes you have a
result okay that's uh quite favorable
for our time overall but uh I think it's
you know leaves most of the almost every
Beauty behind the scenes
and then Levon are
on our own City and beauty of this Chess
World Championship will remind people
that classical chess is quite often far
more watchable and exciting than Blitz
or rapid Jazz a chess boom combined with
the lack of classical events does not
make sense and guys I have to say I
completely agree and I saw anisha's
tweet as well on that he also completely
agrees with this sentiment we've been
talking so much about how rapid and
Blitz is here to stay and it's sort of
becoming this big Mainstay in the Chess
World but the one thing that this world
championship match has shown us is just
how beautiful how intense and how
watchable a classical match can be the
audience our viewers are just glued to
this world championship because of the
decisive games the kind of action that
we are seeing here and classical chess
isn't going anywhere Anish
yeah and the beauty is that when you're
watching a classical chess you can talk
about the beauty of classical chess
while the same time talking about the
game because when you're looking at a
rapid game you can only talk about the
rapid game because of the pace it is
it's so fast so here we can take more
time you know and philosophize while
give the players a chance to go deeper
and Beyond what they would usually play
and um I was actually I wanted to
suggest move B3 but I was very shy
because sometimes there are moves that
come to my mind but I feel like they
could be very bad and I don't want to
give away how bad a player I actually am
so I'm like keeping these moves to
myself I'm like okay it's probably a
horrible move but just uh
but yeah B3 is very slow it's a prepared
to remove now you prepare Bishop edges
but indeed um I was actually thinking of
Knight D5 possibly Knight H5 is better
if thing played that but either way it
looks like the direct danger has been
averted and uh you know
unless there is a strong follow-up
I start thinking that I see black taking
over already
oh what if Bishop H6 uh guys I this is
what I was struggling to figure out I
thought maybe Knight F4 is this idea
maybe an exchange sack but I don't know
which one exactly
metaphoria what of tonight before
let's make the moves on the board for a
moment Bishop page six if Knight F4
yeah what is yawn planning here because
something interesting
Queen
oh my goodness what a tactic
yeah
bang and then you recapture the queen
with an extra piece but
not to spoil the party that was an
incredible idea in this position can
black find some sort of alternative that
keeps the status
Bishop yep
Bishop H4
yeah
4.92
this is incredible you know Daniel this
is exactly why classical chess is so
fascinating right we get to look at
these depths and these lines and it
reminds me of uh of a tweet that I had
earlier on I think it was the day that
someone mentioned that classical chess
is like it's like a chocolate mousse
that you've got the time to really enjoy
and take in everything and not just
gobble it up really quickly like is
often the case with rapid and Blitz the
adrenaline is so high and we all love it
and and the action is fast paced but
when it comes to classical you can truly
enjoy the high level chest the high
level moves that the very best in the in
the world play
and and the build up in games like this
is incredible I honestly think we got
jaded from World Championship matches
not assigning any blame here but I think
we're now collectively as a chess
Community uh commentators Spectators
beginners Grandmasters we're
rediscovering what makes a world
championship match absolutely amazing
it's the buildup of tension it's the
multi-layered story lines you know the
fact that they're playing a world
championship you know the build up as
the time dwindles the fact that there's
no increment uh love this time control
so there is a possibility of a Time
scramble it's not like time is taken out
of the equation people also have to
understand that and ding 23 minutes on
the clock for 20 moves you know don't
tell me that uh he's not gonna feel the
burn on the clock so this is honestly
incredible and I think a lot of people
are rediscovering the beauty of
classical chess uh with every move
that's being played I don't think Janda
palmnushy though is uh rediscovering the
beauty of his position he's discovering
that black is a lot more tactical ideas
on the king side than he anticipated
ding says hey you thought inside belongs
to you no all of the squares belong to
me
Anish is it possible that Jan either
missed or very very seriously
underestimated simply the idea of the
trait of the dark scored Bishops
I think frankly he's a little drifting
at this point so he was planning
something more direct like C3 F4
probably or Bishop A6 Knight F7 then he
decided he discovered that he missed C4
probably as he discovered that he missed
C4 he reacted to it and played B3 and
now he realized that he missed a bunch
of other things so uh this kind of his
control of this game is living away from
him uh and well I I think uh I started
liking Black's position more and more
but that said Jan still has got the time
Advantage position is still uh even in
my last two cents on the topic of uh of
classical chess is I think one other uh
big advantage of a classical chess over
over the rabbit not to say that you know
it's better but an advantage that you
have um as a player in a classical
tournament is that it's much more um
interesting and tempting now to analyze
openings much more deeply and follow you
know um come up with some crazy
dangerous exciting ideas because very
often in a rapid oblique game
if you prepare some idea and then your
opponent will uh you know will somehow
make a mistake or fallen into your pre
or into your the Trap that you know
yours you said with the computer
preparation you often need time to
realize what it is that you've actually
prepared because you know a lot of prep
is done with the computer and often you
don't even know yourself what is your
own point and uh so a lot of prep can uh
can go to waste and what you see is that
many players they choose not to prepare
also besides having to find the
follow-up often players don't have the
time to remember because often you have
so many lines to to remember and
sometimes you need to take a 10 minute
thought to recollect what what you
wanted to play and uh in the classical
game it's possible that's why you see
for example some incredibly deep opening
ideas played
um for example in games of Fabiana
caruana you know yet in this match you
didn't see so many defense because the
players were taking a different approach
but for example in the games of five
like you can recall that game 5 against
Maxima shilagra from the candidates
where you know he follows some crazy
crazy neither of poison Pawn variation
where he plays some Wicked novelty and
then he was able to make sense of that
idea and convert it beautifully uh just
thanks to the fact that he has so much
more time so you can kind of build on
the prep and that's why you see in Rapid
chest top players no they don't do this
they don't
um show any deep computer prep instead
they just play some some line and just
get some position and then play which on
the one hand is more creative on the
other hand you um yeah you don't get to
see the the full beauty of the computer
generated prep which is actually in
itself
um well it it might sound like a
negative thing to your computer
generated prep but for many players it
is a you know you could also see some
some beauty there so that's the last
thing I want to say on that topic but
other than that uh I think we'll have
plenty to talk about uh In This Very
position because uh lots of variations
what happened in Jan is taking his time
because it's really hard to understand
what's going on after Bishop E3 or
Bishop h 6 and Bishop takes E7 would be
an admission of of uh you know of a
local defeat because then you definitely
don't have the attacking potential and
you'll have to start defending
hmm yeah a big moment before we jump to
the chess action Anisha we're talking
about preps I'm just gonna ask you one
question around it Hikaru recently
mentioned that he thinks that you are
the player currently with the best prep
with the best opening understanding in
the world would you agree and then we
quickly jump over to the move that we're
just seeing
it's a cool move
it is a cool uh I I watched the video
yeah I think he kind of thought it was
uh it was me right he thought it was
what he did he think it was me or he
thought it was me right yeah he said
earlier he would say Fabi but now he
thinks it's you he thinks it's me yeah
okay so he thought it was me okay I
don't know did you think it was me or
I thought it was me okay no no yeah I
saw the video no he said it was me yeah
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure it
was me yeah
I'm a big fan of Hikaru big fan
yesterday you know we were we had a call
with you guys just to you know to get
ready for the broadcast and um we are
watching Hikaru stream you know it was
it is hard so to resist his um such a
tremendous streamer and we should value
his opinion on various topics especially
when um the opinions are positive about
me
so I'm very grateful but I have to say
that you know opening preparation is a
very fleeting
it's a very fleeting factor it's like um
you can be well prepared uh you know but
then a few months go by and uh
and you no longer well prepared it's
it's it's in the moment it's like you
know being a good player you have to
always prove it and you have to
continuously keep it up
so well I I in my last tournaments I've
showed some good prep but it's a
continuous process you have to keep
working
and all the top players are working
really really hard
including the players playing in the
match sometimes players also don't show
the full uh breadth of their knowledge
they choose to go for something offbeat
on purpose for example ding against Yan
the previous game he went for something
uh simple he he wanted to take uh for
the game to take this course and he
surely could have played something more
concrete some more or something more
preparation based but sometimes you know
the simply the approach of going for a
slow game it gives you better a better
winning winning chance than than
throwing out a novelty on move 35 so
sometimes you maybe have that normal
team of 35 but you choose not to do it
so it's often a question you know how
much prep can improve your
and okay we have to discuss the stuff
because F4 was a cool move Bishop D6 was
really
um really not an obvious choice and a
lot of action on the board as uh 21
minutes on move 22. that's that's it's
quite something
moved there are four Bishop D6 my
Rook going
his ideas of trying to get to that Rook
because after Rook D5
you don't have another move I could
continue putting pressure perhaps with
Bishop C4
there's also an exchange sock with
Knight takes F4 and Rook takes F4 that
he might be banking on now that's my
Blitz out C3
4 Rook has four Bishop B5 let's make the
moves on the board
Rook D3
so here
hits the queen so you have to take Rook
takes I don't have to take Bishop yeah
yeah sorry sorry oh you mean in this
position yeah you could take with a rook
yeah and then I have to take I have some
uh rookie five you have even Queenie
five Queen G5
oh my gosh this is crazy
wait in this position does white have
some insane tactic
what a position
I'm lummox there's even you have to
consider you have to consider them a
bishop takes G6 by the way
and after HG I think you might have a CD
Bishop F4 Bishop F6
now if you play
now Bishop G6 threatens made on H7 if
you play FG then there's Queen takes G6
maybe black has to play F5 I don't know
but this gets even crazier
this bishop G6 this is incredible ding
blundered it by the way it's uh
it's quite clear that he missed this
because it's but apparently doesn't go
down
yeah
why not
uh it's okay FG I guess what else f f
five you said yeah maybe this no no F5
doesn't work I think just
CJ5 is ridiculous so uh FG I even take
Rook of 8 CD so HG what did you say
after 8G you said CD but I can play they
can go like CD
can I go see this and then I thought
rookie rookie oh
Bishop F6 Queen he won Queen he won and
queen E3 and then you go back and but
then I have Rook D Rook C8 and no it's
not so simple yeah
not so simple
unbelievable lines here white threaten's
mate but black and force a queen trade
first you drag The Rook away then you
force the queen trade and apparently
it's a drawn end game because chess is a
draw and we live happily ever after and
very simple lines here easy to follow
and Daniel it's really important to make
sure that white falls back with the Rook
because if you trade first then the line
that you showed us about an hour ago
would become a reality let's say you go
Queen E3 instead of giving attack then
that checkmate with the rook and the
bishop combining to come on AJ this
would be game over uh these are some
incredible tactics that we're seeing a
big moment after Bishop D6 I have one
question before we go deeper into these
crazy lines are we sure that after C3
black can't fall back simply with the
Rook to D5 my first instinct was attack
that Rick with Bishop C4 but then I
realized that you got Rook D2 creating
your own counter play but perhaps Bishop
to E4 might just be very dangerous for
black Rook D2 is the only Square I can
at least trade on B7 and maybe even push
F5 and it looks like things are going
completely out of control for black
there
Rook D5 allows all sorts of
possibilities uh I am absolutely
convinced that Knight takes a four is uh
is the idea it's also a very beautiful
one and the only reason it's not
immediately great is because there is
this crazy Bishop G6 which he missed of
course because although you do see the
possibility of Rooker 4 I Rooker 4 was
tempting but after Bishop E5 it it would
still take you some time to figure out
Bishop G6
um being the the point uh so well I
think this is what we are about to see
Jan is also a very sharp tactician this
is Jan's bread and butter and he has
enough time so I am absolutely convinced
that Jan will find this Rooker 4 Bishop
G6 idea but the position that's uh going
to ensue this AG
cdcd position
that is uh yeah that that is a lot of
fun and we have to still see what
happens because you don't have to return
the exchange there you could still try
to be greedy and play on
the game yeah
just for maybe for newer players if I
may interject really quickly Bishop
takes F4 the idea for black is Rook
takes F4 and a lot of people might say
but isn't white up in exchange yes white
is up in exchange but first of all black
has a pawn black will have another one
after he grabs C3 and black is complete
control over the dark squares basically
this Pawn shell guarantees King safety
and Black's Bishop coupled with the two
pawns guarantee full compensation at the
least uh for for the exchange the Jan
will not go for this with 100 certainty
that is why we are looking for
Alternatives um and that is why Rook
takes F4 is is juicier here reflect
takes than white is up an entire minor
piece that's why black has to take on E5
first
oh and you know both players they're uh
they're so good at calculation uh I mean
we were we're making a case for ding to
being a good positional player but in
fact he is also a tremendous calculator
and here both of them you know they have
The Showdown of uh this is really like
this kind of stuff is this it is this
your typical calculation slash slash
tactical battle and uh this is really
cool I expect both players
to go very deep here because this
position is possible to calculate uh you
know to enormous depth and I expect them
to you know to play uh find all these
best moves
and yes it's a very interesting time
scramble in coming here with the tactics
happening one after the other
yeah
spending quite a bit of time he's down
to 33 minutes a dingler in about 21
minutes on the clock a big moment here
we're expecting an exchange sacrifice
after Jan decides to pursue that Rook on
D4 with the move C3 and even if the
players do calculate the lines which
will show that they will it's all about
evaluating and understanding what the
position at the end of the line will be
and while Ian goes into a think tank it
is a critical moment he will take his
time here we're going to take this time
to go
into a shot break and we'll be right
back
big moment in game seven as we have been
calling it uh your move a niche on the
board C3 was played and we're seeing a
sacrifice Knight F4 the only move as you
said to keep the game alive and the
complications that are about to happen
this is heating up and both players are
down to about 25 minutes on the clock
the clocks are Level the positions going
absolutely crazy Knight f4 on the board
the line that we saw we have to show our
chat one more time and what is the
ultimate evaluation after the
complications
go take it away Daniel you are um
you are the prophet what's going to
happen so to reiterate Bishop F4 is the
obvious move but they're black sacks The
Exchange and black has full compensation
we think that nepo will play Rook takes
F4 now ding will recapture on E5 and
this is the critical moment now you
might look at this and say well I don't
get it white can just take the Rook with
a pawn no but then black recaptures on
F4 why it's attack Fizzles out black is
up two pawns so we found an incredible
idea here with the move Bishop takes G6
a Desperado comic Causeway sacrifice
there's only one idea to open the H file
you're also threatening made on H7 if
black takes to the H Pawn only now do
you take the Rook on D4 what's the
critical difference why is the H file
important well it's because of the move
Bishop F6 if you add a black pawn to H7
there is nothing if you remove it there
is a mate threat on h8 which is
completely Unstoppable black and try to
throw some pieces at white but white is
just gonna sidestep the checks uh and
Checkmate but that is still not the end
of the story because because after H
takes G6 C takes D4 we think that this
position will likely be reached and we
think that Ding will refrain from
capturing on uh F4 I've already
forgotten a niche uh or Tanya what move
we came up with here D I think it was I
think CD rookie five but after CD it's
also possible to not go to go because
you could just go Bishop F6 Bishop six
group of six and you can claim an
exchange but you have to be very careful
with white because if you defuse the
attack the E and D pawns they can just
storm down the board and it'll be very
very dangerous and after a rook H4 this
is a very very famous situation when you
try to Checkmate on the H file there is
this famous classical game
it's a it's embarrassing that I don't
remember the names of the players that I
think it was in the time of Keras might
have been Smith's love might have been
made
you play Bishop except for what
whoa dear oh dear this is uh so ugly oh
but
yeah it's so ugly for white because
these two Bishops and the two Pawns
oh it's even better because now I can
demonstrate my point even more this is
really resembling that classical game
and that is really famous so in that
game black had like three heavy pieces
on the H file and white white had three
Behavior pieces on the H file and black
had a bishop and the Queen on the long
diagonal and there was nothing white
could do
it's a very very famous classical game
but Jan Shirley remembers as well it's
uh it's a big uh it's a big Soviet cesco
kind of thing so it's a very very yeah
very dangerous position for white here
because the attack on the king side
without dartsburg Bishop with black
having the entire controlled diagonal
it's doomed to fail and he knows it
it's
it's never some tricky moments here
right we're surprised with Bishop F4 but
this last move Rook H4 there's a clear
threat you're hitting the 87 Pawn if it
advances then there are all these
sacrifices on G6 which makes the E6
spawn super weak and I think that would
be actually a very bad position for
black let's say eight five here you go
Bishop G6 fg6 Queen E6 and it looks
busted for black in that position
actually so you can't allow this to
happen the E5 Bishop is hanging
everything looking good for white but if
H5 is not a move after Rook H4 there's a
direct threat how are you countering it
will you push the F Pawn getting the
queen to defend eight seven is that the
idea but that was what I was trying to
suggest I don't think the Rook H7 is a
threat in fact yep although ding uh
counters that as well it's not a massive
threat but uh now Turkish seven root xd3
is probably the follow-up so you can't
even take the pawn and so I think I mean
I love this
um this kind of exchange sacrifices I
love the fact that black got rid of all
the pieces around the king the knights
and the Bishops all the stuff is gone
and uh only the Rooks and the queen I
think this attack is doomed to fail and
in the long term
these two pawns E and F Pawns combined
with the bishop there worth more than
the Rook end
I think we see a takeover here uh in
this game and I'm curious as what to
what Jan uh young missed because I don't
think he went for this on purpose I
think he must have missed Bishop takes
G6 shot simply he must have missed it
because he must that the devil was safe
that one was safe for for white if you
and this is far from from that and this
is definitely not promising for white
it's it's a plan B a plan C or a plan D
in fact it's just really not what you
want
now if I were to take the Devil's
Advocate approach here I think Bishop E4
might be an option to consider for right
trying to at least disarm the
coordination of Black's Bishops and the
the depressing thing in you should I'm
totally with you here is that even in
the event of a trade okay even if black
has one Bishop left the dark squared
Bishop is so strong it dominates over
the whole board White's got these tender
pawns on the queen side Black's
coordination is great I think
dynamically the position is probably
equal closer to equal than to anything
else so in the time pressure absolutely
anything can happen Tanya who are you
leaning toward here
yeah I mean there's definitely a
turnaround here that we're seeing right
with a ding being under pressure for the
most part of the game and now he
sacrificed The Exchange he's got these
Central pawns he can be looking at
getting an initiative but I like Yan's
approach here he's made the move Bishop
E4 trying to trade off the light Squad
Bishop now if the Bishops were to be
traded off I think I quite like white
you can jump in with the Rook from H4
recapture put pressure on E5 I don't see
the pawns advancing very easily to make
the most of those extra pawns I would
prefer White
thing was to decide to actually avoid
the trade let's say a bishop move it's
kind of hard to imagine that because 87
is still weak let's say Bishop A6 Rook
87 and I'm still trying to think where
is the initiative how do the pawns go
forward so even though it looks and I
see the eval Bar says ding is doing
great I still feel I would prefer white
there are still some questions to be
answered for Ding and the clock
situation getting tricky as well well
it's always been tricky but now super
tricky because both players down to 20
minutes
I prefer Whitetail
what about Japanese well I I think it's
a little bit concrete I think I um have
to diffuse the initiative that you have
so well the most ambitious approach here
is to keep the Bishops of course that's
what I was kind of hoping um to do I'm
thinking Bishop Basics maybe even Bishop
C8 because after Bishop C8
uh let's say you take on H7 and this is
definitely something that Ding is
contemplating
um let's make the moves on the board I
can play
I can I should prevent Bishop takes G6
so I can play Bishop G7 and now I opened
up the idea of E5 which is why I like
the bishop C8 move
and here okay if you return the exchange
with Rook G7 you'll probably be worse so
this is not a way to bail out but if you
don't
um the the point I was making before I
think still holds I uh with the bishop
alone I control your two heavy pieces
and if you try to bring more uh fuel to
the fire there's no fuel left pretty
much here so I I think that this is
looking pretty
promising for black
and again maybe I'm too influenced by
the classical game I mean this is just
um it's something like it was such a for
me it was such a big example because as
a kid I was always into these attacks on
the king side I was obsessed with trying
to Checkmate on the H file and for me it
was so remarkable to see that game
unfortunately I have bad memory for
names so I recall the games but not the
the names and the years but I think it
was something along the lines of Kerry
Smith's law for their contemporaries and
um it was left such an impression on me
that the fact that this bishop alone can
control the rook and the Queen and when
white spent like a bunch of moves
bringing the other Rook across like just
had to put the second Queen so like
let's say Bishop 7 Queen E5 Mustang 25
there's nothing you can ever do and um
that left such an impression on me that
I kind of I'm biased to liking this
position for black
but of course uh indeed the material is
uh in White's favor so it could still go
either way especially as the H7 Pawn is
uh hanging but ding decided to just
trade the Bishops and keep the h-pawn um
intact
yeah I was gonna say the ding ding has
sort of an affinity for and has shown an
affinity for Simplicity especially in
time pressure for keeping things
clarified especially in regards to his
King safety so Bishop takes E4 might not
be the top engine move but I think it
makes his resulting position easier to
play and even if it's a little bit less
glamorous with only one Bishop
um and maybe just a minuscule uh tiny
objective Edge for white I really think
that in the time pressure in a Blitz
game I would probably choose black here
because White's Rooks just don't have
any purchase in the center there's no
weaknesses to attack you drop the bishop
back to G7 you're also controlling the
only open file what's ironic is that
black is only one rook and yet it's
doing arguably more than both of White's
Rooks combined at the time being I think
ding is kind of chilling here with his
King perfectly safe this can go either
way it could end in a draw I absolutely
have no idea what's gonna happen the
next five or six moves are going to be
really important
yeah wow I love it thing is chilling
yeah but look at the clock situation
he's done to 15 minutes and looking at
him he doesn't look like he's having a
great time chilling right now but
definitely he's managed to he's managed
to neutralize uh all that attack and
this position Daniel you're mentioning
that it's hard to put pressure on
Black's weaknesses but the one thing
that comes to mind is that c Pawn which
was a long way back created in the
opening as a as a weakness a long-term
weakness let's say right now you've got
to do something about your Bishop you
have to fall back with the bishop Bishop
G7 is a move that comes to mind maybe
there is a more active Squad yes sorry
uh I'd like just to point out just so we
don't jump over this
I think it's a huge deal
that we traded Bishops it's a huge deal
we traded Bishops because it's one thing
to be exchanged down having the bishop
pair and it's a completely different
story being exchanged down without the
bishop pair so I really want to point
out that you know uh we don't change the
topic here we don't talk about Ai and
you know and our favorite streamers
which really pause here for a second
because I am personally I feel uh I feel
very disturbed that the other Bishop has
left the board because now I sense a
huge huge long-term danger for for black
because if I ever get to trade your Rook
somehow with queen of three Rook D1 or
something like this
um I will be up in exchange and
um I think trading the light Square
Bishops for black was a very responsible
decision and it better works out because
if it won't uh they will only have
himself to blame because I think it's
it's really a very big deal when you
have the bishop pair your dominant
exchange you really want to hang on to
it it's a it's a very important asset
it was such a difficult decision right
because you keep the Bishops on the
board but you lose that eight seven pawn
and then to evaluate the consequences of
having the bishop pair we're losing a
very important Pawn in your position is
a very difficult decision to make
especially with the time situation that
thing is in he did decide to forego the
bishop pair keeps that eight seven Pawn
alive and no retreat with the bishop as
was what something that I was looking at
but instead a more active approach makes
the move Rook D5 taking advantage of the
fact that C4 doesn't work because after
C4 you will have an intermediate check
with the bishop on D4 and everything is
still under control so C4 would be a bad
idea but Anish you're pointing out
further attack on the f file targeting
that F7 weakness so it's Rook F1 uh a
move with perhaps the idea of maybe even
dropping back with the other Rook to E3
to F3 trying to provoke more weaknesses
by black
yeah I think white has to consolidate I
think White's issue right now is that
indeed there is a little like if I had
Queen F3 and G3 let's say I would I
would already be chilling but I think
the problem is that I'm a little bit
clumsy with the white pieces right now
uh the queen is out of Play If I go G3
the queen has to guard the H2 Pawn if I
go G3 the queen will be even more out of
play so I have to try and regroup my
pieces so that's why ding keeps the
bishop on E5 that's why it was crucial
to keep the bishop there on the diagonal
Bishop F4 or Rook D5 where the moves um
they were that were the better ones than
the one like Bishop G7 or Bishop F6 so
uh ding is doing the right thing keeping
the the bishop on E5 and Jan uh should
indeed very carefully uh try to regroup
without blundering any pawn in the
process because with the material essays
you don't want to lose one more Pawn
with with white because if you uh if you
have a rook for a bishop on the pawn you
are rapid material in an end game if
it's two Pawns in an end game already uh
it's not the case so you have to be very
careful don't blunder
and try to regroup perhaps Rook F1
serves that purpose other moves that
come to mind maybe like Rook 4 it's so
but you should also be aware of a move
like C4 somewhere so you know lots lots
of things to to consider uh but if Yan
manages to carefully regroup
and there is a lot of potential in his
position because long term if everything
gets Consolidated like the position is
only balanced because of um the dynamic
factors like if we make Rook of one and
you play let's say Bishop G7 you'll just
see the bar uh just go all the way up
because of but even even without okay
let's say Rook of one your uh you go
Bishop G7 and I make let's say queen of
Queen F3
uh we should still see the bar uh really
liking white uh because I I still think
that it's positioned like this okay the
bar doesn't like to have three probably
because it's uh because of rookie 6 of
course but in general I still think that
black should be very careful here
because if I get my Rook e to E1 and
Rook to G1
let's make this moves like rookie E1 H5
and Rook D1 for example
but let me do H5 sorry I did not do the
deliberately H5 actually stops that idea
said here Rook D1 looks a whole lot
better no I think if we get a position
like this and then I get to to trade The
Rook I should uh I should be much better
with white although the bar actually is
uh the bar keeps finding of course why
is someone coordinated that bar keeps
finding all kinds of uh moves like
between A5 25 all sorts of jumps of
course are there
um but I do think that uh of course if
you trade the the Rooks then um and you
can bring the queen back to the center
or black will be uh in big trouble that
said ding realizes that as well and so
he will he will try to cause as much as
many problems too wide as possible and
uh try try to yeah keep all this uh wide
spawn weaknesses keep keep them in check
the C3 Pawn especially especially the C3
Pawn is always it's always a weakness
and if you lose that pawn the bishop
gets the D4 square if you push it
forward the bishop also gets the D4
Square so that's a small issue why it
has
wow and young makes a move that I wasn't
uh expecting he comes back with the Rook
to the H file so once again renewing the
threat of Rook 87 and you just point out
the obvious that the time Advantage is
now completely gone well just more or
less gone uh the clocks are pretty level
but still a lot of moves to be made Rook
H4 played rookette Seven is a real
threat do you parry it with H5
I don't see why not and I'm I'm
seriously wondering what nepo's
follow-up is after age five now Anish
pointed out very astutely earlier that
Rook takes H7 is a lot less of a threat
than it seems because you have the Kara
Smith Loft scenario where you play Rook
H7 congratulations you what we want to
meddle for capturing the H Pawn what's
your follow-up in fact the Queen's
overextended so black and sees control
of the D file perhaps and start some
tactical Shenanigans with Rook D1 in
fact I mean if White's not careful white
could lose this in like three moves uh
but ding again he likes Clarity he likes
to play with an abundance of caution
especially in time pressure so I
wouldn't blame him for playing H5
quickly but the fact that he's not moved
yet the fact that he's taking now a
minute on his move means that he's at
least aware of the possibility of
leading the pawn on H7 a niche what's he
about to do okay 26 is just concrete I
mean it's also a rook H7 Rook D1 it's
there's a concrete issue for white and
black is very safe so young Mr Smooth
Young's idea was he thought H5 is forced
and then uh he is hoping to bring the
queen back he wants to bring the queen
as I told you he wants to bring the
queen to F3 somehow so he tries to
replace the the you know one uh Defender
by the other one so Rook a little bit
lower ranked so he's like okay you know
I'm the queen I'm calling the Rook so
please uh Swatch this dog of mine on H2
I will bring the queen out but um Jan
sometimes he has that I noticed it also
in our last tournament I played against
with him in WR rapid sometimes he he
does this uh he had the same with um
with good cash he thinks when he attacks
something the opponent has to defend
and there he missed the same kind of
thing that Rook H4 is actually not a big
threat and ding is excited because Queen
D6 is very very juicy in the six Rook H7
Rook D1 Queen is indeed overextended and
uh rukeshwar only further on coordinates
White's pieces and he starts looking
really good for white
I'm ready to you know
I'm ready to bet on Queen D6 excited if
I you know when I see an excited
exciting ding I am you know it yeah you
know when it seems exciting it's an
exciting thing and he goes for it great
colonies Queen D6 on the board doesn't
care about Rook at seven Rook T1 perhaps
just wins on the spot in fact after Rook
at seven so some big problems there you
can't really pick up the pawn doesn't
win on the spot or is Perpetual the best
that you'll have in that case
there must be more uh there must be more
the king is so exposed I have also I
have still uh a move because you don't
have a threat so I can collect on C3
with the bishop and then bring the
bishop to D4 and set up a slow Checkmate
and yeah I have to say this position it
starts looking extremely extremely
unpleasant for white
I think we are entering a territory uh
of like
position already is Advantage for black
slowly taking shape and I think you can
definitely speak of uh ding completely
taking over the initiative at this point
absolutely and I think it's worth
I I think it's worth showing Rook takes
H7 Rook doing how bad that is because
Jan completely just ignored the fact
that Rook H7 again this is the critical
Insight white has no follow-up move
because the bishop dominates The Rook
Rook D1 and suddenly White's King is all
alone White's Queen can't come to the
rescue you drop H7 if you take D1 this
doesn't even need to be calculated and
the sort of Russian Schoolboy approach
probably not the best move uh is Bishop
takes C3 I know the evil bar drops but
already this is enough to make white
rule this line out because white is
losing in the queen end game there's
probably some way to mate here uh some
sort of yeah first chicken you don't
have a chance to win for Queen and game
yeah this is
to shift his Queen over to E3 abandoning
the idea set up by his last move big
shout out by the way to Fabi who will be
commentating uh the subsequent rounds
and is in the chat we're all on the edge
of our seats here Jan is losing the
threat of the game how bad is this
23 is good though he's trying to
um he's trying to bring the queen back
um and again it's it's sort of fleeting
uh somewhat in the moment the black
black has a lot of coordination now and
he should try to utilize it somehow and
if White's magically is able to play G3
bring the Rook back from H2O but it's
getting harder and harder look on H4 is
really misplaced D3 Rook D3 is at some
point an idea now Bishop 25 is hanging
but you can you know you can retract it
to F6 you could start with King G7
Bishop F6 after G3 and then Rook D3 so
black has lots of counter play here
um but long term it's still unclear uh
what is happening here so it's all up to
concrete moves here that uh
remember
what is what are you so excited about
let's see yes maybe because Queen X6 is
also somewhat in the air
yeah
okay H5 good move just shutting the Rook
down completely and saying in your face
Rook on H4 and nepo now can't even bring
it back to E4 because it drops H2
there's just a sense in which white is
failing to consolidate and Anish your
earlier move G3 maybe it's worth
throwing that move in just because you
need the services of your Rook The Rook
can't just chill on H4 it can't be a
passive spectator you need it back in
the center uh to protect uh you're the
king and the D file
and the reason I like H5 is that after
G3 potentially Bishop F6 Rook going away
at some point I can throw in the movie
H4 when I'll be the one attacking and
that will be the crucial opening of
White's uh inside crucial weakening of
white king size the bishop of black star
Square Bishop is a tremendous piece here
in this in this position it was serving
a defensive purpose also can serve an
attacking purpose yeah really liking
Black's coordination here and the move
H5 uh as well I think
um yeah Dingus I think is in a very good
shape right now the clock situation is
also fixing itself and for the first
time ding has an opportunity to actually
finally take uh control of the match and
perhaps perhaps think about taking the
lead uh for for a change
well that's that would be huge going
into the second half winning a game with
black but it's still quite far away but
we can also sense it in Yan he does look
a little bit worried about the way
things have turned out after the
complications that we just saw in the
last few moves G3 on the board and now
it's time for ding to be in driving seat
he's the one who can be looking at
attack Bishop F6 H4 The Rook can jump to
D3 hitting that queen that pawn on G3
can suddenly become a big Target well
the first big question is going to be
for Yan to decide where do you move your
rook and it might be critical because
after Bishop F6 you might have to start
putting pressure on the C5 Pawn not
allowing Black's Rook into activity
Bishop F6 Rook C4 might be the way to go
yeah but the problem with that and that
might very well be uh that that looks to
me indeed like the only move probably
but the problem with the Rook on C4 is
that well
it's very constrained
um you know it it is looking at stuff
laterally but uh on the C file it has no
squares it's staring at its uh black
spawn in the front and it's on Pawn in
the back so broken C4 is uh is a very
clumsy well it's it sits there firmly
but uh very inactively meanwhile Black's
control of the D file and especially the
difference between the king safety now
look black has got four pawns on the
king side and the King on G7 potentially
it's it's just Untouchable whereas white
is missing some of the pawns from the
king's shelter the F Pawn is gone
and so uh the king safety becomes a
factor Rooks are
um rook's activity is also a factor I I
really like ding's position but white
position is still reasonably robust so
uh converting this will not be easy
and Bishop F6 is played Bishop F6 is
played I would add really quickly for
newer players Rook F4 might seem very
tempting let's hit the bishop but notice
the alignment of the queen and the
bishop Bishop slides over to G5 this is
called a pin if the Rook moves you lose
your queen so you're gonna end up having
to give away your exchange remember that
black currently has one Pawn for the
exchange and if white goes rookie four
Tanya this is what you were implying
after Rook D3 Black's idea Works to
Perfection because you drop C3 when you
drop C3 you also drop your control over
the D4 Square which would be a perfect
perfect parking spot 24-hour parking for
the black bishop and this is where the
position starts to crumble so nepo you
know you can sense it he knows he's
losing the thread he has to tread
carefully he is walking on hot coals
right now even if objectively the
position is closer to equality than it
is to a black Advantage practically
these next 10 moves are going to be
brutally difficult for Yan
24 7 365 a year is what that Bishop on
D4 will be uh will be but he can't allow
that he can't let lose of the control of
that D4 Central Square he does move the
Rook to C4 so eyeing that C5 Pawn still
tying down that black Rook on D5 now
guys big moment is it time to start
pushing that H Pawn does he try to seize
the initiative now with H4
well I think
[Music]
I'm I'm not sure I'm not sure um it's a
big question here at this uh this moment
is the time is the time to start opening
up White's position and go active or is
it still a time to slowly and slightly
improve your position because I'm
wondering what is White's next move here
with the Rook stack on C4 I'm
considering moves like King G7
reinforcing the bishop on f167 always
good uh always good idea to move one
file up the board with the king from j27
It's Always guarding a little bit more
squares it avoids a check on the back
rank so King G7 is is a is a move comes
to mind also at some point maybe now
maybe after seven maybe the move A5 just
in case you know preventing B4
also comes to mind so maybe you want to
First improve the position see uh
see what happens how wide reacts because
I'm not sure why it has many useful
movies G2 well it's barely useful if
anything the king can also get checked
from D2 with the Rook from D5 with the
queen Maybe not immediately but
somewhere so I'm not sure I can just
improve the position uh so I don't think
rushing it with H4 is needed to though
H4 is probably not a bad move and
certainly as an idea it's one of Black's
main ideas in this position but the
question is how to execute it and
intuitively I would go for King G7 but
there is a choice here Bishop G5 also a
move and I should mention seven and a
half minutes ding has 10 moves to make
nepo is nine no increment you get an
hour on move 40. this is move 31. so
ding has less than a minute per move
Tanya
yeah seven minutes on the clock no
increment a big decision will he go all
out with H4 is this the moment that Ding
really tries to break open Jan's King
position or will he keep all the threats
on the board as a niche you're pointing
out make a slow move make calm move just
improve your position slowly simply ask
Jan the question what's your next move
and it's not a question that's going to
be easy for Yan to answer as well we're
just 12 minutes on the clock and it just
feels like deja vu but we're talking
about different colors because this was
exactly Yan when he played the move Rook
to E1 a few moves back keeping the
pressure keeping the attack going and
asking ding the questions but now the
tables have turned and I see ding he's
about to reach out he's about to make a
move he's got to do it quick I wanna see
H4 on the board
I don't expect that to happen
um
I'm not sure after H4 GTX H4 let's say
if you have a concrete follow-up
um
here and I would certainly
um also Queen F4 is a theme is a theme
as well and I would wonder
um yeah I would in general Wonder after
after H4 ghu you know always always what
exactly the follow-up is I assume that
there is some uh you could also just say
it's a weakening of white skin and not
not need a follow-up but
um yeah even H4 it also doesn't change
the nature of the position very much
it's not like after H4 you're you know
immediately fireworks begin uh it's all
pretty slow and I have to say ding
taking more and more time uh he his
position is extremely easy to play uh
you know you'll have a lot of safe moves
it's on the board H4 he goes for it and
now of course the Eternal question what
happens if Yan actually captures it Ian
sits back he knows it's a big moment he
needs to decide what to do well you
can't leave the G3 Pawn right there
right because ding has a clear threat
Queen F4 is a little intermittent so
that that could be strong
other than that of course you don't want
to allow 8G and Rook D3 that would that
would be a collapse but I think you'll
either taking an H4 right away or you're
going for a queen F4 and knowing Jan
he's gonna go for Queen oh he just goes
AJ he goes GH4 and I was going to ask
you a question what happens if black
continues the pressure with the move
like Bishop E5 get that Bishop back on
the diagonal and now start threatening
H2 is that I remove that thing can be
considering here
okay certainly every active move at this
point uh it becomes a consideration you
could also as I mentioned earlier played
played slow Rook H5 is also an idea try
to regain the h-pawn queen E7 doing it
this way is also possible you could you
could now switch to making slow use for
moves but Bishop E5 is certainly
important don't forget at some point
though about H5 right now it doesn't
work but at some point don't don't allow
H5 opening up the G file
or for white so you have to be a little
bit aware of that keep an eye on the H5
Square
but it should be less than five minutes
you need to make a choice yeah he has to
make a choice because uh at some point
when you have too little time even the
position is easy to play you need you
need the time to execute the moves and
sometimes white can ask you some some
tricky question and you'll need a few
seconds to
respond correctly so link should
accelerate a bit but of a lot of a lot
of options here
I wish he wishes he had a little bit
more time to figure it all out
accurately
there's also tactics Bishop E5 If you
defend with rookie two there's Bishop
takes H2 and the black girl could
basically infiltrate but again this
can't be emphasized enough suddenly
nepo's up seven minutes he doesn't have
a lot of time ding has four minutes now
to make nine more moves so if the
position sharpens up imagine it's moved
36 and you have a minute without
increment this this is an incredibly
dangerous strategy by ding who has to
ensure that the position basically
remains calm that he maintains the
status quo every ticking second is
making a situation more dire he's trying
to calculate it out he thinks this
moment is incredibly crucial will he go
Bishop E5 he can still make a neutral
move like King G7 but Anish your point
is very well taken white could use the H
fund as a battering ram and the last
thing you want if you're ding is for the
g-file to open up now three and a half
minutes on the clock Jesus Jesus this is
incredibly little time and there's so
many moves to make my God there's eight
moves and he only left over two minutes
that's no increment that is if you
divide uh it by it in 30 second
increment time control this is basically
zero see it's basically down to
increment and that is even harder
because you have to space your time well
while with increment the increment does
it for you so dink make a move Bishop E5
whatever just make a move oh my God
minute you gotta do something play
something you're you've got eight more
moves to go he still hasn't played three
minutes and four seconds on the clock
his time spending today is a little bit
off uh also the remember Rook 88 the
moment somehow he's a bit Frozen maybe
the the pressure detention and the
responsibility of the match is getting
to him he's unable to make a move at
this point it's psychological he's just
Frozen nine moves he's got nine moves in
less than two and a half minutes now
this is an average of like 10 seconds of
move he's gonna have to basically Blitz
out the last five moves of the time
control nepo is an expert I've haven't
played him in classical but in Blitz
nepo is so good at causing problems when
you are in time pressure ding needs to
move he's Frozen he's got less than two
and a half minutes on the clock can't
take it I'm about to jump out of my seat
oh my God
he's Frozen he's literally Frozen right
now he's gonna have to Bull it out
so that he actually is able to even make
the moves physically he's Frozen guys
it's it's it's a it's attention
oh my gosh his body is frozen
he's
gotta go he's gotta go
oh my gosh she's gonna have to play like
Luke happens I've seen it happen to
people they freeze he's Frozen
yeah
he's not even close to moving I'm in a
30. does he forget that noise he broke
he broke he malfunctions my God ding
broke
a little bit of 30. this is this is an
online game this is where you think that
somebody's disconnected
he's got less than a minute he might
physically be unable to make nine moves
even if he has to moves in two seconds
he's got a minute 15 now
okay you are a hyperbole player you know
that in 15 seconds you can make like 50
moves not in a position like this though
it's true that is true and not a good
move not a good most though and you need
to be able to remove and mouse and all
that
less than a minute he's under a minute
he's thinking there's no increments
oh
my God
Daniel and finally 45 seconds
God
oh my God it's also a bad 25 seconds
guys eight moves left to reach time
control 45 seconds no increment probably
nuts completely nuts he's gonna make it
he's gonna make the moves but I don't if
he maintains anything other than a
completely lost position by move 40 this
will be the biggest Miracle of the match
I'm not sure he's gonna make the moves I
think he's just kind of broke like
literally like something in him broke
and uh I I've seen like people's I've
had experiences when my opponents fell
asleep uh sometimes literally sometimes
they froze I had Blitz game with Vichy
when he just froze and just forgot to
make a move and
Boris girlfriend once fell asleep
against me
it just happens sometimes that you just
sort of space out collapse and you're
gone
finish the sticks here are just so high
for Ding and it's it's a kind of
position where he's the one who's trying
to put pressure he has to he has to make
this happen somehow at least reach time
control Rook D2 is the move of choice is
janapanishi will he start playing on
ding's clock now is that something that
he's thinking about or does he still
need to be careful about the move that
he chooses not go too fast not go to
rash will it be critical for Yan uh to
take it slow or will he start playing
against things time now Daniel
well there's two things you first of all
you have to avoid a repetition or
Perpetual check and don't try to flag
ding take your time take 15 seconds per
move ding is going to play instantly
here and ding is blundering Rook to D3
backwards allowing Queen takes C5 is
that just over no guys this is this is
like when uh sort of
because in chess is not a physical sport
uh so usually you don't see the
collapses but this is like what a
collapse looks like just sort of just
fall it takes C5 that's a lost end game
it's like when you have to go rookie one
check you just fell down it's just you
just the fact that he was about to take
the lead and he saw the he felt the
opportunity and the tension all of that
I think I think the tension got to him
and he just literally collapsed
yeah he and I know him he's a normal
player he's a sensible rational guy
everything is is fine but he just in
this game you know everything got to him
and he just broke
and it's just crazy he just couldn't
make a move literally he couldn't move
and then well now he's also collapsing
because of course he has also no time
and he just wanders the C5 pawn and for
no compensation and he'll just uh
just lose the pawn in the game now
because also after 25 the problem is
also the queen trade is imminent yeah
that's the problem and the weakness of
why is
no it's crazy I mean I've I've never
expected to see something like this that
you just you just literally collapse at
the chessboard
one expects attention and the pressure
to be
BL championship match and of course that
is there but the very best in the world
they bring out their best in these
clutch moments and we've seen ding do
that at events after event but this just
shows how unique the world championship
is the emotions that the players feel
during this match is nothing like what
they experience in other tournaments uh
and Anish is this a reflection of how
important match experience is when
you're playing the World Championship
yeah I guess uh
pressure gets to everyone but
um probably if you want to become a
world champion
you have to
yeah you you know you have to handle it
and uh
it seems that it's it's just really
difficult
and you know everything was going really
well for ding it was he was at the at
the peak of uh of this match everything
was as good as ever this has never been
better before in fact the score was
equal and here he just was about to
potentially get an opportunity and take
the lead turn things around and maybe
the prospect of that combined with the
pressure of all these days and just
suddenly suddenly he had the total
meltdown and I'm a little bit puzzled by
Yan
why is Young think ah Rook d123 that's
the thing Rook d123 is what that what I
forgot about keeping the queens and that
is what Giannis um thinking about and
why he is also he doesn't exhibit the
signs of someone who thinks the position
is winning
no and he has to make sure he's not
getting mated there and he's being a
professional he's taking his time he is
forcing himself to calculate Queen takes
C5 Rook D1 because the last thing you
want to do is blunder a mate in one and
finally Yan he decides on it Queen takes
C5 is played ding goes all in throws his
chips into the center of the table but
this is not gonna work I think Queen D3
if I'm not mistaken can be simply met
with Rook F2 and White's Rooks surround
the king in a warm blanket ding is gonna
lose this is insane I mean King G7 all
he had to do was keep the tension for a
couple more moves he handled the most
difficult part of the game so well and
then froze when the hard work was over
and nepo
wow
yeah and I think we see that happen the
collapses they happen usually after the
difficult moments when everything is
already uh done and uh and then your
body can relax
um
but you can't just yet and in these
moments of tension you know um that's
how that's also how young collapsed uh
in
the game he lost but yeah this is really
uh this is really incredible and now
Rook F2 Rook F2 just is it defends and
attacks at the same time and it's all
over you know the position was so there
were so many moves that were safe for
black that he could make and keep the
game going we could just play King G7
after age also it does not need to go H4
just just why did he even play H4 that
was I mean why do you need to do this
you could just like King G7 A5 any move
it's really remarkable it's just it just
completely lost his mind and just
totally frozen there isn't a single
check there isn't a single idea he has
to play bishop d8 and then Rook D4 of
Queen C8 anything wins that's it ding's
not even gonna make the moves he's got
just four more moves I have more moves
to make no that's it that's game
positions completely lost you're done in
exchange you're down upon there's no
attack against White's King and they
looked like they've handled the most
difficult part and then just immediately
after now he's down to 20 seconds the
completely lost he finally makes the
move King G7 a move that you had
mentioned a while ago Anish said it's
made of ironic yeah
but I mean a meltdown of Epic
Proportions total meltdown total
meltdown Rook cf4 resigns he literally
will resign he won't even try to make
move 40.
is so good at this just keeping it super
precise he felt it he felt that moment
he knew he was putting pressure on the
clock he knew that Ding wasn't coping
with the Prussia and he made the most of
it the Rooks have been doubled up
there's a there's a problem on the file
a big problem the Bishops attacked the
F7 Pawn is falling there's no way to
fight it this looks like game over six
seconds
and that's it makes a move
on resigns
wow
I was uh that was a heartbreaking finish
that what just happened we see the
players analyzing the Jana pamishi wins
after putting pressure ding fighting it
out and just when it looked like it was
turning around in complete clutch
position situation lapses freezes
doesn't make a move and Jan bounces on
the opportunity with Precision taking
the lead once again in the world
championship match going into the
halfway mark with a one point lead Anish
what a game this was
yeah I mean it's not how you usually
collapse in a normal game usually you
collapse when you are under pressure
let's say on the board but sometimes the
pressure can be overboard
and we see how the mental pressure
broke ding not the position on the board
at all the position was safe easy to
play
and everything was completely fine and
under control but you know the
anticipation the pressure of the match
the fact that he was about to take the
lead
that just broken suddenly
but it did that's the thing what my
coaches sometimes was saying one of my
coaches he was saying that you know it's
not about the position on the board when
you collapse if your brain stops working
you'll you'll find a way to lose it and
the position was completely unusable for
a player of the dings level of course
but when your brain says I'm out of here
I don't want to handle it I cannot
handle it it's too much for me
then somehow you you know yeah you just
collapse and on the board you will find
a way to lose but it was of course lost
mentally this is this game it is just
crazy
this game really showed the
psychological part of the world
championship match is what it takes from
the players to be here and then to
perform uh in these very difficult
moments I've never seen I've never seen
the world's best players the top 10
players what we witnessed today who is
really watching in action what goes on
internally thing literally froze in time
in those seconds in a position where he
was the one who was commanding the
initiative what a fight this was start
to finish uh Daniel you've got to take
us through all the big moments in this
one I'm I'm still letting this sink in
this is an absolutely unbelievable five
minutes this world championship match
just gets crazier and crazier and
crazier and obviously blunders at the
top are not unprecedented but I'll get
into that later let's break down a
couple of the important moments now
nothing be tokens uh the the insanity uh
with which this game ended ding he
started with a surprise it was a
relatively mild surprise it was a French
an opening that he had played before Jan
didn't expect it reverted to a very safe
continuation called the tarash ding
absolutely no problems out of the
opening he handles it well his
preparation is excellent this move
Knight C6 uh he follows the game of one
of Gary gasparov's early coaches and
gets a great position uh into the Early
Middle game the trouble starts when he
blitzes out Knight F6 ironically the
move he made the fastest was the one
that caused him the most problems a
niche we were surprised that he didn't
play G6 and once nepo got his pieces
into the center the attack really
started in earnest
Daniel you know I struggle to uh look at
this game because I think it's it
doesn't it is not what we should be
looking at like
it has nothing to do with the game or
the position uh honestly like if it's
the trouble started trouble was over I
mean he could lose any position at that
point uh
that's what he found
okay yeah he was working he was working
but at some point he stopped working and
he I mean as in another thing he stopped
to work but he just broke
and I he played the normal uh good game
of of his level the top top level chess
and everything was okay and you know it
was where it started
and at this moment
at this moment he's just here he broke
and for some reason
and the sort of the manifestation of the
way he broke his was H4 and then rooted
two and uh
and then Rook D3 the blunder but it
didn't happen on the like I mean he I'm
sure he cannot even say what he thought
what he missed he will not be able to
say it because how can we put it in
words he basically mentally broke and uh
then you know like sometimes when your
brain switches off
like I think he doesn't even he will not
even be able to understand what happened
it's like when you I don't drink but
I've heard stories of people who do they
say I don't know you know I have a bump
here in my head I don't remember what
happened yesterday night like I don't
know um I I'm missing a tooth you know I
uh and you can of course construct the
story what happened basically you just
got drunk and okay then some things
happened yeah but uh this is the same I
mean we can look at the position on the
board but I don't think it's relevant I
think it's completely relevant what
happened in the game I think it was just
that at some point he collapsed and and
if you think now back to the last match
of Jan the way he was collapsing the
blunder she was making and the fact that
Magnus doesn't just just said I had
enough I don't want to play this
tournament anymore
and that that is there's probably a
reason behind it it's probably extremely
difficult to to be there simply at the
when Stakes are so high and Magnus just
said you know I've had enough I'm gone
you guys do it now and we see how how
the guys are struggling with that as
well because it's just extremely tense
and um well somehow he found a way to
lose this position but there were really
no questions I mean in this position
where he played H4
he is completely in control white has no
next move white has no thread you can
play King G7 or you can play A5 you can
actually play H4 and Bishop P5 which you
pointed out which is also quite quite
good but it's just
you can do many many things but uh
no okay he'll he lost the pawn on the
king side lost the pawn on the queen
size and let white coordinate and uh win
but basically yes he just that also the
way he spent his time he just
of course he had to distribute his time
he had like initially seven minutes
before his collapse over like nine moves
which was more than a minute per which
was slightly less than a minute per move
which is more than enough so he could
Pace out his time if you are a rational
player you realize okay it's like 40 40
seconds per move so after four seconds
you make a move instead he just spent
like
six minutes out of seven that's
completely ridiculous and okay just uh
total meltdown incredible
press conference this is such a
difficult moment for thing and it all
happened here I I'm still getting over
it because
again I've just never seen anything like
this in the Chess World of course there
are difficult moments and there are all
these time pressure scrambles that we
see but here we literally saw a thing
not being able to physically make a move
and he was always reaching out trying to
make a move but then he just pulled back
these hesitations these dots creeping in
and it just shows the psychological
battle that chess is he played H4 so
quickly and then after the pawn was
grabbed
it was like a frozen time and again just
never ever experienced anything like
that and it really shows this we're
talking about the world number two and
the world number three fighting this
matchup it's just it's just unbelievable
how difficult this stage is and I'm not
talking about the chess I'm talking
about exactly what it takes the mental
toll that it takes from the players
yeah because you know when she when he
was thinking and he was spending all
this time so the body language was also
not a body language of a player so how
the body language is in such situation
so as the time drops down you get more
and more excited you get closer to the
board you're you start to uh you know
your body like you you get close to the
board physically then your hand starts
to rise this is how it happens I've I
mean I've played a lot of players I've
played Blitz rapid I play classical in
time scramble this is what happens
what happened to dingdo was that he
suddenly went back into this pose
and this never happens when you are
going down on the clock you never go
back into this is not the pose this is
like
he just like he's you know you have a
certain algorithm in which you play you
have like a process and you always
follow that and he just kind of broke so
his algorithm broke his body language
broke and like it was it was just very
odd he froze in a very weird way and uh
just couldn't make a move and I've seen
it happen a lot but of course not in the
game uh like that not in this way
sometimes players just freeze and uh
well it's a big moment for for Ding and
we will see we'll see what uh what he'll
say after that
yeah just incredible I mean he wasn't
even close to making a move and we were
waiting and waiting what is he gonna
find he's he must make a move there's no
increment and then he gets below three
minutes and then he get gets below two
minutes and like you said she's not even
close to making a move we're gonna find
out more in the press conference we're
going straight to it yes Daniel let's
head to estan and hear it from the
players
she
uh my first question uh goes to
um dink
uh the most critical moment was on move
32 you had eight moves
still to make until the time control
increment and you made Rook to D2 and
then Rook to D3 inaccurate moves can you
give us an idea what happened at that
moment
yeah in the previous move we play group
C first and then I realized maybe I was
slightly worse after that and I cannot
go Rook D3 you can take on C5 and then
he has Rook CA check
maybe he's he's going to be better so I
want to take immediate attention so I
play H4 with idea take Rook D2 but I
totally Miss rookie to look D1 kg2 so
after GH I started to think again and I
couldn't find any way to make the games
to continue the other game he told me
that I can play Bishop D4 after Queen C5
maybe it's a chance to draw
oh you have spent a lot of time for this
move Rook to D2
is there a chance that you just somehow
disconnected and you just lose the
control on time
it takes it before it's very hard to
play in a tree
if I just wait here then you'll probably
look F1 then my position hopeless
so
couldn't find the right continuation
during the game
all right thank you
um and also yeah this very same moment
can you please verbalize what have you
felt at that moment when you saw this
Rook to D2 Rook to D3 inaccurate moves
uh played
way before then time increment
uh well
I'd say the game like the whole game was
extremely extremely sharp extremely
tense and uh I don't know I felt like I
should be doing quite fine
uh but after with four suddenly Bishop
D6 is superb move and uh
I mean I didn't really see what to do
so maybe there were like
a lot of sharp lines but I couldn't like
figure out what do I do
so I went to this position like it
slightly worse surely
and I mean this poem for exchange here
because okay my rocks placed poorly
and also I was like very skeptical about
my position in case if black would play
Bishop F6 uh instead of Queen D6 because
after rookie seven Queen D6 is like um
it looks ugly my Rook is stuck on H7
it's never an attack and my king is weak
uh so it was really really concerned at
this point but after let's say uh Queen
to six at least okay I could play Queen
E3 Rook C4 and you stabilize a little so
I shouldn't be I shouldn't be losing
them by force or something yeah
and after it was like suddenly age four
uh
I guess like us all uh reasons to be
ambitious here uh but uh
I would say it would be quite
quite normal to make some solid moves
like I don't know King G7 just rookie
five repeat once or twice and then okay
uh
pass the time trouble because black has
endless most basically yes sir like
could never be worse because of my king
is so weak and the file is controlled
uh but uh yeah after H4 I felt like
maybe it becomes like sharp and you know
let's say three results instead of two
and then after now D3
uh okay my presentation was to grab on
C5 immediately but an exhibition before
check uh you know she takes D4 in case
Rook D1 checking YouTube Queen F4
and I wasn't sure if uh
if there is uh if there is the win for
me because okay my king is so exposed
and there is like Queen of 180 and so on
so perhaps I mean okay I always have a
draw but maybe
uh but maybe a black is also doing fine
yeah I mean they can hold the draw so
after Bishop D4 I can at least try
attribution before I can at least try
like taking on before with the queen
and played Rooks against the queen with
the PC Pawn passage but yeah it should
be should be probably about equality but
yeah would remain very complex
and after he yeah you know suddenly
played
uh Rook the frequency five Rook uh check
yeah I felt like he completely lost the
trace and here I think
uh my king is super safe because okay C4
it controls all sorts of checks from
from G4 E4 and yeah basically white I
think because we didn't get this point
and also like a Time trouble became
really severe
right um thank you very much
um
I think um we know that you
French defense was one of your favorite
openings in your childhood
uh and let's say at the beginning of
your chess career but you have not
played since 2013 according to the
database uh you played it here strictly
because of the Practical reasons or
there were some sort of sentimental
reasons to refer to that
um
actually during the walk with Richard
back in Hangzhou I told him I may play
French defense but it's a half joke half
series
and when he take it seriously so today
he's taking insisted me I can try this
French defense to surprise my opponents
and I take advice I prepared a lot
for the screen
uh yeah
the opening phrase was yeah on
yeah the opening was was the one which I
played in my childhood but now it's the
theory has developed a lot of a lot of
so it's not the old French it can be
calling some new French idea operations
yeah
so but I played the game I think
uh not so bad but
in the end I I messed up things
right and we sell on cameras that when
Jan played the first move you took some
some time to make your decision uh was
that your decision that you you made on
made on on board or you were already
prepared you made decisions decision
earlier it's just uh you will go in
through some process of course I
prepared a lot for this game with the
French defense I just want to remember
record a lot of things then play this
move
[Music]
this was not a complete surprise to you
and you demonstrated to be prepared in
the opening but pretty much how would
you have rated possibility of having to
face French defense in this match
uh I'd say
I'd say French defense is completely
okay yes so it's nothing wrong
the perhaps the only problem is that uh
I mean if uh White like expects French
defense it's uh uh it could be tricky
yes so what I you know why it could dig
somewhere deeply and uh
uh try to test back in some critical
lines
and Knight D2 is of course not a
critical line but 92
I also felt this is like some safe very
safe small Edge for white
uh very small but very safe yes so I
mean uh you will get crazy if you like
prepare like
uh each and every opening for uh every
games so I had an idea so in case of the
French I'll play uh
let's say my stuff which I uh used to
play a lot I think online and we had
like
uh I would say a few games against uh
Sasha grishuk in this line yeah so if
like we've uh
successes from from both sides at some
point yes so
uh but I always thought that this like
Bishop e796 should be somewhat worse for
black and uh I was slightly surprised
because I think black is trying to be
uh more let's say more principle in this
line like up to 95 some Bishop C5 ideas
or uh even this is Bishop B7 at least I
can recall Sasha played something like
this against me uh so yeah I guess uh it
feels quite quite a smart choice like
uh and uh I mean
probably every every site got what what
he wanted
all right thank you
um I think uh there was the moment on
movie tonight to say six if I may ask
about that so
um a move you ruined upon structure with
that move uh on the queen side can you
explain the advantages of this move why
you went to that decision
forgot my preparation I guess I remember
it was the part of my preparation just
end up
take take castle castle or something
like this
have you planned some potential kingside
attack with that with Bishop he said no
my preparation basically ends there oh
okay
um all right
and also like every day you come here
with the surprise Series in the opening
is that the part of your general
strategy for the match to be
unpredictable in the openings
I can only say that this French defense
alone
until now is only for this so This
drones
yeah
I don't know if what will happen next
all right thank you and my last question
to Yan and then I'll give the floor to
journalists Ian gave us the impression
of being a little bit tired today
uh could you rest well yesterday on the
rest day or were you still affected by
the things how it went on game six
uh no I wouldn't say I felt like
extremely tried let's say after this day
normally you're not too tired but since
we got we have like sofa in the
uh in the launch I've felt like I got to
make some use of this
all right
um
thank you my client with chess.com my
question is for Grandmaster Jan
napamishi uh going into this match when
you saw that the time control had no
increment until move 60. this is the
first day where I think it really
mattered a lot did you think that was an
advantage for you this time control
uh no idea so it could be like a vice
versa situation yeah like uh but uh
I'd say
uh maybe I play slightly more games with
this time control recently uh but I
don't think it should make some
difference yeah so I guess
today like I was sort of luckier to to
see this H4 uh and like
suddenly suddenly black has to make some
strong moves to keep up the initiative
otherwise it's just
um like a free porn from me and which is
also important it opens some like nice
files for for us like GF and 10 H5
and yeah my king would go to H3 yeah so
in some lines so I guess uh yeah as it
happened of course it uh it gave me some
favor
uh but I wouldn't
I know I wouldn't rely on this too much
thanks thank you do we have more
questions
from press
uh please feel free to come forward we
have microphones on both sides Mike
let's go second question
uh still free on the palm machine now
that we're halfway through the match I
know you said going into the match you
wanted to play perhaps a little truer to
your style in this match uh do you feel
like now that we're halfway through you
can say that you've done so to this
point
well uh
depends on what you supposed to to be
closer to my style yeah so like no draws
or something yeah or what
uh okay I just try to try to play chess
yeah but I mean
uh whatever you do like however you play
you get to play well
I mean and then the like the game is not
one end in the opening here or right
after the opening normally yes so it's
still
everything to be decided later so well
I just tried to play yeah like
uh
I don't think I can like I can even try
to specify the results are so completely
different than from 2021 do you feel
different given the fact that we have
such a seesaw battle
well
um
I mean okay clearly I didn't expect
anything like this
are so like lots of like
a lot of punches yeah
to both to both sides but uh
uh yeah I guess no one actually expected
here so perhaps
uh perhaps
people for for at least for some time
wouldn't like stated okay classical
chess is dead or something yeah so it it
can still I mean okay uh I'm not sure if
it's fun but it's yeah it's it's
exciting for sure thanks
um yeah and as you just quoted this are
you following social media while you're
playing
I'm trying to like see as as little as
possible yeah so if I occasionally
something I immediately close everything
yeah
close my browser and
plug off from from the electricity
what about you I think how how often do
you use
social media to get some information not
so much
all right do you have more questions
please
talk from Detroit Hamburg Germany a
question for ding Lorraine
um you gave the impression that you
decide very spontaneously what to play
in every game what opening is this
impression correct
that you decided right before the game
you give us the impression that you are
making spontaneous decisions yeah just
make up the decisions on the board this
is the impression we have is that right
or that you choose the opening right
before the game not not very much in
advance
okay for this game I just prepared
yesterday for this game
thank you
uh we can get ready with the press for
questions and now I think it's time for
Twitter segment please just say you can
bring us the questions
hello Jesse February here my first
question was for ding what were you
going to play if young played Knight G4
instead of Rook ae1 I'm sorry if Jan had
addressed this line already H5
H5 okay did you consider Rook text D3
there was uh
and then was H5 in somewhere in that
line yeah
okay
uh the next question is for both of you
from hurry what about your playing style
separates you from other top players
uh yeah let's go first with you
oh I have no I have no idea
I think
uh
uh I think uh okay there are like some
players whom you I mean if you're given
just the game about the names yeah you
couldn't you wouldn't recognize like
this select player
uh so I think from some point it applies
to me equally uh so it's
like pretty much trying to find the
strongest moves
and uh like as much as
like my opponent lets me play I try to
play
so
I I don't know of course like there are
like people more attacking less
attacking or something yeah but uh I
wasn't
I mean I wouldn't uh
say there is like a major difference
nowadays
so you repeat the question for things
all right what about your playing style
separates you from other top players
I don't know which kind of print style
for me uh
I'm praying now because I'm explaining
different like they have different moves
and different ideas I don't know which
place they are
okay that's fine we can go to the next
question
all right the next question is from Jack
Den did you and your team know about the
1987 game between Cooper doc I am no no
okay you answered so fast that's so
suspicious
no no uh okay do you have more questions
in
from Twitter yeah I have one this one uh
Jan what was going through your mind
when ding's time was running low near
the end
uh
okay surely I didn't mind
uh because
yeah it's
um I mean
you really you really
want to see this too often yeah like uh
so literally like a few seconds worth of
humus
uh but I guess at this point uh then
when he was below a minute he already
sort of like got driven by the wrong
ideas so
uh it was even more important to me than
I still have like five minutes or
something here to to calculate lines if
necessary
so I yeah of course it was like a major
factor but at this point I thought its
position and it's already it was already
like uh more or less decided
all right thank you thank you Jesse
as in Twitter we have one more question
from press please go ahead yeah
Germany my question is
today that was the first time you had
not a big time Advantage at a certain
time it moved 30 around 30.
um how did you cope with this time
pressure you had only 10 minutes for for
more than 10 minutes for for 10 moves
was it a problem for you or is it when
it was a tense position so
yeah I guess it would be a problem uh it
really became a pro become a problem but
normally you know if your position like
poor like extra Town 20 minutes won't
help
and also today it was like loads of
lines to calculate for for all the game
yes so like basically
I mean yeah the language which was
mentioned for example my G4 H5 here here
like some some different modes also so I
mean
I was trying to calculate as much as
possible I like using both my time and
my opponent's time
uh uh probably I didn't succeed
as
at some point I got even worse but
uh I guess once again I guess after I
played like Rook C4 and it was at least
my my next few moves are very very
simple yeah so it was
I wouldn't call this a very very bad
time trouble but yeah for sure for sure
it's a good term either way
thank you for answering the questions do
we have more questions from press
this can be our last question if
everyone anyone is willing to ask
I would like to to thank players to come
here and answer our questions because
it's very difficult and we understand
this and we we appreciate very much
I guess we have no more questions
tomorrow is the rest day another rest
day and I wish our players to have a
good rest day so thank you
foreign
moving into the second half of the match
we've already had five decisive games in
the world championship this has never
happened before the match just gets
crazier
taking the lead in the match for the
third time with his win in game seven it
wasn't as much about the result but the
way it happened what we saw today is
something that nobody has witnessed so
clearly so apparently a breakdown by a
player on the board as happened with
ding today we saw his emotions in the
press conference Daniel this world
championship it just keeps getting
crazier
it keeps getting crazier indeed Tanya I
just cannot believe this scoreboard
neither team can stop the other white
wins and then white wins and then white
wins and again we thought there was no
way ding he's in the driver's seat he
does the hard work he's pressing nepo's
collapsing he's tilted and then the
unthinkable happens and nepo wins again
with the white pieces and yet again for
the third time he holds uh a one point
lead Tanya I mean the the this moment
that we just witnessed it's going to be
chewed up uh and it's going to be
discussed this way in Seven Ways to
Sunday by commentators and armchair
generals and I think our job as
commentators is not to pile on obviously
ding is fully aware of what just
happened uh there is no rational
explanation for it and this is the
direct product of the unbelievable
pressure that attends to the world
championship match and that attends the
feeling that you are on the cusp of
scoring what would be a huge Victory
with the black pieces and would have
really put him I think uh in an
incredible spot to potentially win the
championship and the only other thing
that I wanted to say uh Tanya is that
blunders massive blunders and World
Championship matches are not uncommon
there have been blunders really from the
start of the world championship matches
to the end steinit shigoran game 23 1892
Maiden 2 blundered Carlson Anand as
recently as 2014 there was that moment
in game six where Magnus Carlson
basically blundered two pawns and Anon
blundered it as well it was a blind spot
to Paul of Mr made into against uh
kramnik in 2006 and lost that game so
it's not the blunders that are
unprecedented but a meltdown like this
on the clock Anish I can't remember
anything like that
yeah the manifestations of meltdowns are
always very different indeed you
mentioned countless examples of the
world championship matches they're also
some in other tournaments but this was a
very spectacular
um one because usually you you see a
move that's a blunder but here we didn't
see any move we just saw a player Frozen
and his thinking process afterwards it
was completely irrational as he uh of
course we'll understand once here comes
down as well and as you mentioned indeed
it's it's um it happens and it will only
make ding's comeback greater if he is to
come back from this because
this is a hard one to swallow and uh he
has a rest day I think it's a painful
day ahead but I think it's a needed one
I think it's good to to recover because
if they say time heals and it is true
not no better medicine than having a bit
of time you need to process what
happened and uh if you look purely at
the scoreboard without delving into the
details the situation is not so bad
because so far a lot of white winds is
only down at one point and the next game
ding is playing with the white pieces
and okay it's in insane as that might
sound another way to win perhaps
yeah
well ding's done it twice already in the
match right he has one and he strikes
back and then he equalizes the score we
saw it in the press conference and and I
feel like that's the those are the
Dynamics that we've been seeing from the
start of the day a very vulnerable
emotional thing and today watching it we
were all we were all watching it in
complete silence you could see the pain
you could see the Heartbreak he of
course is fully aware of what just
happened and Niche before the Press gone
you mentioned it yourself it had very
little to do with the game it had very
little to do with the French it had very
little to do with the middle game
pressure that Yan found with his ideas
but the Meltdown that we saw now Jan on
the other hand looked confident and got
it as he always is
ding visibly emotional going forward
into the second half how do you see this
playing being played out and Daniel what
does ding need to do to come back
psychologically
well the pain cannot be sugar coated I
think that's first first and foremost
he's gonna wake up tomorrow and he's
gonna toss and turn in his bed and and
you know the broken record of these last
15 minutes of the game is going to keep
spinning around and spinning around uh
in his mind and I think his job and the
job of those around him Richard report
his parents whoever is with him at the
tournament is just to put him in a calm
emotional state he has to use tomorrow
to do the objective things like get some
sleep get some exercise try to put as
much distance as anisha's saying between
what just happened here uh in this match
after the tournament you can work with
your team on figuring out what happens
and how to avoid it in future matches
right now there's no time for any of
that there's no time for deep
investigation or an autopsy you have to
forget this ever happens you have to
move on and you have to realize that you
have surmounted this lead already twice
you need to roll out another good piece
of preparation with the white pieces in
the next game and obviously in situation
is where you're going lower on the clock
you just have to force yourself to move
something tells me that this is not
going to happen again this match and
something tells me that so far ding has
really surpassed everyone's expectations
when it comes to handling his emotions
something tells me that John is not
going to have an easy ride just because
he won this game
yes sir Danny I absolutely agree and you
know sort of the wins that have been
changing they're now blowing against the
ding and Jan he he's aware of that but
just like when you are facing an
opponent who is down on the clock and
defends very well you know there's a
style of Alexander grishock
you know they are constantly having
these games and playing against them is
always very hard the same way here I
feel if ding will resist now
this might this might come as a surprise
for Yan who expects that you know he he
feels okay I punched him he came back I
punched him he came back I punched him
you know and he gave maybe this was
Jan's last punch as well maybe this was
maybe Jan put all his strength into the
sponge and now he thinks okay that's it
are you are you down
but maybe it's enough for ding to get up
just maybe it's not for him to get up
and then uh it will turn out the Tian no
longer has the strength to punch again
so we'll never know we'll never know uh
looking forward to see the rest of this
match Tanya
anyways really nicely put well and if
there is one player in the world who's
capable of coming back from this what we
just witnessed it is dingler and he has
done it so far in the match after a
tough start after a tough game stuff
losses he strikes right back yeah's job
is far from over he does lead the match
a very critical rest day coming up at a
very crucial point for both these
players for ding to get over to distance
himself from what just has happened and
for Yan as well to calm his Nas to go
into the second half of the event we
will be back with game eight action
which starts on Thursday and I have to
ask you Anish we've been talking about
how important it is for ding to get this
rest for his emotional state but what
about Yan what does it mean for him to
once again take the lead in the match
have a rest day break away from it and
then to go into the second half that's a
huge confidence boost for Yan
of course on the surface uh everything
is is looking very good for Yan
but uh
especially recently we've had so many
matches due to all these new tournaments
the online tournaments that have match
formats I've observed a lot more matches
than I've observed before and I've
noticed that the psychology of matches
is far more nuanced than what I used to
think before
um
we've seen so many different scenarios
in these in all the tour events and uh
it's there there are so many unexpected
unpredictable psychological moments and
when some someone looks like you know is
everything's going right suddenly you
see the player is doubting himself so on
the surface it does look very good for
Yan it does look very good for Yan of
course there is a rest day so Shannon
pointed out nothing is better than to
have a rest day after a win
but there is a lot of Chess to be played
and uh if ding manages to pull himself
together
once again perhaps just one last time
well and he'll show up and bounce back
the momentum will switch back so this
this is all this is until until the next
twin you know it's uh the one who who
made the last move seems to be in a
commanding position but if ding is to
come back from this you know he will
retake the initiative so this is really
hard to predict but for today and for
tomorrow it is Jan's moment to celebrate
Jan will sleep much better than dink
this night in the next one
um but you know we have got lots of lots
of Chess still to be played here
we most certainly will Yan will sleep
amazing the food today will taste
amazing it'll be the best food that
Giannis had thus far in Astana no matter
where he goes which restaurant he goes
to uh it's gonna be a five-star dinner
for him but to Echo anisha's Point
listen the score is four to three it's
the best of 14 match you need to reach
seven and a half points so very
important for ding not only to play
objectively but to realize that a draw
in the next game is not the end of the
match right if he wants to play a little
bit more solidly if nepo holds with
black okay it's four and a half three
and a half the way that this match is
gone yes white has won a lot of games
but ding could have just as easily won a
game here with the black and given how
much opening preparation he has up his
sleeve and how many surprises we've seen
from him what's to say that he doesn't
have another one of these nasty
Surprises with the black pieces maybe
akarokan so most important thing for
ding is to play the position not to tell
himself I have to win the next game or
the match is over because that's how you
lose the second game in a row and that's
how you actually end up losing the match
we will see if Tanya if he is up to the
task I can't wait
yeah same Daniel and a dingler
with the white pieces
match is anything but predictable we've
had five decisive games and going into
the second half yeah once again takes
the lead with one point what a day of
Chess we had it's been absolutely
fantastic commentating with you Daniel
and Anish and before we wrap up Anish
I'm going to throw the floor open to you
one more time just because of the
emotions we experience today because of
the chess we start we saw today your
final thoughts on game seven
thank you Tony I'm too emotionally
invested in this in this match uh you
know I I need to I feel I need to
recover I don't know how the players
feel but I just need to crash here uh
you know it's it's too much for me uh I
can't I just can't uh unfortunately
tomorrow is the rest day I need to
recover from this this is just uh yeah
this is heavy heavy stuff yeah yeah it
was very emotional and the fact that
Anish giri is speechless that's not
something that happens often Daniel I'll
tweet something Tanya I'll tweet
something it's fine
absolutely a niche they're just finally
throwing it to Daniel uh Daniel what did
you think about the action that we
witnessed today
well first of all a huge thank you to
you Tanya and and to you Anish it's been
honestly such a blast commentating these
games
um not a lot of things I would do at 5am
uh my time but uh this these hours just
go by so quickly I feel like I've got
courtside seats to the action and I've
got uh you know amazing players helping
me understand what's going on so it's uh
really the at the honor of a lifetime
and uh I mean it's the second half of
the world championship match I feel like
we've already had the action of a
lifetime and we still have an entire
second half to go uh so this match I
think it's safe to say has over
fulfilled everybody's expectations you
know there were ups and downs is this
going to be interesting are we just
going to have a draw Fest like we've had
the last couple of world championship
matches no no no no and no these are two
players who are putting everything on
the line This is a legitimate world
championship title and yes it's always
going to be bad that Magnus Carlson
isn't playing but I think it's safe to
say that these players are making a name
for themselves as the legitimate title
contenders and uh this second half is
going to be uh one of the most epic in
history
of Chess and and just uh just again the
kind of emotions that we felt from the
players never seen anything like it and
a big shout out to our chat who's been
with us through the ride feeling it all
alongside us that there is a lot more
chance to be played and as we head into
the second half of the match we will be
back with gaming we're gonna leave you
with the biggest moment from game seven
here we go clocks have started and Jan
goes with one E4 will we see a surprise
from ding I don't think so
and he goes with the French unbelievable
ding's predictability this is the one
thing that you think you can hang your
hat on ding has been trying to push the
envelope all match long
John is calling things Bluff and we're
about to find out what he has in store
for us looks like this is the start of a
very fascinating middle game that we're
about to see Jan doesn't want to waste
our time yeah wow huge threat singular
and has to make 22 moves in 35 minutes
on the clock
your move a niche on the board and we're
seeing a sacrifice Knight F4 the only
move as you said to keep the game alive
it's frozen guys it's it's it's it's
attention
his body is frozen
all he had to do was keep the tension
for a couple more moves he handled the
most difficult part of the game so well
and then froze when hard work was over
and nepo wow looks like a mobile six
seconds
that's it makes a move
on resigns I was uh that was a
heartbreaking finish that what just
happened we see the players analyzing
the Yana palmishi wins
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign